TO OUR INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THAT ECONOMIC POWER AND
RESILIENCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
TOURISM INDUSTRY- WE DO HAVE-
TWO MEMBERS HERE ONE WILL BE
JOINING US AS A- HE HIS FLIGHT
WAS DELAYED- BUT I'M VERY
EXCITED TO HOLD MY FIRST
HEARING. FOR THIS COMMITTEE
WHICH AS YOU KNOW IS A VERY
LONG TITLE- BUT- THAT COMMITTEE
ON ARTS ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS
TOURISM AND INTERNET MEDIA.
BEFORE I BEGIN I JUST WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT IT
HAS BEEN A DEVASTATING TIME
ACROSS THE BOARD NOT ONLY FOR A
FAMILIES WHO'VE LOST LOVED ONES
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC- SO
MANY OF OUR INDUSTRIES BEING
IMPACTED FROM HEALTHCARE TO
EDUCATION. AND OF COURSE
EVERYTHING THAT IS RELATED TO
THIS COMMITTEE TOURISM A THEME
PARKS ARTS MUSEUMS AND SO WE
ARE GONNA. DO A LITTLE DEEP
DIVE BECAUSE WE'RE HERE TO
LISTEN TO YOU WE REALLY WANT TO
HEAR DETAILS WE WANT TO BE HERE
TO FIND OUT HOW W CAN HELP.
THAT BEING SAID I AM WE HAVE A
FEW HOUSEKEEPING- AND THEN WILL
HAVE COMMENTS FROM OUR SENATORS
AND OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER. DUE TO
THE CURRENT STAY AT HOME ORDER
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SCENE IN THIS HEARING
ROOM. AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CAPITOL BUILDINGWE HAVE
LIMITED PHYSICAL SPACE IN THIS
ROOM FOR PEOPLE TO WATCH AND
PER PARTICIPATE IN PERSON AND
STILL PRACTICE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE EIGHT. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THIS ROOM WE ARE IN ROOM
FOUR TWO OH TWO AND WE ARE
CONDUCTING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
WHICH AT THIS HEARING. AND
THANK YOU FOR ATTENDING AYE WE
HAVE MORE PEOPLE THAN I'VE SEEN
IN QUITE AWHILE- THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE THAT ARE HERE TODAY
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
STATEMENT DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SEGMENT OF THIS HEARING
YOU WILL BE ASKED TO RAISE YOUR
HAND AND APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. PLEASE FOLLOW THE
INSTRUCTIONS FROM THE SERGEANTS
I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. SUBSEQUENT
COMMENTERS PLEASE WAIT FOR
DIRECTIONS FROM THE SERGEANTS.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU ARE DONE OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEN
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER OPENING COMMENTS
TO OUR PARTICIPANTS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LET ME FIRST START BY
WELCOMING YOU- TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS COMMITTEE- I
ENJOYED WORKING WITH YOUR
PREDECESSOR BUT I KNOW LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
TAKE A CONVERSATION TO THE NEXT
LEVEL- AND THIS IS A COMMITTEE
THAT- INVOLVED SUBJECT MATTERS
THAT ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TO MY DISTRICT. EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THESE WORDS FROM ARTS
AND ENTERTAINMENT TO SPORTS TO
TOURISM TO INTERNET MEDIA ARE
THINGS THAT ARE REALLY KIND OF
CORE TO WHO WE ARE AS
CALIFORNIANS AND VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE WORK. THAT WE DO
HERE. THE SUBJECT OF TODAY'S
HEARING IS ONE THAT I AM VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT- I KNOW THAT
MY CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE HERE
AND LISTEN IN ON THIS. NO THAT
TOURISM. IS WHAT BROUGHT ME TO
MY CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO WHEN I
WAS TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD.
TWENTY NINE YEARS AGO- IT'S WHY
I FELL IN LOVE WITH SAN
FRANCISCO WITH NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH OUR STATE. AND
THE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT I'M
HONORED TO REPRESENT- REPRESENT
SOME OF THE VERY TOP
DESTINATIONS NOT JUST IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT OUR
ENTIRE COUNTRY. AND I'D LIKE TO
SUGGEST SOME OF THE BEST PLACES
TO VISIT- CLEARLY DURING THIS
TIME PERIOD A PANDEMIC IN
RECESSION. THIS IS AN INDUSTRY
THAT HAS BEEN UTTERLY DECIMATED
AND- I'M HERE BECAUSE I WANT TO
HEAR EVERY IDEA. THAT IS OUT
THERE WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP
MOVE THINGS FORWARD. LET ME
ALSO SAY THIS WHICH IS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I DON'T THINK THAT
THE STATE. HAS PLAYED ENOUGH OF
A ROLE IN WORKING WITH TOURISM
TO MOVE FARTHER INDUSTRY AND I
KNOW THAT ARCHER WOMAN. AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WE'RE VERY COMMITTED. TO REALLY
REVITALIZING THIS CONVERSATION
AND SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO BE
CREATIVE BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
A CHOICE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE.
THAT CALIFORNIA TOURISM-
CONTINUES TO THRIVE AND
CONTINUES TO LEAD SO WITH THAT
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION. HANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILL AND
SENATOR PAN. I THANK YOU CHAIR-
QUICK SILVA- BROTHER REPRESENTS
SACRAMENTO AND AS A MEMBER OF
THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON THE ARTS.
PLEASED TO JOIN YOU TODAY YOUR-
HEARING AND- YEAH WITH CODED WE
KNOW THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE-
ARE SUFFERING- VARIETY
DIFFERENT REASONS INCLUDING.
SOMETIMES MENTAL HEALTH AS
WELL- AND- THE ARTS AND OTHER
TYPES OF WAYS ENGAGEMENT
THROUGH ENTERTAINMENT AND
SPORTS- ARE WAYS THAT WE CAN
HELP- PROVIDE- POSITIVITY FOR
PEOPLE- REDUCE ISOLATION. AND
CERTAINLY- TOURISM IS A IS ALSO
PART OF THAT AS WELL SO- I KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT THESE ARE TO MY
DISTRICT AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING THIS
HEARING TOGETHER SO WE CAN HAVE
THIS VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE
SUPPORT- NOW THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS. AND ARTS
AND THE TOURISM THAT COMES WITH
IT AND OF COURSE OBVIOUSLY AS
AN ECONOMIC DRIVER AS WELL- BUT
AS WE TRY TO DEFEAT. COBIT
VIRUS. AND THAT WE WILL IF WE
CAN COME TOGETHER AS A COUNTRY
WITH A PROPER LEADERSHIP- THEN
WE CAN TRY TO BRING BACK THE-
THE JOBS AND ALSO THE JOY. THAT
COMES FROM THESE THINGS AS WELL
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR. SHARING THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN AND ALL JUST US
START OFF WITH. I AND YOU CAN
CONSIDER ME A CHEERLEADER FOR
CALIFORNIA LITERALLY I WAS
ACTUALLY A CHEERLEADER IN
JUNIOR HIGH. BUT BUT IN REALITY
WE NEED A CHEERLEADER FOR OUR
STATE BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THE INDUSTRIES YOU
REPRESENT ARE NOT ONLY HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO'S GONNA STAND UP.
AND FIGHT FOR THEM BUT THAT'S
GOING TO CHEER YOU ON BECAUSE
THAT'S THE WAY WE'RE GOING TO
GET DOORS OPEN. SO WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD ITH
EIGHT OVERVIEW FROM CALIFORNIA
TOURISM MARKETING PROGRAM AND
WE WILL INVITE CAROLINE. BUT
TED UP WHO IS THE PRESIDENT.
AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE OF EXECUTOR
OFFICER OF VISIT CALIFORNIA. WE
COULD START PLAYING MUSIC LIKE.
I'M SITTING HERE ABOUT HERE.
RIGHT WITH YOU SO MUCH RANDOM
CHAIR FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
INTERESTS AND CONGRATULATIONS
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR NEW
LEADERSHIP POSTS WE'RE THRILLED
TO HAVE YOU IN HERE YOU'RE A
GREAT CHAMPION AND- IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU AS SOMEONE MEMBER
TO- ALSO BEEN HIGHLY ENGAGE
WITH THE INDUSTRY AND REALLY
APPRECIATED ALL YOUR TIME IN
THE LAST YEAR AND HERE WE FIND
OURSELVES SO THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR. BEING PART OF SUCH AN
IMPORTANT MEETING AND- THIS IS
MY FIRST- IN PERSON APPEARANCE
FORMALLY SINCE MARCH SO- I'VE
DONE AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED ZOOM
SPEECHES CALLS INFO ALL DAY
LONG ON ZOOM SO- I I'M JUST SO
PLEASED TO BE HERE IN PERSON SO
THANK YOU FOR BEING BRAVE AND
TAKING THE TIME TO DO THIS-
WITH THEIR GREAT COMMITTEE
CONSULTING THEIR DATA MITCHELL-
SO ANYWAY THANKS- AND TODAY I
JUST WANT TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF TOURISM FOR FREE
ALL OF YOU IN THOSE LISTENING
AND- AND REALLY WHAT'S BEEN
LOST DUE TO COVE IT. AND HOW WE
AT THIS CALIFORNIA ARE PIVOTING
ON BEHALF OF THE INDUSTRY AND
SOME TRENDS SO FOR THOSE THAT
ARE A LITTLE LESS FAMILIAR WITH
VISIT CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT TO
START HERE WE'RE ACTUALLY THE
FIRST NON AGRICULTURAL
COMMODITY BOARD IN CALIFORNIA
FRANKLY THE NATION I'M PROBABLY
THE WORLD A FIVE A ONE C. SIX-
WITH SOME ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
INVESTORS USED TO BE TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND BUT- WE'VE SEEN SOME
WANING OBVIOUSLY. AND I DON'T
THINK WE'RE AT THE BOTTOM YET
BUT IT WAS ESTABLISHED TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO- AND THOSE
INVESTORS ARE REALLY SIT AT THE
TABLE AND HELP GUIDE US
STRATEGICALLY YOU CAN SEE ON
THE NEXT SLIDE THAT THE
INVESTORS INCLUDE EVERYONE FROM
RENTAL CRS TO HOTELS
RESTAURANTS RETAIL OF A SKI
OPERATIONS TRANSPORTATION- AND
ATTRACTIONS OF COURSE AND THEN
OTHER CATEGORIES THAT ARE VERY
MUCH PART OF OUR- TRAVEL.
ECOSYSTEM THESE BUSINESS AGREE
TO PAY AN S. VOLUNTARILY AND
THEY ACTUALLY HOLD A REFERENDUM
EVERY SIX YEARS TO RENEW. THAT
REFERENDUM WHICH JUST OCCURRED
LAST YEAR. I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT OUR BOARD LEADERSHIP I
REALLY WORK WITH THEM ON A
DAILY BASIS MANY ARE HERE TODAY
ALSO TO TESTIFY BUT SOME OF THE
GREATEST GLOBAL ICONS YOU CAN
SEE. IN THE WORLD OF
ENTERTAINMENT AND TOURISM ARE
HELPING AND INVESTING IN EVERY
DAY TO GUIDE THIS INCREDIBLE
ECONOMIC ENGINE. FOR CALIFORNIA
IN ADDITION TO OUR TRAVEL
INDUSTRY PARTNERS WE ACTUALLY
WORK IN CLOSE COLLABORATION
WITH MANY STATE AGENCIES SO I
JUST KIND OF THREW UP THIS
ECOSYSTEM IF YOU WILL OF HOW WE
WORK. AND COLLABORATE WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES THAT HAVE
YOU KNOW TOURISM IMPACTS OUR
PUBLIC POLICY. AND I ALSO SET
ON THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR'S-
INTER AGENCY INTERNATIONAL
COUNCIL ON OF COURSE WORK
CLOSELY. WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND NOW YOU KNOW SO
PLEASED TO HAVE YOUR LEADERSHIP
AS PART OF THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL- BUT OUR FIRST AND
FOREMOST ARE MISSION CRITICAL
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO DRIVE
DEMAND. AND TOP OF MIND
AWARENESS- TO BRING CONSUMERS
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD TO
CALIFORNIA- IN A VERY HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT SO. WE
PUT THIS TOGETHER JUST KINDA
INDICATE THAT WE SET VERY HIGH
UP IN THE FINAL YOU KNOW IF
CONSUMERS DON'T END UP IN THE
FINAL IN THE END UP IN NEVADA'S
FINAL OR FLORIDA'S FINAL. WE'VE
LOST THEM SO WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO GET THAT TOP OF MIND
AWARENESS- AND THEN WORK WITH
THE INDUSTRY AS PEOPLE START TO
CONSIDER CALIFORNIA NOT OTHER
DESTINATIONS. BUT IT'S REALLY
THE PEOPLE YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM TODAY THAT REPRESENT THAT
GOLDEN TRIANGLE OR THE
TRANSACTION WHEN OF THE VISITOR
DOLLARS COME INTO THE STATE AND
HAVE TO DELIVER ON OUR BRAND
PROMISE THAT WE'RE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH ALL THOSE
TWENTY THOUSAND PLUS
BUSINESSES. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW ACTUALLY THE
VISIT CALIFORNIA WAS BORN OUT
OF A CRISIS SO HERE WE ARE
AGAIN TALKING ABOUT CRISIS. IN
FACT IT HAPPENED OUT IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE LOMA PRIETA
EARTHQUAKE AS WELL AS THE
NORTHRIDGE. EARTHQUAKE NOT ONLY
DID IT SHATTER MUCH OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE- WE KNOW THAT
HERE. FOR REAL I FELT IT MYSELF
IN SACRAMENTO NOW I'M AGING
MYSELF. IN THE BAY AREA BUT- IT
IT SHATTERED THE IMAGE OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD- AND IT WAS A MEDIA.
CHALLENGED THE THAT THE
INDUSTRY COULD NOT REALLY-
RESPOND TO ALLOW WE HAD SOME
REAL INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES THE
MEDIA WAS REPORTING IT GLOBALLY
AS IF ALL OF CALIFORNIA HAD
IMPLODED- AND THAT WAS A WAKE
UP CALL TO THE INDUSTRY THAT
THEY REALLY NEEDED TO COME
TOGETHER TO. WORK
COLLABORATIVELY EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE COMPETITORS ON A
GLOBAL SCALE PARTICULARLY WHEN
IT COMES TO CRISIS AND NOW WE
FIND OURSELVES IN A- DUAL
CRISIS NOT ONLY COVE IT BUT OF
COURSE WE'VE HAD SEVERAL YOU
KNOW CONSECUTIVE YEARS OF
WILDFIRES WHERE THE INDUSTRY
HAS REALLY COME TOGETHER. AND
WE WORK WITH THE INDUSTRY ON
COMMUNICATIONS THE REALITY
VERSUS THE MEDIA NARRATIVE
THAT'S BEING SHOWN GLOBALLY-
AND COMMUNICATING DIRECTLY WITH
THE CONSUMER AS WELL. YOU CAN
SEE HERE THAT IT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WE'VE HAD TEN IT'S
CONSECUTIVE YEARS OF RECORD
GROWTH GENERATING JUST EVEN
FROM VISIT CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS
INCREMENTALLY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF SPENDING INTO THE
STATE'S ECONOMY. AND GENERATING
ABOUT TWELVE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE AND LOCAL TAX
REVENUE PRINCIPALLY FROM SALES
TAX REVENUE AND TRANSIT
OCCUPANCY TAX- AND VERY
IMPORTANTLY GENERATING ONE
POINT TWO MILLION JOBS DIRECTLY
IN TERRORISM NOT JUST. NOT
INDIRECTLY BUT DIRECTLY AS A
MATTER OF FACT- IN OUR WORLD
COUNTY THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
IT'S THEN WILL NUMBER ONE OR
TWO EMPLOYER GIVEN THE WAYNE OF
EXTRACTIVE INDUSTRIES IT IS
MISSION CRITICAL FOR OUR RURAL
AREAS- WERE MUCH OF OUR CRISIS
HAS YOU KNOW- BEEN EXPERIENCE
UP UNTIL THIS YEAR WITH COVERT-
TO GET THESE PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK. SO I'M JUST GOING TO TURN
TO COVERT NOW AND PROVIDE AN
UPDATE CERTAINLY CO THAT HAS
NOT BEEN KIND TO THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY AND WE
FELT THE IMPACTS IMMEDIATELY
YOU CAN SEE ON THE NEXT SLIDE
THE PRECIPITOUS DECLINE FROM
OUR TWENTY NINETEEN NUMBERS AT
A HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR. POINT
NINE BILLION- DOWN TO ARE
PROJECTED SIXTY SIX BILLION IN
VISITOR SPEND- IT'S ACTUALLY
BEEN NINE TIMES WORSE THAN NINE
ELEVEN AND THAT IS A MILESTONE
MARKER FOR ALL OF US IN THE
INDUSTRY OF HOW EPIC CRISIS CAN
GET AND YET. WE'RE EXPERIENCING
SOMETHING THAT'S NINE TIMES
GREATER. SO I YOU KNOW THE
UNFORTUNATE THING IS I CAN
REVEAL NOW THAT THE LATEST
RESEARCH FROM OXFORD ECONOMICS
SHOWS THE BAD SITUATION THAT
PRESENTED ITSELF IN MAY. IS
ACTUALLY GETTING WORSE- YOU CAN
SEE HERE FROM OUR TRAVEL
SPENDING FORECASTS FROM TOURISM
ECONOMICS THAT WERE NOT DUE TO
RECOVER. TO THOSE TWENTY
NINETEEN NUMBERS AND FOR FIVE
YEARS AND BASICALLY PUSHED US
BACK AN ENTIRE DECADE. AND THIS
IS FROM THE PERSPECTIVE AND THE
DATA ANALYTICS THAT WAS BASED
ON THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
VACCINE- AND ANOTHER ROUND OF
FEDERAL STIMULUS THAT IS STILL
UNDECIDED AT LEAST AS OF. TODAY
JUST FOR CONTEXT PRIOR TO COVE
IT OVER THE LAST DECADE LEISURE
AND HOSPITALITY JOB GROWTH HAS
FAR OUTPACED. OTHER SECTORS IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS BEEN- BRIGHT
SIDE AND VERY MUCH PART OF THE
GROWTH OF THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. BUT WITH CODED- YOU
CAN SEE IN THIS CHART THAT
NEARLY FOUR IN TEN OF ALL JOBS
LOST IN CALIFORNIA DURING THIS
PERIOD I'VE BEEN IN
HOSPITALITY. AND THE LEISURE
SECTOR AS A MATTER OF FACT OUR
CALCULUS WHEN WE WENT INTO THE
MAY TIME PERIOD WAS THAT THE
STATE WAS PROVIDING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS OF. VERY
CONSERVATIVELY ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS A
MONTH- ALMOST A BILLION DOLLARS
A MONTH BECAUSE OF THIS.
SUSTAIN JOB LOSS AS OPPOSED TO
WHAT IT WAS CREATING PRIOR TO
COPE WITH THESE NUMBERS DON'T
EVEN I WILL ACCOUNT FOR THE
LIVE RECENT LAKE. THAT DISNEY
OR THE RECENT ROUND OF JOB
REDUCTIONS AT THE AIRLINES- AND
ALSO NUMEROUS BUSINESSES AS YOU
ARE WELL AWARE HAVE SLID INTO
BANKRUPTCY GONE OUT OF BUSINESS
OR FRANKLY JUST HANGING ON BY A
THREAD. THE PANDEMIC HASHIT
CALIFORNIA'S TOURISM INDUSTRY
HARDER THAN OTHER STATES
PARTICULARLY IN OUR GATEWAY
URBAN CENTERS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA WAS THE
COUNTRY'S TOP TOURISM ECONOMY.
IT'S NOW AMONG THE WORST
PERFORMING ONLY FIVE STATES
HAVE LOST MORE VISITOR SPENDING
SINCE MARCH AS YOU CAN SEE HERE
WE ARE THE NUMBER ONE TRAVEL
DESTINATION AND SO WHEN WE ARE
HIT WE ARE HIT VERY HARD WE'RE
ACTUALLY FIVE TIMES THE SIZE OF
THE HAWAIIAN TOURISM ECONOMY AS
A MATTER OF CONTEXT AND SCALE.
OBVIOUSLY DISNEYLAND UNIVERSAL
STUDIOS AND OTHER ATTRACTIONS
STILL AWAIT A GREEN LIGHT FOR
SAFETY OPENING. AND THEN
ADDITION HOTELS HOPING TO
REGAIN SOME BUSINESS MEETINGS
AT EVEN REDUCE CAPACITIES. AND
THEY'VE DEVELOPED PROTOCOLS
USED SUCCESSFULLY IN OTHER
STATES YOU'LL HEAR A LITTLE BIT
MORE FROM THE PANEL LATER. I
JUST WANNA POINT OUT THE NEXT
SLIDE IN TERMS OF THE MEETINGS
MARKET WHICH IS CRITICAL. OUR
RESEARCH ANALYTICS ESTIMATE
THAT ABOUT TO BE ABOUT SIXTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
SPENDING AND YOU CAN SEE WHERE
THE ONLY STATE IN THE NATION
THAT IS STILL YET TO OPEN- AND
THE MEETINGS MARKET IS VERY
FORWARD- PLANNING SO MEETINGS
OFFICIALS ARE LOOKING AT TWO
THREE FIVE YEAR CALENDARS. AND
FOR SURE- THIS NEXT CALENDAR
YEAR- THE FIRST TWO QUARTERS AT
LEAST HAVE BEEN WIPED OFF THE
CHART. BUT THAT'S SIXTY FIVE
BILLION IT'S ACTUALLY JUST IT
HASN'T EVAPORATED IS JUST MOVED
TO OTHER STATES WHICH IS SO
UNFORTUNATE. SO IN TERMS OF OUR
PIVOT I JUST WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR TRAVEL
MESSAGE JEAN PRIORITIES AND YOU
CAN SEE FROM THIS BIG YELLOW
CIRCLE SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT AND
WE'RE LEADING WITH THE SAFETY
MESSAGE- SECONDARILY DOUBLING
DOWN ON ECONOMIC RCOVERY. AND
I'M PEELING TO CALIFORNIANS TO
CONSIDER ANY LEISURE PLANS IN
CALIFORNIA TO HELP THEIR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS. AND FINALLY-
WRAPPING THAT IN BRAND
INSPIRATION- IT TOO YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY UNDER TO GET PEOPLE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
BUSINESSES ARE LEANING IN-
SIGNIFICANTLY ON CLEAN AND SAFE
PROTOCOLS. BUT THERE IS STILL
AN INSPIRATION AND ARRESTED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO YOU AND
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT THE INDUSTRY
SEGMENTS THAT ALSO HAVE PIVOTED
AND TAKEN THIS VERY VERY
SERIOUSLY- AND BRACING FACE
COVERINGS DISTANCING POLICIES
EARLY ON. IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
MANY OF THE LINE WORKERS
ACTUALLY HAVE TO ENFORCE THOSE
RULES AS OPPOSED TO EVERYBODY
BEING COMPLIANT WITH THEM AND
THEY'VE HAD TO PUT THEMSELVES
IN UNCOMFORTABLE SITUATIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF US IN
CALIFORNIA. ARE STAYING SAFE TO
SUPPORT THE INDUSTRY WE HAD
VISIT CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN ON A
MANTRA AROUND AMPLIFYING THIS
MESSAGE AND WE CAME OUT WITH
THE RESPECT CALIFORNIA
RESPONSIBLE TRAVEL CODE WHICH
SHARED ACROSS THE STATE OUR OWN
CHANNELS WHICH HAVE ABOUT
THIRTY THREE MILLION FOLLOWERS
DIGITALLY- AND REALLY ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE HEADING OUT TO JUST
SIMPLY DO THEIR HOMEWORK ABOUT
THE SITUATION AT ANY RESPECTIVE
LOCAL DESTINATION. THEY PLAN TO
BENEFITS VISIT- IT SO IT'S PART
OF THAT IS A MULTI CHANNEL
CAMPAIGN AND IT'S NOW BEING LED
BY A PARTNERSHIP WE ACTUALLY
HAVE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION- WOULD
LEADING WITH A PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT ENCOURAGES A
SAFE TRAVEL BUT AGAIN IN THIS
KIND OF SIGNATURE BRAND WRAPPED
INSPIRATIONAL TONE. WE CALL IT
NEVER MEANT NORMAL- AND I'D
LOVE TO SHARE IT WITH YOU GUYS
TODAY MMHM. THERE'S A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT GETTING BACK TO
NORMAL. BUT IN CALIFORNIA
NORMAL'S NEVER REALLY BEEN OR
ANY. SEMESTER MANDATORY. THAT'S
ARE KIND OF PART KEEPING OUR
DISTANCE CAN BE AND IF YOU'RE
NOT WASHING YOUR HANDS A LOT
ALREADY MAYBE YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
GETTING DIRTY SO IF THIS IS THE
NEW NORMAL NO PROBLEM FOR MORE
WITH TAKE IN STRIDE AND RIDE IT
OUT HELP CALIFORNIA STAY SAFE
AND OPEN LEARN MORE AND VISIT
CALIFORNIA .COM. SO TAKE I'M
FINE YEAH VERY FINE ALL THE
MASS. SO TO KIND OF DOUBLE
CLICK ON THIS WE ALSO DONE
AGAIN FOR THE FIRST TIME AND I
SHOULD NOTE FOR THE RECORD THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE EVER
PIVOTED SINCE NINE ELEVEN TO DO
IN STATE MARKETING- AND THAT
AND THAT'S CRITICAL BECAUSE
USUALLY THE INDUSTRY DOES THAT
ON THEIR OWN AND MOVES PEOPLE
AROUND THE STATE BUT THIS TIME
THE INDUSTRY ASKED US GIVEN.
THE RESOURCE DEFICIT AS A
RESULT OF COVE AND FOR US TO
STEP IN AND CREATE KIND OF A CO
OP PLATFORM ACROSS ALL OUR
CHANNELS TO INSPIRE
CALIFORNIANS STAIN AND STATE SO
AGAIN THE CONSUMER FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS CONCERNED ABOUT
SAFETY AND WE REALLY WANTED TO
LEAN IN AND AMPLIFY THE GREAT
WORK THE INDUSTRY'S BEEN DOING
IN THIS SPACE NOT JUST FROM A
BIGGER BRAND PLATFORM BUT BY
INDUSTRY CATEGORY SO WE'VE ALSO
DEVELOPED A SET OF
COMPLEMENTARY DIGITAL VIDEO.
CALLED SAFE TRAVELS CALIFORNIA
THE TALKS ABOUT- WHAT A GREAT
TIME YOU CN HAVE WHILE YOUR
HOTELS FOR EXAMPLE OR RENTAL
CAR COMPANIES OR DESTINATIONS
ARE- KEEPING THEIR CONSUMER
SAFE SO I'VE GOT THREE I JUST
WANT TO CLOSE WITH- THE FIRST
TO FOCUS ON HOTELS AND RENTAL
CARS WITH THE FAMILY VACATION
MARKET- THE THIRD- HIGHLIGHTS
THE WINE COUNTRY AND WE WILL
RELEASE THAT WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT AND WE GET PAST THE WILD
FIRE SEASON SO WERE QUEUING UP
FOR. OUR HELPING TO SUPPORT OUR
WINE COUNTRY AS WELL SO LET'S
TAKE A LOOK AT ALL THREE. THESE
PARENTS ARE IN UNCHARTED
TERRITORY IT'S CALLED FINALLY
TAKING A VACATION. TRAVELING
THE CALIFORNIA COAST WITH
CONFIDENCE BECAUSE THEY PICKED
UP A RENTAL CAR IN A TOUCHLESS
PROCESS. AS THROUGH STRESS
PROTOCOLS. SURE IS IT THEY CAN
TAKE THEM SO OUT BEFORE THE
TIDE ROLLS IN. STAYING SAFE
MEANS STAYING OPEN FOR AND
VISIT COME DOT. THIS GUY IS IN
A STRANGE POSITION IT'S CALLED
RELAXING ON A MID WEEK GETAWAY
HE'S IT EASIER BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA HOTELS AND RESORTS
ARE FOLLOWING STRICT SPACING
AND SANITIZING PROTOCOLS TO
KEEP GUESTS SAFE. BUT ONE
QUESTION DOES PUZZLE HIM WHAT
IS IN THIS DELICIOUS BEVERAGE.
ALAS THAT MYSTERY WILL REMAIN
UNSOLVED FOR NOW STAYING SAFE
MEANS STAYING OPEN LEARN MORE
AND VISIT CALIFORNIA .COM. THIS
COUPLE IS IN AN UNFAMILIAR
SITUATION IT'S THE LONG AWAITED
EVENING. YES THEY CAN RELAX
THANKS TO THE STRING SPACING
AND SANITIZING PROTOCOLS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WINERIES AND
RESTAURANTS SO THEY'RE ONLY
DILEMMA. IS WHO GETS TO ENJOY
THIS MASTER PIECE OF CHEESE.
AND WITH THAT THE SHORT
QUESTION IS ANSWERED STAYING
SAFE MEANS STAYING OPEN LEARN
MORE AND VISIT CALIFORNIA .COM.
SO WITH THAT I'LL JUST CLOSE ON
A FINAL SLIDE WE'RE SINCE THE
OUTBREAK OF COVE AND WE'VE
STARTED A WEEKLY NEWSLETTER
THAT I DO WE'VE GOT ABOUT
FIFTEEN THOUSAND SUBSCRIBERS
BUT WE UPDATE CURRENT CONSUMER
SENTIMENT THE SITUATION ON THE
GROUND ON A WEEKLY BASIS SO I.
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
JUST TO SHARE THAT IN CASE
YOU'RE INTERESTED OR YOUR
STAFF'S INTERESTED IN GETTING
THAT NEWSLETTER SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE TIME IN THE
INTEREST TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
ASK. OR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR-
SENATOR I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION SHARING THIS-
VIDEOS WITH US AND THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING I CAN YOU
MAYBE JUST TOUCH ON YAK IN
TERMS OF FOR CALIFORNIA TOURISM
INDUSTRY WITH KOBE- SORT OF
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL TO
CALIFORNIA INTERNATIONAL
TRAVELERS AND THEN I GUESS THE
MASTIC FROM WITHIN THE US THAT
WAS WELL SO- YOU KNOW.
UNFORTUNATELY I KNOW AMERICANS
ARE BANNED FROM TRAVELING TO A
LOT OF OTHER COUNTRIES- SO- WE
BECAUSE OF OUR MISHANDLING TO
COPE WITH THAT PANDEMIC BUT
ALSO THAT MAKES EACH YEAR FOR
INTERNET SALES CAN YOU SPEAK TO
IS THERE IS THAT SIMILE
DROPPED- DO YOU SEE-
DIFFERENTIAL THERE DO YOU SEE
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
TERMS OF INTERNATIONAL VERSES
ESSENTIALLY DOMESTIC A REST OF
THIS COUNTRY I TRAVEL- TOURISM
YEAH THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS IS A
MULTI PHASED APPROACH OF KIND
OF MOVING OUT IN THE OPENING
AND THAT'S BASED ON CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR. SO PHASE ONE IS THIS
PIVOT IN STATE CALLING ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAMPAIGN PAYS
PHASE TWO WILL BE WESTERN
FEEDER AND AGAIN WE JUST WE
REACT TO CONSUMER SENTIMENT SO-
THAT CAMPAIGN IS CALLED CALLUM
CALIFORNIANS COLLEEN AND WE
EXPECT TO RULE THAT OUT AFTER
THE FIRST OF THE YEAR BASED O
THE WILL OF CONSUMERS TRAVELING
FURTHER THAN A COUPLE HOURS
FROM HOME- PHASE THREE- IS A
CAMPAIGN WERE ROLLING OUT LATER
IN THE SPRING CALLED ALL DREAMS
ALWAYS WELCOME ANTICIPATING
CONSUMER SENTIMENT AROUND
GETTING ON AIRPLANES- AND THAT
WOULD BREACH OVER 50% OF THEIR
INTEREST IN TRAVELING THAT FAR.
AND THEN FINALLY YOU KNOW PHASE
FOUR IS NEW NORMAL AND NOT IS
GOING BACK INTO THE
INTERNATIONAL MARKET SO WE'VE
SEEN PRECIPITOUS DROP OFF WE
CLOSED ALL FOURTEEN
INTERNATIONAL OFFICES FRANKLY
BECAUSE THE SENTIMENT THE WILL
IS NOT THERE I'M NOT SAYING
THAT PEOPLE AREN'T TRAVELING
BUT IT'S. EXTREMELY FEW AND FAR
BETWEEN AS WELL OF. WHAT WE'RE
IN OF INTERNET AIRLINE TRENDS
AS MANY OF OUR KEY PRIMARY
MARKETS- WERE SEEN SOME OPENING
OF. AIRLINES IN THE END OF
MARCH TIME FRAME THEY'VE
ANNOUNCED FOR. DIRECT FLIGHTS
OUT OF SHANGHAI SYDNEY FOR
EXAMPLE CANADA- EUROPE SO WE'RE
TRACKING EACH AND EVERY AIRLINE
AND THERE IS THIS LINE UP
AROUND THE END OF MARCH AT
LEAST TODAY SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE SEEING SO WE ARE. NOT
ACTIVELY MARKETING
INTERNATIONAL HOWEVER WE'VE
KEPT A- I'LL A LOW THRESHOLD
RETAINER BECAUSE WHEN WE START
TO OPEN WILL START WITH THE
TRAVEL TRADE SO WE NEED TO
START WORKING THOSE MARKET
SEVERAL MONTHS BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY SEE THAT RECOVERY BUT-
IT'S AS YOU DESCRIBED A VERY
DIRE SITUATION AND A WAYS OFF
RIGHT NOW. I GUESS ONE OTHER
QUESTION IS THAT. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AND I THINK IT'S
SORT OF THAT IN YOUR MESSAGING
IS THAT- THE STATE'S THAT SHOW
THE BEST RECORD AND KEEPING THE
IN KEEPING COVERED UNDER
CONTROL AND I KNOW YOU TALK
ABOUT THE CONVENTION INDUSTRY.
I KNOW THAT- YOU SEEM LIKE YOU
EXPRESSED CONCERN OF ME HERE
FOR FURTHER ON IN THIS HEARINGS
THAT WE'RE LOSING IT TO OTHER
STATES BUT I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT A LOT OF THE OTHER STATES
ARE HAVING INCREASING CASES AND
IF YOU'RE MAKING A RESERVATION
FOR WHETHER IT'S TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OR TWENTY TWENTY THREE- WE
SHOULD BE TALKING TO PEOPLE
THAT. YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
HOUSE. WHICH STATES ARE MORE
SERIOUS ABOUT GETTING KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE BECAUSE YOU CAN
MAKE A RESERVATION. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND OF THAT
STATE'S NOT TAKING IT SERIOUSLY
I THINK WE CAN NAME SOME STATES
WHERE LEADERSHIP HASN'T.
DETERRED YOU YOU MAY FIND
YOURSELF OUT OF CONVENTION AND
SUDDENLY HAVING TO THE STAND
EVEN IF KOBE IT'S ACTUALLY
UNDER CONTROL IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY INCLUDING HOPEFULLY
CALIFORNIA SO. I AGREE AND
THANK YOU FOR POINTING THAT OUT
I SHOULD OF. BEEN A LITTLE BIT
MORE. IN THE INTENT TO OF THE
INDUSTRY AND YOU'LL HEAR FROM
OTHERS OF STARTING OUT. WITH
VERY SMALL MEETINGS TO DIP
THEIR TOE IN THE STAND AND
REALLY START TO BUILD THAT
TRACK RECORD I SUBSCRIBE TO
THIS I THINK WE'RE IN A MUCH
BETTER PLACE- AND SHARE YOUR
SENTIMENT- AND- AND- LOOK AT.
YOU KNOW HOW WE'RE TREATING
OTHER GATHERINGS BUT REALLY
FOCUSING ON. SMALL ENGAGEMENTS
OF LESS THAN A HUNDRED JUST TO
START DOWN THAT PATHWAY AND
ESTABLISH WHAT WORKS IN TERMS
OF THOSE CLEAN AND SAFE
PROTOCOLS. HATS OFF TO US THAT
WE ARE IN A GOOD SITUATION
COMPLETELY AGREE. NOW PLAYING
THANK YOU AND I GUESS I WAS
JUST THAT THAT THE LAST COMMENT
I MAKE ABOUT IT IS THAT. IT IS
DEPENDENT ON EACH AND EVERYONE
OF US WHO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN IT'S NOT
BECAUSE GOVERNMENTS TELLING YOU
TO DO SOMETHING. I WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM PEOPLE ABOUT JOBS AND
ECONOMIC COUNTY ME AND SO WHEN
YOU DECIDE TO GO OUTSIDE. AND
THINK SHOULD I WEAR MY MASK
THINK ABOUT ALL THOSE PEOPLE
WHO CAN'T GO TO WORK BECAUSE
THIS VIRUS AND IF YOU WEAR A
<c.magenta>ASK WHEN THEY MAY BE ABLE TO</c>
GET. BACK TO THEIR JOBS COMES
OUT LATELY AGREE AND I THINK
YOU'LL HEAR THE FRUSTRATION OF
THE PANEL THAT'S COMING AFTER
ME ABOUT. HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO ENFORCE THIS WITH CONSUMERS
AND HAVING THAT UNANIMITY SO-
THAT'S WHY WE KIND OF STEPPED
IN TO TRY TO PROVIDE THAT COVER
FOR THE INDUSTRY IT'S SO
IMPORTANTAND WE SUBSCRIBE TO
THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK
YOU MANAGER OUT ONE QUICK
QUESTION ONE MORE QUESTION THE
QUESTION IS YOU REFERENCE THE
FACT THAT CONVENTION BUSINESS
IS NOT COMING IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S GOING ELSEWHERE I'M
ASSUMING IT'S STAYING IN THE
STATES WHERE THE ODDITIES
ASSOCIATIONS ARE BASED ON OUR
ARE WE LOSING CONVENTION
BUSINESS TO OTHER STATES THAT
ARE SOMEHOW MORE COMPETITIVE
WITH US- AND IT'S NOT ABOUT
KIND OF TRY TO MINIMIZE TRAVEL.
THERE IS THERE IS A CROSS CUT
WERE WERE ACTUALLY LOSING
BUSINESSES TO OTHER STATES I
DON'T WANT TO ARTICULATE TO SAY
THAT WE LOST SIXTY FIVE BILLION
SO THERE FOR SIXTY FIVE BILLION
IS GOING ELSEWHERE THERE IS A
PIECE OF THAT THAT'S GOING
ELSEWHERE THERE'S A PIECE THAT
STAYING CLOSER TO HOME THAT WE
KNOW BECAUSE WE TALKED OR ARE
COMPETITON EVERY DAY OF THE
OTHER STATES BOOKING AND
PICKING UP THAT BUSINESS IT MAY
NOT BE HOLISTICALLY SIXTY SIX
BILLION AS I SAID BUT- A GOOD
SHARE OF THAT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO PLAN SO FAR OUT- IS BEING
LOST BECAUSE WE'RE NOT OPEN. TO
BOOK BUSINESS TODAY. SO I THINK
THAT THAT'S- SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE DISCUSSING IS AND
INSENSITIVE TO YOUR COMMENTS
CENTER PAM IS. THAT THE EVEN IF
THEY BALK BUSINESS THREE YEARS
OUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE
INDUSTRY WON'T POSTPONE IT EVEN
WITH OUR OWN BOARD MEETINGS
WE'VE- GONE VIRTUAL WE POSTPONE
IN THE INDUSTRY IS VERY
FLEXIBLE AND RESILIENT- BUT I
THINK THE INDUSTRY WANTS TO
KNOW THAT THERE IS A PLAN. YOU
KNOW TWO TO THREE YEARS OUT
THAT THEY'VE MARKED IT ON THE
BOOKS AND EVEN IF THEY HAVE TO.
AT LEAST THEY'RE OUT BEING ABLE
TO OPEN THE SALE THAT THAT
THAT'S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
THAN ACTUALLY HOLDING THE
MEETING. AND THEN- OF COURSE
I'M GONNA ASK YOU AND EVERYONE
WHO COMES TO THIS- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OVERVIEW AND I
THINK- THE NEXT PANEL IS ALSO
GOING TO BE A BIT OF AN
OVERVIEW BUT I'D LIKE EVERYONE
WHO'S SPEAKING. IF YOU COULD
TELL US YOU'RE THE TOP THREE
THINGS YOU WISH THE STATE COULD
DO. RIGHT AT THIS MOMENT THAT
WOULD HELP I'M JUST GOING TO
TRY TO GET THAT SURVEY FROM
EVERYBODY. WHAT WOULD IT BE.
RIGHT THANK. I WILL SAY WITH
REGARD TO LEISURE TRAVEL I
THINK WE'VE GOTTEN SOME PRETTY
GOOD COOPERATION. I THINK
CONSISTENCY IS KEY ACROSS ALL.
BUSINESS SECTORS AS WELL AS-
COUNTIES SO JUST TRYING TO BE.
CONSISTENT AND KEEP. THE
CHANNELS OF COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN LOCAL COUNTY HEART
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS
THE POP YOU KNOW THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT. THAT
IS KEY. AND THEN THIS THIS
ISSUE OF TRYING TO CLARIFY
CONSISTENCY AROUND TEARS. AND
ALLOWING- COMMITTEE OPEN
COMMUNICATION FOR THOSE SECTORS
THAT ARE STILL NOT OPEN LIKE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
TODAY. TO AT LEAST LISTEN WITH
ALL SERIOUSNESS OF. THE EXTENT
THE INDUSTRY'S GOING TO. TO
APPLY THOSE SAFE AND CLEAN
PROTOCOLS. I THINK IS CRITICAL
SO THAT THAT WE HAVE- UNANIMITY
AMONGST A BLUEPRINT FOR. SAFE
THREE OPENINGS. THAT THAT WOULD
BE EXTRAORDINARILY HELPFUL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY WELL
DONE AND WE APPRECIATE THAT WE-
I KNOW I'M TAKING NOTES AND WE
WILL. MAKE SURE WE GET I LIKE
THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND
KIND OF A SURVEY HERE BECAUSE
WE WANT TO LEAVE. THIS HEARING
WITH SOME ACTION ITEMS SO WE
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU THANK. YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I THINK THE- NEXT
WE HAVE COMING UP TO READ TO A
IS HOW CAL. TOURISM HAS
WEATHERED THE PANDEMIC. AND NOW
THE IMPACT ON WORKERS BUSINESS
OWNERS AND LOCAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WE WILL HAVE JOE
ELLIS SANDRO ON WHO IS THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF SAN
FRANCISCO TRAVEL. WELCOME THANK
YOU. SO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE TODAY
AND TALKING TO THIS ON THIS
IMPORTANT SUBJECT THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US- I LIKE
TO DO A SPECIAL SET OUT TO SEE
MEMBER CHIU WHO REPRESENTS MY
DISTRICT AND IT'S BEEN A- LONG
TERM- A SUPPORTER OF TOURISM
AND SAMUS IS GOING TO OUT CITY
CALIFORNIA- IT'S ALSO GREAT TO
BE BACK HERE IN MY HOMETOWN OF
SACRAMENTO TO- TO SEE IT'S
BEGINNING TO HAVE THE RECOVERY
TO AND THE NEXT STEP IS GOING
TO HAVE TO TAKE TO GO FORWARD.
MY NAME IS JOE DALLESANDRO THE
PRESIDENCY OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION. IT'S THE
NONPROFIT DESTINATION MARKETING
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO-
PROMOTE SAN FRANCISCO IS A
PREMIER DESTINATION FOR
MEETINGS. CONVENTIONS EVENTS
EVENTS AND LEISURE TRAVEL. LIKE
VISIT CALIFORNIA WE ALSO WERE
STARTED BY A BY A DISASTER AND
THAT WAS THE NINETEEN OH SIX
EARTHQUAKE. WE WERE FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN OH NINE- WITH THE
GROUP OF PROGRESSIVE BUSINESS
LEADERS WHO THOUGHT THAT SAN
FRANCISCO BEING SO FAR OUT FROM
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY. GOOD
REBOUNDER ECONOMY TO TRAVEL AND
TOURISM AND WE'RE THE ONE THE
OLDEST DESTINATION MARKETING
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE WORLD
RIGHT NOW BASED ON THAT- THAT
THOUGHTFUL THINKING BACK THEN.
WE'RE ESPECIALLY PROUD THAT OUR
RESIDENTS AND GOVERNMENT HAVE
WORKED HARD TO MINIMIZE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS OF COVERT
NINETEEN. YOU KNOW WITH THE
FIRST CITY THEY WOULD DECLARE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY THE UNITED
STATES. THE PERSON DID TO GO
INTO LOCKDOWN AND WE ALSO HAVE
THE BEST. COATED RECOVERY RATES
OF ANY MAJOR CITY IN THE UNITED
STATES RIGHT NOW SO WE'RE VERY.%
PROUD OF THE LEADERSHIP IN OUR
CITY IN THE DIFFICULT DECISIONS
THEY MADE EARLY ON BUT IT'S
BENEFITING TO THE- CITIZENS OF
SAN FRANCISCO TODAY AND THE
VISITORS TO SAN FRANCISCO TODAY.
THE PANDEMIC CONTINUES TO
DEVASTATE A TOURISM BUSINESSES-
HOTELS RESTAURANTS MEETING
FACILITIES TOURISM ATTRACTIONS
SMALL AND LARGE BUSINESS AND
TOURISM RELATED RETAIL ARE ALL
DEVASTATED BY THE IMPACTS OF
THIS THIS PANDEMIC AFTER TEN
YEARS OF TEN PLUS YEARS OF
GROWTH VISITORS SPENDING WILL
DROP 67% IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY. I'M AND WHAT'S
IMPORTANT WE TALK ABOUT THESE
DROPS OF SPENDING AND
VISITATION IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THE FIRST QUARTER OF
THIS YEAR WAS PRETTY NORMAL IT
WAS IT WE WERE HEADED INTO A
VERY STRONG YEAR. AND THEN ALL
OF A SUDDEN IT FELL OFF THE
FACE SO THE NUMBERS THAT WE
PRESENT TO YOU OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY KEEP IN MIND THAT THAT
FIRST QUARTER WAS A FAIRLY
HEALTHY FIRST QUARTER AND THEN
ALL OF A SUDDEN IT FELL APART.
NEXT YOU WERE PLANNING ON AN
UPTICK BUT WE STILL. WILL STILL
BE DOWN 40% AT LEAST FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN. FROM
NINE POINT SIX BILLION TO
ABOUT. ESTIMATED FIVE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN TOURISM. ANY
HOTELS WERE FORCED TO CLOSE
WITH OCCUPANCY RATES AT AN ALL
TIME LOW SOME WILL BE CLOSED
PERMANENTLY. THOUSANDS REMAIN
WITHOUT JOBS. ANY BY
INTERNATIONAL VISITORS I WILL
DECREASE 72% THIS YEAR. AN
OVERALL 67% FEWER INTERNATIONAL
RIVAL RIVALS WITH THE DROP FROM
CHINA NEARLY 73% AND 69% FOR
YOUR- TRADITIONALLY THE
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS HAVE
ACCOUNTED FOR A MUCH LARGER
PERCENTAGE OF VISITORS SPENDING
AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT SAN FRANCISCO. WHEN
64% OF ALL OF OUR VISITORS
SPENDING COMES FROM
INTERNATIONAL VISITORS TO THE
CITY. BECAUSE RECOVERY WILL BE
pDRIVEN BY MAINLY BY DOMESTIC
TRAVELER VISITOR SPENDING WILL
TAKE LONGER TO RECOVER BECAUSE
DOMESTIC TRAVELERS TEND TO
SPEND LESS THAN INTERNATIONAL
TRAVELERS IN THE STATE'S
SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME. SO
THAT'S GOING TO BE EVEN LONGER
FOR US TO RECOVER. THE LOST OF
THE CONVENTION BUSINESS IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS A KEY COMPONENT OF
THE DECLINE IN THE THING THAT
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT. IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN A
RECORD ONE POINT TWO MILLION
CONVENTION NIGHTS WERE BOOKED
AT HOTELS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS YEAR WE EXPECT THE NUMBER
TO CLOSE OUT AT ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND. WITH
MOST OF THOSE COMING IN THE
FIRST QUARTER. SO FAR FORTY
GROUPS HAVE CANCELED OFF THE
BOOKS AND TO TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TODAY WE GOT
FOUR MORE CANCELLATIONS FOR THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. CANCELLATION OF
CITY WIDE CONVENTIONS ALONE
REPRESENT A LOSS AND DIRECT-SPENDING OF OVER SIX HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO ALONE.
THE CITY IS DEVELOP PROTOCOLS
FOR FUTURE LARGE MEETINGS
SOCIAL DISTANCING ROLES ENHANCE
SANITATION REQUIREMENTS AND
EVERYTHING BECAUSE SAFETY IS
PARAMOUNT FOR EMPLOYEES INSISTS
SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT FOR
VISITORS SO WE DO NOT WANT TO
TAKE ANY STEPS. THAT WILL
ENSURE THE SAFETY- AS WE OPEN
UP THE CITY TO A FUTURE TRAVEL.
SAN FRANCISCO TRAVEL DOES NOT
ANTICIPATE NORMAL OPERATIONS TO
RETURN INTO A LEASE THEN LATER
PART OF NEXT YEAR. BUT ONLY
EFFECTS SEEN IN RAPID TESTING
IS READILY AVAILABLE. WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE THE SAN FRANCISCO
WE'LL SEE THE NUMBERS THAT WE
SAW IN TWO THOUSAND NINEEEN
UNTIL TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR
OR TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY FIVE.
I RESEARCH THAT- IT'S NOT JUST
SAN FRANCISCO THAT'S AFFECTED
BY THIS LACK OF MEETING
BUSINESS AND THE MEETING
BUSINESS IS ESSENTIAL FOR. FOR
TOURISM WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
LEISURE STARTING TO COME BACK
THAT'S TRUE IN A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS OR SEEN LEISURE
TRAVEL. BUT IT'S MAINLY ON
WEEKENDS AND THE URBAN AREAS DO
NOT SEE THE SAME AND LEISURE.
TRAVELERS AT SOME OF THE RESORT
AREA SEE SO WE NEED TO FIND
DEMAND DRIVERS TO BRING PEOPLE
BACK INTO OUR CITIES AND BACK
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
MEETINGS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT LEISURE TRAVEL I MEAN
BEYOND MAJOR TRAVEL WE'D LOVE
TO HAVE A MEETING LIKE THIS IN
SAN FRANCISCO. WE CAN'T DO THAT
TODAY THIS AND AGAIN IT'S NOT
JUST SAN FRANCISCO THAT'S BEING
AFFECTED BY THE LACK OF
BUSINESS MEETINGS. AND THE
BUSINESS NEED MEANING SECTORS
COLLAPSING ACROSS THE STATE.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA. RULES WILL
NOT ALLOW A LARGE INDOOR
GATHERINGS DESPITE DISTANCING
SANITATION PROTOCOLS THAT HAVE
PROVOKED PROVIDED. SUCCESSFUL
ELSEWHERE. IN PALM SPRINGS ON
MEETING HAVE BEEN LOST FOR THIS
YEAR AND THEY'RE BEGINNING TO
BE KANSEN FOR THE FIRST QUARTER
OF NEXT YEAR. THE COACHELLA
VALLEY ALONE HAS LOST THREE
POINT ONE BILLION IN VISITOR
SPENDING SPENDING. MANY
PLANNERS CAN'T WAIT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ISSUE GUIDANCE AT
VIRTUALLY EVERY OTHER STATE IS
ISSUED. THEY'RE MAKING PLANS TO
TAKE THEIR BUSINESS THEIR
DOLLARS ELSEWHERE THIS IS OUR
OF OUR BIGGEST CONCERN BECAUSE-
WE WORK WITH A PLANNER WHO
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A MEETING
HERE FOR THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THEY CAN'T FEEL
THAT WE CAN GUARANTEE IT
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
ESTABLISHED THOSE. PROTOCOLS
YET SO THAT'S GOING TO BE ONE
OF MY TOP THREE THINGS TALKING
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
COMMUNICATING IN ADVANCE TO A
PLAN IS BECAUSE MANY OF THESE
CONVENTIONS. ARE PLANNED YEARS
IN ADVANCE AND SO WE'RE GOING
TO BE OUT OF LUCK FOR THENEXT
RECOVERY TIME THE NEXT THREE OR
FOUR YEARS IF WE CAN'T START
BOOKING THOSE CONVENTIONS WITH
THE IDEA THAT THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO COME BACK ONLINE. MANY
CRITICAL TO- CALIFORNIANS ARE
THE SMALL MEETINGS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO START WITH WE
REALIZE THAT THE ABILITY TO
LARGE. DO LARGE CITY WIDE
CONVENTIONS ARE LARGE EVENTS IS
NOT GONNA HAPPEN ANY TIME SOON.
WE DO FEEL THAT WE'RE IN A
POSITION THAT WE'RE READY TO
HOLD SMALL MEETINGS MUCH LIKE
THIS. MEETING IN HOTELS AND
OTHER MEETING VENUES AND AROUND
THE STATE. WE CAN'T DO THAT AT
THIS POINT BUT THIS IS GONNA BE
ONE THE MOST IMPORTANT. BABY
STEPS. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THESE
MEETINGS WE DO HAVE THE
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE WE FEEL THE
SAFETY IN PLACE BECAUSE THAT IS
PARAMOUNT. BUT THAT IS THE NEXT
UP WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE HAPPEN.
THE PANDEMIC IS ALSO COST
HUNDREDS OF MILLION DOLLARS IN
TOURISM RELATED. REVENUE DATA
TAX REVENUE. RELATED TOURISM
REVENUE SPORTS VITAL CITY
SERVICES IMPORT AND ENJOYED BY
RESIDENTS AND VISITORS. IN SAN
FRANCISCO ALONE ALMOST A
BILLION DOLLARS OF LOCAL TAX
MONEY IS GENERATED BY. BY
VISITORS AND WE'RE GONNA SEE
THAT DECIMATED THIS YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY VISITORS TO OUR
CITY CENTER STATE SUPPORTER
RESTAURANTS CULTURAL
INSTITUTION THE ARTS
ATTRACTIONS NIGHTLIFE SPORTS
AND BELOVED OPEN SPACES AND
AMENITIES THAT DEFINE OUR
DESTINATION AND PROVIDE FOR THE
QUALITY OF LIFE THAT OUR
RESIDENTS HAVE GROWN ACCUSTOMED
TO. I RESIDENT COMMUNITIES
ALONE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THESE BELOVED
ACTIVITIES WE NEED OUR VISITORS
AND OUR NEIGHBORHOODS TO
SUPPORT THE RESTAURANTS WE NEED
THE VISITORS TO SUPPORT THE
ARTS AND CULTURAL ACTIVITIES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. WE NEED TO
VISITORS TO ATTEND SPORTING
EVENTS ARE WE ALONE IS
RESIDENTS CANNOT SUPPORT THE
QUALITY OF LIFE THAT IS SO
ESSENTIAL TO ALL OF US THAT
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. AS YOU NO
HOTEL TAXES AND MOST CALIFORNIA
ZIP A CITIES CONTRIBUTE TO A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT TO LOCAL
CITY BUDGETS. THEY ARE TAXES
PAID BY TOURISTS TO FIND
SERVICES THAT BENEFIT ALL RISK
RESIDENTS INCLUDING PUBLIC
SAFETY SALARIES AND OTHER
MUNICIPAL OPERATIONS. IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO SUCCEED CITY
COMPTROLLER EXPECTS. A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
FROM LOCAL HOTEL TAXES IN THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR ACROSS ALL
FUNDS. THAT 63% LESS TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION. THAT
WAS BUDGETED LAST FISCAL YEAR.
AGAIN THE SAME STORY IS PLAYING
OUT ACROSS THE STATE. IN
ANAHEIM WHERE TOURISM TAXES
MAKE UP ABOUT A QUARTER OF THE
BUDGET. THE LOCKDOWN LAST
SPRING BECAUSE THE FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS SHORTFALL 31%
AND HOTEL TAX COLLECTIONS. FOR
THE FISCAL YEAR THAT STARTED IN
JULY COLLECTIONS ARE PROJECTED
TO DROP ANOTHER THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. TO EIGHTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL 62%
DROP OF THE TWO FISCAL YEARS.
WITH STATE LINES FOR THEME PARK
RE OPENING AND THE RESUMPTION
OF BUSINESS MEETINGS FAR FROM
CERTAIN. RECOVERY RIGHT AWAY-
FOR SOME CITIES REMAINS ELUSIVE.
SO TOURISM IS EXTREMELY
CRITICAL COMPONENT FOR OUR-
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IT
GENERATES MILLIONS OF JOBS
BILLIONS IN TAXES BILLIONS OF
THE VISITOR SPENDING AND
ENHANCES OUR QUALITY OF LIFE.
HOWEVER WITH THE CURRENT
SITUATION IT IS GOING TO BE A
VERY LONG VERY SLOW RECOVERY
THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO THE
COLLABORATION WE WORK TOGETHER
WITH OTHER DESTINATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO BE DISTURBANCE.
PROTOCOLS THAT ARE CONSISTENT
ACROSS THE STATE NOT
CONSISTENCY IS REALLY IMPORTANT
WE'RE IN THIS TOGETHER WE
REALIZE IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG
SLOW RECOVERY IT CAN BE DONE
BUT WE NEED THE SUPPORT OF THE
STATE AND THE PATIENCE AND
SUPPORT OF OUR PARTNERSHIPS IN
ORDER TO MAKE IT HAPPEN- THE
THREE THINGS THAT I WOULD GET
BACK TO YOUR QUESTION. ASSEMBLY
INTO THAT I THINK ARE IMPORTANT
IS WHAT CAROLINE SAID IS
CONSISTENCY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
FOR A VISITOR BECAUSE THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE JIG YOU
POLITICAL BOUNDARIES IN OUR
STATE THEY DON'T KNOW WHEN
ACROSS IN A COUNTY BORDER CITY
ORDER. THE CONSISTENCY IN RULES
AND REGULATIONS WILL BE REALLY
IMPORTANT STATE BUDGET FACE A
MASK MANDATES ARE IMPORTANT
BECAUSE SOME COMMUNITIES HAVE
MORE REQUIREMENTS THAN OTHER
COMMUNITIES AND IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HAVE THE SORT OF
CONSISTENCY. BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING I WOULD SAY
RIGHT NOW IS THE ABILITY TO
HAVE SMALL MEETINGS AS A DEMAND
DRIVERS- WE BELIEVE MUCH LIKE A
LOT OF OTHER BUSINESSES THAT
OPEN AT LIMITED CAPACITY WE CAN
OPEN OUR HOTELS IN A MEETING
VENUES TO SMALL MEETINGS.
SAFELY AND WITH THE PROPER
SAFETY PROTOCOLS AND SANITATION
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE- AND I THINK
THAT THAT IS PROBABLY THE NEXT
STEP THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
WE BELIEVE IT CAN BE DONE MUCH
LIKE CHURCHES HAVE SHOWN THAT
THEY CAN DO RESTAURANTS HAVE
SHOWN THAT THEY CAN DO.
THEATERS HAVE SHOWN THAT WE CAN
DO SO CAN WE AND MEETING
INDUSTRY AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
CRITICAL NEXT STEPS OF OUR
OPENING STRATEGY. SO I'M HERE
IF ANYBODY ELSE HAS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. BUT THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO.
THANK YOU I JUST STONE. I HAD
ONE THOUGHT I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SOME GROUPS THAT ARE KIND
OF IN TRAIN IN WHAT WE CALL A
HYBRID MODEL WHERE THEY'RE
USING HOTEL SPACE CONFERENCE
ROOMS BUT THEY'RE ALSO
ALLOWING- THEIR PARTS OF THE
GROUP THAT DON'T FEEL. THAT
THEY'RE READY TO DO THAT TO
KIND OF ZOO MAN- HAVE IF YOU
SEE ANY OF THAT STARTING TO
HAPPEN WE CERTAINLY HAVE A
PLANNER SO WE'RE TALKING A LOT
TO THEM ABOUT THAT EVEN IN THE
LARGER CONVENTIONS THAT WOULD
HAVE A MOSCONI CENTER OF HAVING
A HYBRID VIRTUAL AND IN PERSON
MEETING WE BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE FIRST STEP IN
IN ORDER TO MAKE IT HAPPEN
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
IS AS IS THE INDUSTRY WE'RE
MAKING. TAKEN STEPS TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO ALL THIS AND BE
ABLE TO OPEN TO LARGE MEETINGS
INSTANTLY SO WE BELIEVE THIS
HYBRID APPROACH IS THE WAY TO
EASE INTO IT TO SHOWCASE HOW WE
CAN DO I MEAN SAFETY SAFELY AND
ALLOW PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE A
LOT OF OUR MEETINGS AND SEVEN
CISCO EVEN MEDICAL MEETINGS ARE
ARCHITECT MEETINGS AND THE
MEDICAL MEETINGS ARE PRIMARILY
MADE UP OF DOCTORS WHO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
SAFETY PROTOCOLS. RIGHT NOW
THEY CAN'T EVEN ME AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS NEXT UP A
HYBRID MEETING WITH PART
VIRTUAL PART IN PERSON. WOULD
BE THAT WOULD BE THE NEXT AND-
THANK. THE SCHOOLS ARE STARTING
OUT AS A AS OF OUR TO. THIS WAS
A SOLDIER. WELCOME TO THE CAP
I'M REALLY PLEASED THE PRESENT.
I THINK YOU COVER WHAT I WAS
HOPING FOR. A CURE BECAUSE I
KNOW THE- NOT HERE. WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS ISSUE OF MEETINGS AND HOW
CLOSE ARE WE OR THEY TO. MOVING
FORWARD WITH SOME GUIDANCE. YOU
KNOW WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
OF A COALITION OF CALIFORNIA.
CITIES THAT HAVE CONVENTION
CENTERS AND IN PLACE AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE- CAL TRAVEL
TO- TO. GET THAT NEXT STEP
THEY'RE WEIRD LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY
MOVEMENT ON IT TO BE HONEST
THERE'S A LOT OF. FRUSTRATION A
LOT OF JOBS AT STAKE- AGAIN WE
BELIEVE WE CAN DO THIS SAFELY.
STARTING SMALL. AND GOING TO
THE NEXT LEVEL AS YOU KNOW SAN
FRANCISCO IS ALREADY IN THE
ORANGE. ZONE WHICH SHOULD ALLOW
US TO BE OPEN AND LIMITED
CAPACITY FOR SOME OF THE-
MEETINGS LIKE THIS WE HAVE. HAD
LOTS F COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WE HAVE NOT.
HAD THE GO AHEAD YEAH. I WHAT I
WOULD SAY AND I KNOW I'M SURE
THIS THE CASE FOR A COLLEAGUE
SO MANY OF US GET PULLED IN BY
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES TO- HELP.
FACILITATE CONVERSATIONS WITH
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT RE OPENING
GUIDELINES AND IF IT'S- NOT FOR
SURE THE- ARCHER AND MYSELF AND
OTHERS- DOCTOR PAN WE'D ALL BE
WILLING TO. TO HELP SO. JUST
OFFER THAT OFFICE AS A
SUGGESTION IF WE CAN BE
ENGAGED. HAPPY WE WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT SUPPORT. THANK
SENATOR THANK YOU- AND
ACTUALLY- I'LL POINT OUT
ACTUALLY DOOR TO MEDICAL OF
NATIONAL MEDICAL MEETINGS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN THIS YEAR- THAT I WAS
GOING TO ATTEND AT THE BUSINESS
COUNCIL DOESN'T OPEN LARGE
SCALE THEY WEREN'T SAN
FRANCISCO WOULD FORTUNATELY
BUT- WILL BECOME THEIR NEXT
AREA LOOKING ACCENTS BUT I JUST
WANT IT AND YOU KNOW MY OTHER
HAT IS NOW IN SESSION I CHAIRED
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE SO
I HAVE A VERY CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE-
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH AND WE
DO OVERSIGHT OVER THAT. YOU CAN
TEASE PARTICULARLY YOU TALKED
ABOUT WELL YOU KNOW WHAT ABOUT
THE OPENING SMALLER MEETINGS
BUT- IN TERMS OF PARTICULARLY
YOU SAID THAT WE'RE A
DISADVANTAGE FOR COMPETING FOR
CONVENTIONS. NEXT YOU KNOW
YEARS OUT SO IS IT THAT'S OTHER
STATES ARE DOING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S AND DOING THAT'S
GIVING THEM THE ADVANTAGE TO
BOOK A CONVENTION IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE LET'S SAY OUR
TWENTY TWENTY THE L. FOUR. KEY
TEAM YEAH YEAH SO WHAT'S
HAPPENED OTHER STATES AND I'LL
JUST GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF SOME
STATES THAT ARE SIMILAR TO
CALIFORNIA STATE OF WASHINGTON-
ARE VERY SIMILAR IN CALIFORNIA
VERY SIMILAR APPROACH TO THE-
THE KOBE CRISIS THE GOVERNOR IS
ALREADY. ALLOWED MEETINGS AT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE AGAIN
SPACE WITH ALL THE PROTOCOL IN
PLACE TO START HAPPENING IN
WASHINGTON WE CAN'T DO THAT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO IF YOU
HAVE A- GROUP WE'RE LOOKING AT
WELL PLACED A FULL GROUP OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE TOGETHER.
YOUR CHOICE IS COMING TO A
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA PLACE IN
WASHINGTON STATE YOU CAN DO IT
WATCHING STATE. STATE OF NEVADA
GOVERNOR IS DOING THE SAME
THING WITH THEIR STARTING I
BELIEVE THEIR NUMBER IS MORE
LIKE A THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT ARE
GONNA START HAVING SO. PLANNERS
IS THEY'RE ANXIOUS TO HAVE
THEIR MEETINGS NOW ARE LOOKING
WE'RE GONNA TAKE THIS MEETING.
AND MAKE NAY THEY DON'T THEY
CAN'T TAKE IN CALIFORNIA SO
THEY'RE LOOKING AT OTHER PLACES
THAT ARE ALLOWING THEM TO TAKE
THEIR MEETINGS WHETHER THEY'RE
IN THE NEXT TWO MONTHS THE NEXT
TWO YEARS. THE UNKNOWN FACTORS
THAT WE HAVE NOT SET UP ANY OF
THESE PROTOCOLS IN CALIFORNIA
YET FROM THE FROM A STATE
PERSPECTIVE. SO IF YOU'RE NOT
YOU'RE A PLANNER LOOKING AT A
MEDICAL MEETING OR ANY TYPE OF
MEETING AND YOU'RE THINKING
WHERE CAN I GO WE DON'T KNOW
WHEN CALIFORNIA'S GONNA COME UP
WITH A PROTOCOL SO LET'S GO TO
A PLACE. THAT IS ALREADY
ESTABLISHED ANNOUNCES PROTOCOLS
SUGGEST HE GETS A CHALLENGE.
OKAY SO JUST TO BE CLEAR.
THERE'S THAT WHAT'S- RIGHT NOW
WE DON'T. WHAT YOU KNOW LATE
NEXT YEAR I DON'T KNOW NO STATE
ARE THOSE STATES MAKING
COMMITMENTS THAT THEY'RE
PREDICTING THAT THEY'RE STILL
GOING TO BE ABLE TO STAY OPEN I
MEAN- NEXT YEAR AND- WE'RE
BEING MORE HONEST AND NOT
SAYING WE CAN OR IS IT BECAUSE
OF OUR CURRENT PRESIDENT SOME
OF THE CARE UNLESS OR
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN. RIGHT
CURRENT SITUATION. WHERE YOU
KNOW MAYBE SOME STATES ARE
SAYING AND I DON'T KNOW IT'S A
GOOD IDEA OR NOT TO TEAR SAYING
THAT OR NOT. VERSES SAYING THAT
WHILE WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
BOOKING A MEETING AND YOU KNOW
SOLVED. EVEN AS EARLY AS FALL
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND SAYING
WELL WE DON'T PUT IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT WE'RE WILLING
TO BOOK IN THIS OTHER STATE
BECAUSE THEY'RE- ALLOWING STUFF
NOW. SO I THINK WHAT'S
HAPPENING. CENTER IS THAT-
PLANNERS WHO HAVE TO PLAN
THERE'S A LOT OF BUSINESS-
EXPENSE TO HOLD A MEETING AND
WATER COMMITMENT IN ADVANCE TO
HOLD A MEETING. SO THEY'RE
LOOKING AT IT AT THE STATE THAT
HAS- PROTOCOLS THAT ARE BEING
ANNOUNCED FOR GATHERINGS
ANNOUNCER MEETINGS AND
THINKING. THAT'S PROBABLY A
SAFER BET THAN THAN BETTING ON
CALIFORNIA WHEN THEY HAVEN'T
EVEN ANNOUNCED ANY SORT OKAY SO
STRATEGY. SO IF CALIFORNIA SAID
LOOK. WE'LL HAVE A PROTOCOL
WE'RE NOT OPEN NOW FOR. TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE AT
SURVIVOR X. RIGHT. BECAUSE OF.
WHATEVER STAGING. BUT THEY SAID
BUT WE HAVE A PROTOCOL THAT YOU
KNOW. IT'S THIS AREA YOU KNOW
WE'RE AT RED OR ORANGE RIGHT IF
IT STAYS ORANGE. WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO HAVE ONE FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE AND SIX
MONTHS. WITH THAT PROVIDE SOME
ASSURANCE TO A MEETING PLANNER
THAT OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT WILL GO
AHEAD YOU KNOW WE'RE OKAY WITH
I MEAN. THIS IS THIS IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT
WOULD DEFINITELY HELP. FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONVICTIONS STILL ON THE BOOKS
FOR TO THE SECOND HALF OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. OKAY
ASKING US RIGHT NOW WHAT IS THE
PROTOCOL IN CALIFORNIA OKAY WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING THAT WE CAN
GIVE THEM OR GIVE HER ANY SORT
OF. A FIRM- NATURE LIKE THAT
THAT WE CAN SHARE WITH THEM
OKAY SAID SO BASICALLY WE CAN
GET A PROTOCOL FROM. THE GET
NOW FROM BASICALLY CDPH OUR
STATE THAT SAYS A LOT THERE
WILL BE A THERE'S A PROTOCOL TO
SAY THAT IF. YOU WERE AT A
CERTAIN STATE. WE WILL ALLOW.
THAT TO. THEN THAT WHAT WE BE
YOU NEED TO PROVIDE ASSURANCES
PLANNERS NOT TO CANCEL OR EVEN
TO SCHEDULE. THAT WOULD RATHER
MUCH MORE BENEFICIAL YES OKAY
CAN SAY THAT WE'RE GONNA. ARE
YOU ORANGE KNOWN FOR YOU KNOW.
TWO MONTHS OR WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE YEAH WE CAN TELL OUR
PLAN IS THAT THAT WOULD BE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL. OKAY THANK
YOU THAT'S VERY HELPFUL THANK
YOU. WHAT WE HAVE ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARRIVING ON
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RICHARD BLOOM. I
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THE FLIGHT
OUT HERE AND- WE ARE IN OUR
SECOND PANELIST ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. OF THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND I THINK THE MORE
WE- YOU KNOW KIND OF WILL TO
LIST DOWN WILL BE ABLE TO LEAVE
HERE WITH SOME. VERY SPECIFIC
ASK BUT I WOULD I WOULD SAY ON
THE WHAT. ARDS TO- WHAT'S
CENTER PANELISTS SAME. I KNOW
MY DAUGHTERS ARE THIRTY AND
THIRTY ONE AND ALL OF THEIR
FRIENDS ARE PLANNING A WEDDING
AND HAD PLANNED WEDDING SO THEY
HAD TO PUT HIM OFF. AND THE
FLEXIBILITY OF THE VENUE- MAYBE
TO POSSIBLY RESCHEDULE A YEAR
LATER HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE AND
THEN DECIDING TO EITHER.
CONTINUE WITH THE VENUE OR EVEN
THE WEDDING- IT BUT- IT IS
DIFFICULT IF YOU'RE THE VENUE
TO KEEP SAYING OKAY WE'VE
EXTENDED IT FOR A YEAR. NOW
WILL DO ANOTHER YEAR SO I THINK
SOME CONSISTENCY IS GOING TO
MEAN A LOT TO- THE OPERATORS OF
WHETHER IT'S A HOTEL OR VENUE
OR SO FORTH. OKAY SO THEY WERE
GOING TO CALL UP AND NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO CALL UP- DAN HARVEY
WHO'S THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
HERTZ CORPORATION. WE WELCOME
HIM. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO COME. ET TODAY- WHAT I'LL
BE REPRESENTED THE RENTAL CAR
INDUSTRY AND I'LL BE TALKING
ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS ARE FROM A
NATIONAL LEVEL AS WELL AS KIND
OF BRING IT AT HOME.
SPECIFICALLY THE CALIFORNIA.
BUT I'M REALLY HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THE RENTAL CAR
INDUSTRY AND GENERALLY ALSO
ABOUT THE FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF HERTZ. SO I'VE WORKED FOR
HERTZ FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
THREE YEARS. JUST OVER HALF OF
THAT HAS BEEN RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO- YOU KNOW LONG
CAREER. WITH A COMPANY THAT IS-
WE JUST CELEBRATED TWO YEARS
AGO OUR HUNDRED YEAR
ANNIVERSARY. I'M REALLY AN
UNBLEMISHED. TIME PERIOD WITH
OUR COMPANY WHERE WE'VE NEVER
BEEN- IN THE FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES SUCH AS WE ARE
TODAY. PURCHASE ONE OF THE MOST
ICONIC COMPANIES OUT THERE- WE
HAVE- WERE A FORTUNE FIVE
COMPANY WITH ALMOST TEN
THOUSAND LOCATIONS IN A HUNDRED
FIFTY COUNTRIES. AND WE ALSO
OWN THE BRANDS FOR DOLLAR
RENTAL CAR AND THRIFTY RENTAL
CAR SO WE'RE ABOUT 35% OF THE
pINDUSTRY ROUGHLY. HERS IS ALSO
YOU KNOW WE TAKE OUR CUSTOMER
SAFETY VERY SERIOUSLY WHERE THE
CURRENT- JD POWER NUMBER ONE IN
CUSTOMER SATISFACTION HOLDER WE
JUST LEARNED THIS MORNING THAT.
WILL RETAIN THAT FOR ANOTHER
YEAR. IT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO US SO WHEN
THIS PANDEMIC STRUCK IN HIT OUR
COMPANY. BESIDES THE- THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT WE KNEW THAT
WE HAD A COMMITMENT TO PROVIDE
A SAFE. INJURY FOR PEOPLE
TRAVELING IN THE CALIFORNIA. IN
THE END GETTING INTO SOMETHING
THAT MAY BE A LITTLE BIT NERVE
WRACKING FOR THEM INTO A RENTAL
CAR SO WHEN THIS PANDEMIC IT
WE- YOU KNOW WE WORK WITH THE
GOVERNMENT HEALTH OFFICIALS. WE
ENHANCED ALREADY ROBUST
CLEANING PROTOCOLS TO MEET
HEALTH CHALLENGES- IN THE
EXPECTATIONS OF OUR CONSUMERS.
WE CREATED A NEW PROGRAM CALLED%
THE GOLD SEAL STANDARD WHICH
BASICALLY MAKES IT SO THAT
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE. THEY'RE
THEY'RE ENTERING INTO A STAR
RENTAL CAR. THAT HAS BEEN
CLEANED. YOU KNOW ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS FROM THE
TIME THAT THE CAR RETURNS AND
THEN EVEN WHEN THE LAST PERSON
THE PARKS THE CAR LEAVES- AND
THEY- RESTORE LIES EVERYTHING
THAT THEY OF TOUCH. AND THEN
SET THAT UP FOR THE NEXT
CUSTOMER. OUR COMPETITORS ALL
TOOK SIMILAR ACTION SO THIS
WASN'T JUST- WITHIN HERDS- BUT
IT ONE TRAVEL STOP IN THE EARLY
SPRING- WE WERE REALLY HIT WITH
A DOUBLE WHAMMY. I MEAN. NUMBER
ONE AIR TRAVEL IS HUGE FOR OUR
BUSINESS I MEAN. IT'S NO
MYSTERY THAT. YOU KNOW MOST OF
THE BUSINESS AT THE AIRPORT
RAIL CARS COMPANIES BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE LOCATED IS
FROM PASSENGERSTHAT ARE
DEPARTING. DEPARTING AIRPLANES.
SO WHEN THIS HAPPENED AND 80%
OF THE FLIGHTS ROUGHLY. STOP
FLYING IN. NOT ONLY DID WE
HAVE. THE CHALLENGE OF NOT
HAVING REVENUE IN THE CARS
GOING BACK OUT BUT EVERYBODY
WAS RETURNING THEIR VEHICLES.
AND SO ALL OF A SUDDEN JUST IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAD SIXTY SIX
THOUSAND CARS THAT WE NEEDED TO
FIND A PLACE TO PARK IN OUR
FACILITIES WE USUALLY RUN ABOUT
8290% UTILIZATION SO. WE DON'T
HAVE THE PROPERTY FOR THAT SO
UNDER THE SCRAMBLE WE CREATE A
LOT OF LEASES WITH PROPERTIES
ALL OF THIS IS THAT ADDITIONAL
COST SO. NOW REVENUES NOT
FLOWING IN. AND WE HAVE A COST
BURDEN THAT WE HAVE NEVER
ANTICIPATED- THAT WAS IN THE
MILLIONS. NOT TO MENTION THAT
THE LACK OF TRAVEL AND REVENUE
FOR THE SECOND QUARTER FOR US
AND PUBLICLY- DOUBLED IT WAS
THAT WE WHAT WE SUFFERED A LOSS
OF 82% AND TOTAL REVENUE.
MEANWHILE YOU KNOW OUR OUR
LEASES STILL CAME DO. THE
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN ABLE TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS THAT HAS
BEEN UNABLE TO PROVIDE ANY
RELIEF FOR THE RENTAL CAR
INDUSTRY CONGRESS AND THE WHITE
HOUSE. HAVE SUSPENDED
DISCUSSIONS FOR RELIEF AND TELL.
AFTER THE ELECTION BUT THE
RESULT IDUSTRY WIDE HAS BEEN
THE LOSSES OF TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF THE LOSS OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS WITHIN OUR
COUNTRY ACROSS THE NATION AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. IN
CALIFORNIA THE RENTAL CAR
INDUSTRY YOU KNOW HAS MADE A
SLOW RECOVERY SINCE THE APRIL
THOSE DIVE. AT SOME OF THE
FLIGHTS HAVE RESUMED. AND HAS
BEEN AIDED SOMEWHAT BY OUR
LOCAL TRAFFIC- IN THE SUMMER
DEMAND FOR ROAD TRIPS A LOT OF
OUR BUSINESS TODAY THAT IS
RESUMING BACK ARE FROM
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THAT ARE
JUST TRYING TO GET OUT AND DO
SOMETHING. BUT WE'RE STILL DOWN
IN TOTAL REVENUE MORE THAN 50%
PER YEAR. NOT SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT HURTS AS YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD THE STORY FOR US IS THAT
IS THAT ESPECIALLY DEVASTATING
I MENTION THE WE'VE BEEN AROUND
FOR A HUNDRED YEARS. BUT WHEN
THIS HAPPENED WE HAD TO REALLY
WE'RE REALLY FORCE WAS A
DIFFICULT DECISION THE FIRST IN
THE TOUGHEST DECISION. WAS THE
ONE THAT IMPACTED THE
LIVELIHOOD OF OUR DEDICATED
WORK FORCE. AND THE OTHER CAME
FROM FILING CHAPTER ELEVEN BACK
IN MAY. AFTER AFTER A HUNDRED
TWO YEARS. WE HAD NO CHOICE BUT
TO REDUCE THE LABOR. IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IN THE REST OF
THE U. S. BY MORE THAN 70%
INITIALLY WITH A MIX OF
FURLOUGHS AND THEN REALLY
TURNED INTO- LAYOFFS. CURRENTLY
IN CALIFORNIA WE STILL HAVE
HALF OF OUR AIRPORT OPERATION
PLEASE- STILL IN THE LAST
STATUS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
UNABLE TO BRING THEM BACK. SO
AS WE SLOWLY RISE FROM THE
BOTTOM OF THE OF THE ECONOMIC
HER. IT IS AN INDUSTRY
SPECIFICALLY SPEAKING FOR HERTZ
WERE REALLY FOCUSED ON CREATING
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT. FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE EMPLOYEES IN
CUFFS CUSTOMERS TO MAKE. PEOPLE
FEEL LIKE TRAVELING IS SAFE AND
IT IS SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
DO IS YOU SEEN AT SOME OF THE-
MARKETING THAT YOU SEEN EARLIER
TODAY. IN ADDITION THE CLEANING
PROCESS OF THE PRODUCT WE HAVE-
YOU KNOW UNPRECEDENTED
PROTOCOLS IN OUR FACILITIES WE
IMPLEMENTED A COMPANY WIDE MASS
POLICY FOR NOT ONLY OUR
EMPLOYEES FOR OUR CUSTOMERS.
THAT WAS A NATIONAL POLICY NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA- PHYSICAL
DISTANCE HE'S MEASURES. IN OUR
LOBBIES AS YOU CAN IMAGINE- WE
HAVE BUSES TO TRANSPORT BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN THE AIRPORT
AND- ENSURING THAT THOSE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING- POLICIES
ARE ARE IN PLACES DIFFICULT
WHEN. YOU'RE TRYING TO STOP
TRAFFIC AND PEOPLE LOADING ON
THE BUSES. BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
O WORK THROUGH THAT WE'VE
CONSTRUCTED BARRIERS FOR
EMPLOYEES TO COMMUNICATE WITH
OUR CUSTOMERS. BOTH IN OUR
FACILITIES AND OUR BUSES. SO
WE'RE CREATING THAT SAFE SPACE
FOR PEOPLE TO COME AND WE FEEL
THAT WE CAN WE CAN INCREASE
THAT WITH VOLUME- WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY THE PURPOSE BEHIND IT
AND MAKING EVERYONE FEEL SAFE.
NOW TO ANSWER SOME OF THE
UPCOMING- QUESTIONS BY
ASSEMBLYMAN CHILL YOU KNOW
KNOWING THAT THE STATE FACES
UNPRECEDENTED BUDGET DEFICITS
THIS COMING YEAR HURTS IS NOT
HERE TO ASK FOR GENERAL FUND
SO. THEY CAN BETTER BE UTILIZED
BY EDUCATION HEALTHCARE AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. WITH THE CAR
INDUSTRY THE CAR RENTAL
INDUSTRY COULD USE- AND THE
HELP. AND WHAT WOULD HELP
COMPANIES LIKE HERTZ RETURN TO
PROFITABILITY AND TO GENERATE
REVENUES FOR ENTITIES LIKE
VISIT CALIFORNIA. AS FOR
LEGISLATURE TO ELIMINATE
DECADES OLD PRICING CONTROLS
THE PASSAGE LEGISLATORS HAVE
IMPOSED ON THE CAR RENTAL
INDUSTRY FOR ELEVEN COLLISION
DAMAGE WAIVER THIS IS. A
SERVICE THAT WE IT'S AN
INSURANCE- WAIVER THAT WE SELL
TO OUR CUSTOMERS- AND ALSO THE
ABILITY TO CHARGE FOR
ADDITIONAL DRIVERS. THESE
RESTRICTIONS ARE VERY UNIQUE IN
CALIFORNIA- THEY'RE NOT- IN
MOST OTHER STATES. AND READ
RELIEVING THESE REGULATIONS
WILL HELP US SO THAT WE CAN
HELP THE STATE TREASURY. AND
HELP TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
ADEQUATE FUNDING TO VISIT
CALIFORNIA. SO THOSE ARE TWO
THINGS SPECIFIC TO OUR INDUSTRY
THE PROBABLY THE THIRD AND I
THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT.
OVERALL IS A SIMILAR MESSAGE
THAT YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY TODAY
AND THAT'S THE CONSISTENCY IN
THE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
MESSAGING. AND WHAT PEOPLE CAN
AND CANNOT DO AND WHAT THE WHAT
THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE AND WHAT
THE CURRENT SITUATION IS TODAY-
FOR EXAMPLE. YOU KNOW IF
SOMEBODY COMES IN AND THEY WANT
TO TAKE A ROAD TRIP TO GO
CAMPING IT'S VERY UNCLEAR.
WHERE THEY CAN GO. THERE THEIR
CAMPING IS AVAILABLE IN SOME
COUNTIES AND THEN YOU GO ACROSS
TO ANOTHER AND IT'S NOT WITHIN
EVEN THOSE INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES
MAYBE A STATE PARK THAT HAVE
CAMPGROUNDS MAY BE CLOSED. WELL
JUST DON'T KNOW AND SO A LOT OF
TIMES YOU'RE JUST GOING OUT AND
DEALING WITH WHATEVER THEY HAVE
TO DEAL WITH. BUT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT. FOR PEOPLE TO WANT
TO TAKE THOSE TRIPS IF THEY
DON'T. HAVE THE CERTAINTY OF
WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
FACE WHEN WE'RE OUT THERE.
YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE. OR YOU
MAY NOT BE AWARE WITH THE
RENTAL CAR INDUSTRYPROVIDES.
THERE'S A CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
REVENUE SEGMENT. THROUGH THE
ASSESSMENTS WRITTEN IN THE BY
DECLINE IN THE REVENUE THIS
DRASTIC IT'S A SERIOUS BLOW TO
OUR BUDGET WHICH HELPS TO
PROVIDE FOR THE MARKETING IN
AWARENESS DELIVERED THROUGH
VISIT CALIFORNIA. THAT IS
PROVEN TO BE SO VITAL IN THE
PAST FOR US. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING IN OUR RECOVERY IN A
PROSPEROUS PROP PROSPEROUS WAY
IN A SAFE WAY THAT WE TOLD YOU
WE WILL LIVE UP TO OUR
COMMITMENT. TO ENSURE THAT WHEN
PEOPLE GET OFF THE AIRPLANE
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO GET TO
THEIR DESTINATIONS IN A SAFE
WAY. AND THAT'S REALLY THE
MESSAGE I WANTED TO GET ACROSS.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER
HARVEY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
DO YOU HAVE ANY REMARKS OR
QUESTIONS JUST BECAUSE- THIS.
I'M JUST GLAD TO BE HERE- TO BE
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC I APOLOGIZE FOR
BEING LATE TO I ACTUALLY HAVE
PROBABLY UP MORE THAN THE
AVERAGE BEAR UP AND TRAVELING
GOOD- ON- ON AIRPLANES ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND I HAVE TO SAY
THAT- IT'S MOSTLY SOUTHWEST AND
IT'S- EVERY FLIGHT HAS BEEN ON
TIME- AND GREAT THERE'S ALWAYS
BEEN A MIDDLE SEAT AVAILABLE
AND- A GREAT COMPLIANCE WITH-
MASKING RICK MASKING
REQUIREMENTS IN A- I THINK A-
FAIR AMOUNT OF COMFORT. TO
AMONGST MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AND THEN OVER THE WEEKEND I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RENT A CAR
AND I HAD THE SAME EXPERIENCE
WITH ONE OF YOUR COMPETITORS TO
ENSURE VERY SIMILAR TO- OF THE
SERVICE THAT THAT HURTS IS
PROVIDING AND I. THINK GOING
FORWARD THAT. THAT OF US
STELLAR SERVICE I SHOULD SAY
THIS WAS THE FIRST FLIGHT ON
SOUTHWEST THAT ACTUALLY GOT
CANCELED BECAUSE IT WAS A
MECHANICAL PROBLEM AND THAT'S
WHY I. WAS LATE I HAD TO SWITCH
OVER. TO ANOTHER FLIGHT BUT I
THINK THAT THAT HIGH LEVEL OF
SERVICE. THAT PROVIDES A LEVEL
OF COMFORT- FOR- PATRONS OF
THE- OF THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
AND PARTICULARLY THE HIGH.
COMMUNITY IS GOING TO BE KEY TO
COMING BACK- AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE FROM THE- PANDEMIC AND
TO BEING ABLE TO. BEGIN TO
OFFSET THE TERRIBLE ECONOMIC-
COSTS THAT WE'VE WE'VE
SUFFERED- AND I'M QUITE CERTAIN
THAT- THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
KEY TO. A DOMESTIC TRAVEL AND A
RETURN TO NORMALCY- AND DOUBLY
CERTAIN THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE
TRUE FOR INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL
IN. BOTH OF THESE ARE- OF
FUNDAMENTALS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND TO IN PARTICULAR
THE ECONOMY OF A LOT OF FUN- OF
THOSE WHO ARE SITTING HERE ON
THE- ON THE DICE TODAY AND
PARTICIPATE IN THIS IN THIS
COMMITTEE. I DID HAVE- BUT
WANTED TO ASK- CUT YOU MISTER
HARVEY ONE NOT A FOR ONE
CLARIFICATION I MAY HAVE MISSED
IT BUT- THE ISSUE WITH THE
CAMPGROUNDS WHAT IS THAT- HAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR SPECIFICALLY
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. DID THE
SOME TYPE OF A WAY FOR. PEOPLE
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING BETWEEN THE COUNTIES
WITHOUT HAVING TO YOU KNOW CALL
EACH COUNTY AHEAD OF TIME READ
THROUGH THE DOCUMENTS THAT WILL
TELL THEM WHAT THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS ARE. I MEAN IT
REALLY COULD IT STARTS WITH
CONSISTENCY IF THERE WASN'T
STATEWIDE CONSISTENCY. THEN
THAT WOULD BE EASY RIGHT
BECAUSE THEN- EVERYBODY WOULD
KNOW PRETTY MUCH WHAT'S GOING
ON EVERYWHERE ELSE BUT WE HAVE
THE INCONSISTENCIES WITHIN THE
COUNTIES. WE KNOW THAT WITH THE
COUNTY IS BEING ABLE. TO BE.
WHETHER OR NOT IT INTO WHAT
PACE THEY'RE GOING TO OPEN THAT
CAUSES A LOT OF CONFUSION SO IF
THERE WAS SOMETHING THAT IF IT
WAS GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
INCONSISTENT BY BY COUNTIES.
SOME WAY THAT EACH COUNTY HAS A
STANDARD YOU KNOW SOME TYPE OF
A STANDARD VIEW DOCUMENT THAT
SAYS WHAT THE STATUS OF THE-
COUNTY IS IN WHAT IS AND WHAT
IS NOT. AVAILABLE TO DO WITHOUT
REALLY HAVING TO READ THROUGH
YOU KNOW THE LEGAL DOCUMENTS TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE LAST
ORDER. OKAY THANK YOU LET ME
GIVE THAT SOME THOUGHT. AT I
THINK THAT WAS MENTIONED BEFORE
ON THE CONSISTENCY THAT- FOR
EXAMPLE MASK YOU HAVE SOME
CITIES THAT MADE A MASK
ORDINANCE SOME COUNTIES THAT
HAVE MADE AMOUNT MASSPORT ANTS
OR ARE NOT IN ALLIANCE EVEN
WITH. THE CITY IN THEIR AREA
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE STATE SO
IT IS VERY CONFUSING. FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT THERE AND
ICE I THINK THAT WORD THAT
KEEPS COMING UP CONSISTENCY
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR- MANY
PEOPLE JUST TO KNOW WHEN I'M
OUT I'M DOING THIS OR SO FORTH
YEAH MADAM CHAIR EVEN FOR AN
EXAMPLE THAT YOU JUST THAT THE
DAY YOU REALLY MADE ME THINK OF
IS THAT YOU KNOW ONE WEEK WHEN
HE CAME OUT AS A COMPANY WITH.
A NATIONAL MASS POLICY FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS AND OUR OUR
EMPLOYEES- PART OF WHAT WAS
DRIVING THAT OF COURSE SAFETY
IS A BIG FACTOR OF IT BUT ALSO
BECAUSE SOME STATES REQUIRED IN
SOME STATES DON'T REQUIRE IT.
OUR EMPLOYEES WERE HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME ENFORCING IT
BECAUSE THE TRAVELERS DIDN'T
KNOW WHERE THEY WERE GOING WHAT
WAS WHAT WAS THE EXPECTATION
THERE. SOMEONE WE WERE ABLE TO
PUT A BLANKET STATEMENT ON OUR
COMPANY WEBSITE THAT SHOWED OR
FROM THE PHONE OR WHAT HAVE YOU
RESERVE YOUR CAR THAT SAID.
THIS IS NO MATTER WHERE YOU GO
IT HURTS THIS IS WHAT OUR
POLICY IS THAT GREATLY REDUCED
OUR EMPLOYEES WERE VERY
THANKFUL THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THOSE SITUATIONS
BECAUSE MORE PEOPLE WERE
COMPLIANT BECAUSE. THEY KNEW
WHAT THE EXPECTATIONS WERE
AHEAD OF TIME. SENATE PAN.
THANK YOU THINK. SO IT. WE DO
HAVE A STATEWIDE MASK OR BUT I
KNOW THAT WE CHANNEL AS WORKING
WITH THE VERY YOU KNOW THE C.
P. C. PH N. CHEERING FROM
DIFFERENT COUNT HEALTH.
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW IT THIS DOES
CHANGE INTO ACCOUNT THE IS A
BIG RIGHT SO WHAT HAPPENS IS.
WHAT A. AND SAN DIEGO MAYBE
BRADY ONE HALF UP IN CHEST.
ABOUT THE- FROM SACRAMENTO TO
THE BAY AREA CELLS. I GUESS ONE
JUST CLARIFICATION- IS THAT.
YOU KNOW WE COULD PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO TRAVELERS THAT'S
KIND OF LIKE THE- THIS EARLY
THE MOST RECENT I CAN MUSTER
STICK IT'S NOT QUITE THE RIGHT
WORD BUT- BUT IN TERMS OF IT IS
IT THAT. AND THEN HAVE IT'S
POSSIBLE TO REGION MAY BE LESS
RESTRICTIVE THAT THEY'RE
TRAVELING AND IF THEY'RE GOOD.
DOES THAT HELP THE ARE ANY I
GUESS THE PROBLEM I GUESS. I
GET IT YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING BUT I ALSO THINK PART OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT YOU KNOW
YOUR CALIFORNIA. WE GENERALLY
HAVE A LOT OF LOCAL CONTROL-
THAT'S- AND IT'S NOT JUST IN.
PUBLIC HEALTH WITH A WHOLE
LAYER OF DIFFERENT THINGS AS
WELL A LOT OF DIFFERENT AREAS
AS WELL SO- IT'S PROBABLY GONNA
BE VERY DIFFICULT FOR SOMETHING
THAT. YOU KNOW STOP FLIES
ACROSS THE STATE- THERE ARE FEW
THINGS IS THAT LIKE A MASK OR
IT COULD TRY TO PLAY ACROSS THE
STATE THERE MAY BE VARIATIONS
ENFORCEMENT DEPENDING ON THE
LOCALITY BUT- AND TERMS OF-
GUIDANCE TO TRAVELERS WHO ARE
COMING LET'S SAY TO CALIFORNIA
WANT TO TRAVEL- IT IS. IS THERE
YOU'RE BASICALLY SAYING LIKE.
PEOPLE JUST TO CONFUSE AND
THEREFORE THEY WANT TO COME. WE
CAN PROVIDE SOME LIGHT.
GUIDANCE TO THEM. YEAH EVEN IF
IT'S MORE COLD RESTRICTIVE THAN
MAY. BE HAPPENING THE COUNTY
THAT WOULD. ACTUALLY BE BETTER.
YES AND SO CURRENTLYI'M MOST
OF THE TRI THAT WERE CATERING.
YEAH TODAY LOCAL PEOPLE ARE
LOCAL TO ANY RIGHT SO THE- EVEN.
WITHIN RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
SO JUST NOT KNOWING WHERE TO GO
SO. UNDERSTANDING THAT. NOT
ANYTIME SOON ARE WE GOING TO
CHANGE IT TO WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT OR THE WORK TO WHERE
THE STATE POLICY. OVER RULES
THE COUNTY POLICY TO WHERE
EVERYBODY'S DOING THE SAME
THING IF THERE WAS SOME TYPE OF
A CONSIDER MAYBE HAVE LIKE THAT
THE TOP TEN THINGS THAT PEOPLE
ARE LOOKING FOR WHEN THEY'RE
GOING. ON A ROAD TRIP- ON A
TRAVELING TRIP OR WHATEVER
THEY'RE GOING TO GO. WHETHER
IT'S- THE STATUS OF THE HOTELS
THE STATUS OF THE RESTAURANTS
WHETHER OR NOT IF THEY'RE ABLE
TO HAVE INDOOR DINING OR
OUTDOOR DINING. THAT A
CHECKLIST WILL ACT CAMPING TO
THAT BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY
BECAUSE I BROUGHT THAT UP
EARLIER. THAT THERE WOULD BE
SOME TYPE OF A STANDARD
DOCUMENT WERE OR PLACE THAT YOU
COULD GO AND JUST LOOK AT. EACH
COUNTIES- EACH COUNTIES CURRENT
GUIDELINES AND WHAT THEY'RE
WHAT THEY'RE ALLOWING THAT
WOULD MAKE IT A LOT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO SEE. YOU KNOW ONE
WHERE WHERE CAN WE GO IF WE'RE
LOOKING TO DO X. Y. NZ AND ALSO
WHERE NOT TO GO. SO IF PEOPLE
DON'T END UP CHAU UP THERE.
THAT AND THEN FOR OUT LATER
WELL WE MADE THIS TRIP FOR
NOTHING BECAUSE WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO DO THAT'S WHERE AS IF. WE
WOULD HAVE. BEEN ABLE TO SEE
THIS AT A TIME WE WERE GONE
SOMEWHERE ELSE TO WEAR THIS IS
FRIENDLY. OKAY SO IT MIGHT BE.
WHAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL IS THAT
TRYING TO IN A FIVE WHAT ARE
THE- ITEMS. THAT THE TOURISM
INDUSTRY SO I ON A VISIT
CALIFORNIA HIGH TECH THAT HONOR
WHOEVER. THAT DO YOU THINK
TRAVELERS WOULD BE MOST
INTERESTED IN. AND THEN TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE FEED
INFORMATION INTO A GRADE OR
SOMETHING THAT. GIVES SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN LOOK IT UP AND
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO. WAIT
THROUGH EACH COUNTY WEBSITE TO
FIGURE THAT OUT IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT. MIGHT BE
HELPFUL YEAH I THINK SO I MEAN
I'M VISUALIZING THAT AND I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE THAT
WOULD DEFINITELY BE HELPFUL
OKAY. CERTAINLY I MEAN YOU KNOW
THE PUBLIC ALSO TO DELIVER
WHOLE BUNCH OF DIFFERENT THINGS
BUT- MAYBE IF THERE WAS SOME
WAY TO SAY OKAY WHAT WHAT ARE
THE THINGS THAT. FROM YOUR
EXPERIENCE- THAT TRAVELERS
REALLY CARE ABOUT THAT WILL
HELP THEM. MAKE FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE BUT TRAVELING AND
SAY HEY YOU KNOW 'M GOING TO
DO THESE THINGS. THAT THAT
MIGHT DOES TEN THAT MEANS THAT
WILL ALLOW SOME OF THE OTHER
FOLKS TO. FOCUS YOUR EFFORTS
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO GUESTS
LIKE OKAY YOU KNOW HE'S LIKE
ALL RIGHT I HAVE TO. DEAL WITH
THIS YOU KNOW WORKPLACES AND
SCHOOLS AND A WHOLE BUNCH OF
THEIR LIST OF DIFFERENT. THINGS
AS WELL SO. ALL. RIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU A COUPLE. THANK YOU
CENTER. AND THANK MISTER. WE
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US. WE
GO TO THE NEXT COUNTLESS WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL INVITING GUESTS SO
AS THEY COME UP AND MAKE THEIR
WAY WE'RE GONNA ASK OUR
PANELISTS OF HERE IF WE CAN
KIND OF HOLD QUESTIONS SO WE
CAN GET BACK ON A LITTLE TIME
SCHEDULE. BUT OUR NEXT A
PRESENTER IS FROM UNITE HERE
FRANK SANTOS. THAT'S RIGHT.
WITH THE- HELP AREAS ON AND BE
TALK ABOUT THE WORK FORCE.
WELCOME THANK YOU- THANKS TO
THE ASSEMBLY TO REMAIN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE. TO
EXPLORE SMILEY LANCASTER
CENTERS CAN YOU PUT THE MIKE
JUST A LITTLE CLOSER TO YOU
YEAH BECAUSE SO WE ARE HERE
YEAH INVESTORS HOLD PULL IT
DOWN A LITTLE BIT. YEAH YEAH.
YES LIKE THAT. ALL RIGHT MY
NAME IS FRANK CENTERS ON
NETWORK AT THE TO RUNNING A
RESTART IN RANCHO PALOS VERDES
FOR A YEARS I AM SHIFTING
BANQUETS- JOB. HUNDREDS OF MY
COLLEAGUES- AND I WE ARE LAID
OFF. IN MARCH DO IT TO DEPEND
THEY MAKE. DEFIER YOU MAY OR
HOTEL REOPENED IN JUNE. AND I
HAVE NOT BEING CALLED- TO WORK
LIKE A HUNDREDS OF MY- MY
COWORKERS- I'M A FATHER AND I
HAVE THE LIVE TO TRY. TO
PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY WITH A
LEADER THAT I GET ENOUGH POINTS.
I HAVE ALSO BEEN LEFT WITHOUT
HEALTH CARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE HEALTH CRISIS. HI OF THE
MONEY THAT WE RECEIVE WE NOT
EMPLOYMENT GOES TO. PAY PRIVATE
INSURANCE'S ON B. COPAYS. I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF UC'S
HOUSEKEEPERS BANNERMAN'S FRONT
DISC AGENTS DISHWASHERS I PER
WORKERS SERVERS AND BARTENDERS
FROM ACROSS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
LOOKING TO SACRAMENTO FOR
LEADERSHIP AT THE TIME. WHERE
WE HAVE BEEN LEFT WITH ALMOST
NOTHING I'M NO LEGAL RIGHTS TO
RETURN TO OUR JOB. I COME TO
SACRAMENTO ALONG WITH DOZENS OF
WORKERS FROM ALL ACROSS THE
STATE BACK IN SEPTEMBER.
LOOKING FOR LEADERSHIP ORIGIN
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM TO SAME.
THE AB THREE TO SIXTEEN.
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM VOTED BE
TOOK AB THIRTY TO SIXTY. JUST
HOURS BEFORE THE DEADLINE. THE
LAW. WILL HAVE A GRANTED
WORKERS LAY OFF TO RECALL THE
NINETEEN A RIGHT TO RETURN TO
OUR ALL JOBS WHEN BUSINESS
REOPENS. SIMILAR LOS IN SERENE
THIS PROTECTIONS HAVE BEEN
PASSED IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES LONG BEACH. PASADENA
GLENDALE SENT MONICA AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. WE HOPE. AT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
EVENTUALLY FOLLOW. I'M HOPEFUL
BUT BY BEING HERE TODAY AND
SHARING MY STORY THIS GOVERNING
BODY WILL BEGIN TO RIDE
GOVERNOR NEWS SUN WRONG. DAME
PARTS. CALL THE NINETEEN HOUSE
OF AND WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE OR
INDUSTRY. IN THE HEAVY LAYOFFS
I'M FIGHTING FIGHTING'S ARE
CONTINUING TO HAPPENS. I'M
ACROSS THE INDUSTRY FOR EXAMPLE.
AS OF TOMORROW HMS HOST ONE OF
THE LARGEST CONCESSIONS
COMPANIES IN NORTH AMERICA
HOUSE ANNOUNCES THAT IT WILL
NOT BE RECALLING HUNDREDS OF
FEET SLAY OF WORKERS A JONES
WIN ARE PERFECT LEAVING THEM TO
FEND FOR THEMSELVES THREE
INDEPENDENT MAKE WITHOUT THE
SECURITY OF KNOWING. THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO RETURN TO THEIR JOBS.
HOW MANY WORK HOW MANY MORE
WORKERS AND FAMILIES MUST BE
IMPACTED FOR THIS GOVERNING
BODY TO TAKE ACTION I
UNDERSTAND WORKERS. ONE MORE IS
ONE TOO MANY SOURCE FIDELITY
WORKERS LIKE MYSELF. OUR TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA HOSPITALITY AND
TOURISM HAS THREE GREAT. WE ARE
THE ONES YOU WANT TO BE WORKING
THIS JOBS WHEN THINGS GET
BETTER. WE HAVE THIS
BRILLIANCE- PROFESSIONALISM TO
DO SO. WE ARE THE BACKBONE OF
THE ECONOMY WE WERE YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND HOPE TO
CONTINUE EIGHT CHARLIE OR
STORIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER SANTOS I JUST SAID WE'LL
HOLD QUESTIONS BUT- HERE TO-
YOUR STORY IS SO IMPACTFUL SO
WHO DO WE HAVE ANY OF FOR
MEMBERS THAT WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT. WE THANK YOU FOR
REPRESENTING I KNOW WHAT'S
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS AS I LIVE
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND A
REPRESENTATIVE. NOT ONLY.
DISNEYLAND THAT IS IN MY
DISTRICT BUT A NOT VERY FARM
MANY MANY HOTELS AND SO FORTH
AND I KNOW. NOT ONLY THE IMPACT
ON THE INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES LIKE
YOURS BUT ON THE CITY'S AND
REALLY THE ENTIRE ECONOMY SO-
WE SEND OUR PRAYERS TO YOUR
FAMILY AND I KNOW- AS FRONT
LINE WORKERS- SOME OF THEM HAVE
BEEN. IMPACTED WITH CLOVER
THEMSELVES NO THANK YOU FOR
COMING TO SHARE. THANK YOU OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. I'M SO SOME OF OUR
BLUE YEAH I'LL JUST ADD A COM I
THINK THAT MR SANTURCE IS. A
STATEMENT AS REFLECTIVE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE AROUND THE STATE THAT
HAVE LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN.
DEEPLY AFFECTED BY- BY THE
PANDEMIC IN THE ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED. IN ITS WAKE UP ON TOP
OF THAT- MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR STATE HAVE
HAD TO DEAL WITH A. A VERY
DYSFUNCTIONAL EDT- AND THAT HAS
MADE MATTERS ONLY WORSEN I
KNOW- MR CHU YOU'VE BEEN- I
JUST CHAMPION ON- POINTING OUT
TO OF THOSE ISSUES AND ALL OF
OUR STAFFS HAVE BEEN WORKING
OVERTIME TO TRY AND RESOLVE
ISSUES FOR. CONSTITUENTS BUT-
THIS IS- I'M I'VE CERTAINLY
NEVER EXPERIENCED ANYTHING LIKE
THIS IN MY LIFE AND I HOPE I
NEVER. DO AGAIN- BUT WE'RE
LEARNING A LOT OF LESSONS AND
APPRECIATE THE A STATEMENT
FROM- FROM THE GENTLEMAN. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT. MISTER PAM SORRY
SENATOR THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE TESTIMONY FROM UNITE HERE
AND I GUESS I. YOU CAN IN THE
ABSENCE OF THE LAW I WOULD URGE
EMPLOYERS- TO- IF THERE AND I
UNDERSTAND DEALS EVERYONE'S
FACING TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC
STRESS BUT IF YOU DO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO START RE OPENING
AGAIN. AND THAT DAY DID YOU I
HOPE YOU LOOK TO YOUR YET THAT
THE WORKERS WHO'VE BEEN WORKING
FOR YOU FREAK OUT OF IT HE MAY
HAVE HAD TO LAY OFF. AND
PRIORITIZE BRING THEM BACK- YOU
KNOW THAT IT WE PEOPLE NEED TO
HAVE SOE. SENSE OF. STABILITY
ALSO I MEAN LOYALTY SHOULD
MATTER SOMEONE WHOSE WORK FOR
YOU SHOULD SHOULD TAP SHOULD
TAP THE OPPORTUNITY FIRST
OPPORTUNITY HE'LL COME BACK IF
YOU ARE ABLE TO DO SO AND I
THINK YOU KNOW WE'RE HERE
TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE
CAN TRY TO BRING AT LEAST SOME
OF THOSE JOBS BACK. SO THAT IF
WE CAN BRING BACK SOME OF THOSE
JOBS I STRONGLY URGE EMPLOYERS
TO. BRING BACK PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THEM. PRIOR
TO COVERAGE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO- JOE COMMITTEE CALL WHO IS A
BUSINESS AGENT FOR TEAMSTERS
LOCAL SIX SIX FIVE AND WE'LL BE
TALKING ABOUT A SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS AND WITH DRIVERS
AND TRUCK OPERATIONS. WELCOME
MUINTIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANKS FOR HAVING ME. I'M
ACTUALLY HERE TO TALK MORE
ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT- COVE IT
HAS HAD ON OUR MEMBERSHIP- MY
NAME IS JOE MATTOCK CAL-
TEACHERS LOCAL SIX SIX FIVE I-
FIRST BECAME A TEAM STIR BACK
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT MOM AS
A DRIVER AND INSTALLER FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION- ARM OF THE
TEAMSTERS- JUST LAST YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN JULY I BECAME A
BUSINESS AGENT- FOR. LOCAL. SIX
SIX FIVE. I WE HAVE- PRE CODE
SIX THOUSAND. ACTIVE MEMBERS-
WE'RE CURRENTLY DOWN TO FOUR
THOUSAND- ABOUT 95% OF THOSE.
LAYOFFS ARE DUE TO THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF THE-
TOURISM INDUSTRY- JUST TO GIVE
SOME EXAMPLES- WE HAVE. OUR
PART IN THE PARKING INDUSTRY
ALONE WITH BETWEEN I SAN
FRANCISCO SERVING HOTELS
RESTAURANTS AS WELL AS- THE
PARKING FACILITIES AT THE
AIRPORT SFO AS WELL AS SAN JOSE.
WE HAVE AGAIN PRETTY COVERED
ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS
CURRENTLY EVEN WITH SOME CALL
BACK TO BE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
NOW THAT ARE OUT WORKING- WE
ALSO REPRESENT- DRIVERS- FOR
SHUTTLE BUSES ON THAT TREND FOR
PEOPLE PEOPLE FROM THE AIRPORT
TO THE HOTEL DOES WELL AS
AROUND- AIRPORTS AS A FOLLOWS
WELL AS AS WELL AS SAN JOSE-
ABOUT ABOUT A- SEVENTY PERCENT-
HIT- IN TERMS. OF LAYOFFS-
WE'VE ALSO. USED TO THROW A
COUPLE MORE AT YEAR WE HAVE
SMART CARD AT THE AIRPORTS OF
THE- SMARTCARDS THOUGH THE ONES
THAT YOU LOVE YOUR LUGGAGE
AROUND ON OUR MEMBERS ARE THE
ONES THAT- WHEN YOU JUST LEAVE
THE CAR WHEREVER YOU'RE DONE
WITH IT THEY FIND AND PUT HIM
BACK FOR SUPPOSED TO BE- BAY
THEY HAD LIKE A 95% HIT- OUT.
AT THE AIRPORT. ADDITIONALLY WE
HAVE TAXI DISPATCHES OUT THERE
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE PEOPLE ARE
GETTING AND TAXIS AND I'M NOT
GOING TO THE AIRPORT SO. THEY
HAD A HUGE IMPACT THEIR- THE
RENTAL CARS- WE REPRESENT THE-
SERVICE AGENTS WHICH OF THE CAR
WASHERS- IN MAY WESAW WHEN
THIS FIRST HAPPENED ABOUT A
NINETY FIVE PERCENT- LAY OFF
RIGHT THERE- THEY HAVE
INCREMENTALLY BROUGHT SOME
PEOPLE BACK- NO ONE THING I
WILL SAY ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE
RUN UP OUR INDUSTRY J. AS DAN
WAS MENTIONING AND I WAS I WAS
IN THE VIDEO THAT WAS SHOWN ARE
THERE AS WELL- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THESE ENHANCE CLEANING
PROTOCOLS BUT- THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE STILL WORKING ARE.
STILL EXPECTED TO CLEAN AS MANY
CARS AS THEY WERE CLEANING
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC- INC. BUT
NOW INCLUDING YOU KNOW USING
THOSE- ENHANCE PUT YOU KNOW
CLEANING PROTOCOLS WOULD HAVE
PUT A LOT OF STRESS ON THOSE
THAT ARE BACK TO WORK YOU KNOW
AS WELL. SO I DO WANT TO SAY
THERE HAVE BEEN AND I MENTIONED
IT A LITTLE BIT- THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME JOBS THAT HAVE COME
BACK IN SOME HIGHER BUT IT'S
BEEN VERY VERY MINIMAL- WE- I
GUESS ULTIMATELY I MEAN YOU
KNOW I I'M TALKING ABOUT ALL
THESE NEGATIVE THINGS MORE
POSITIVE PERSON IN GENERAL AND
I YOU KNOW I WOULD NEVER
IMAGINE I THINK NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM WOULD IMAGINE THE SORT OF
GONE ON THIS LONG AND HAS SUCH
AN IMPACT IT HAS HAD- JUST
HOPING THAT- WITH THE HOLIDAYS
ARE COMING AND ABOUT THE ROLE
INCIDENT INTO THE NEW YEAR-
THINGS WILL TURN AROUND HELP TO
GET THIS INDUSTRY BACK ON ITS
FEET. I OWE IT WOULDN'T
INCLUDING HERE I JUST WANT TO I
KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO SPEED
THINGS UP BUT IT'S I MEAN SURE
YOU ASK FOR A FEW. THINGS
ALLOW- A FEW. SPECIFICALLY
WITH- THE TOURISM INDUSTRY BUT
JUST IN GENERAL I WANT I JUST
WANT TO SEE MORE BROADLY- YOU
KNOW JUST WITH OUR LOCAL ALONE.
AS YOU AS OF YOU'VE HEARD WE
HAVE ABOUT YOU KNOW A THIRD OF
THEM LAID OFF ON LIVING IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. TRYING
TO LIVE OFF OF. ET DE WHICH IF
THEY CAN GET IT RIGHT ONE BUT
TRY TO LIVE OFF OF FOR FIFTY
WEEK IF THEY GET THE MAX-
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH TO COVER
YOUR- MEDICAL EXPENSES FOR YOUR
FAMILY. I WAS JUST MENTIONED SO
ASSISTANCE- FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN LAID OFF ADDITIONALLY
ASSISTANCE. WAS MENTIONED TO
OPEN YOU KNOW FOR SOME OF THESE
BUSINESSES TO REOPEN.
ASSISTANCE FOR SOME OF THESE
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE. THAT
HAVE- HAD TO LAY OFF A LOT OF
THESE WORKERS- YOU KNOW WE HAD.
A LOT OF OUR- GROUPS AND- HER
TO BE A ONE OF ON OF OUR
EMPLOYERS ACTUALLY FURLOUGHED A
LOT OF EMPLOYEES AND CONTINUE
TO PAY THEIR MEDICAL WHILE THEY
COULDN'T HAVE THEM YOU KNOW ON
BOARD WITH US IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE SELF I THINK YOU
KNOW AND THIS IS NOT A PLEA TO
GET THE MONEY FOR HURTS BUT
JUST SOME SOME ASSISTANCE FOR
SOME OF THE SMALLER BUSINESSES
WELL TO TRY TO. YOU KNOW. GET
THINGS BACK IN ORDER THERE AND
GET THESE WORKERS BACK- BACK
WORKING. NOW I GUESS LASTLY-
IT'S KIND OF. YOU KNOW- PILE ON
TOP OF WHAT IT WAS ALREADY SAID
WHAT JUST FINDING WAYS THAT WE
CAN AND I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
HERE OR HOW BUT- JUST STUFF
FINALIZE WE CAN OPEN UP SAFELY
GET YOU KNOW GET MORE
BUSINESSES OPEN UP AND GET MORE
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK SO. THANK
YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR TIME OR FOR. ALLOWING ME
THE TIME TO SPEAK IN A- I GUESS
SINCE THERE'S NO QUESTION. I'LL
GET UP. WELL THANK YOU CAN YOU
LET YOUR MEMBERS KNOW THAT-
WE'RE WISHING THEM WELL WE KNOW
IT'S BEEN A MAJOR HIT TO THEM
AS WELL AND- WANT TO SEE THEM
BACK TO WORK AS WELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. I CANNOT
ASSURE JUST ONE I JUST WANT
ALSO SAY TO MY TEAMSTERS LOCAL
AND ALSO TO THE PRIOR- INJURY-
WORKERS. THIS IN THIS HEARING
ROOM JUST LAST WEEK WE HAVE
MANY LEGISLATORS THAT I
CONTINUE TO ASK VERY TOUGH
QUESTIONSOF EDT AND THEIR
CONTINUAL FAILURES- OF OUR
STATE AND TAKE CARE OF OUR
EMPLOYEES WORKERS AND ANY
FEEDBACK THAT YOU HAVE TO US
SPECIFICALLY RUN EDT AND- OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING- IF WE COULD TAKE TO
UNDERSTAND THE- THE PERSPECTIVE
THE TEAMSTERS AND UNITED
CHARITY BUT- REST ASSURED WE'RE
WE'RE FIGHTING VERY HARD TO
DEMAND MORE ACCOUNTABILITY FROM
THAT AGENCY BECAUSE THEY HAVE.
UTTERLY FAILED MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA WORKERS AT THIS
TIME- BUT I ALSO WANT ALONG
WITH THE CHURCH COUNCIL OR MY
REGARDS TO WORK TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES AND WORKFORCE AND
AGAIN HOPE WE CAN FIGURE OUT AS
SOON AS WE CAN HOW TO REOPEN
THE ECONOMY SO WORKS FOR
EVERYONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NOT WILL CALL UP THEN- LISA
ALLEN WHOSE OPERATION MANAGERS
OF TOURIST SALES IN CALIFORNIA
TOURISM. WITH AMADOR STAGE
LINES. WELCOME LISA HI THERE
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME TODAY IT'S AN HONOR
TO BE HERE AND VERY NICE THAT
WE CAN ALL GET TOGETHER AND DO
THIS MY NAME IS LISA ALLEN AND
I'M THE OPERATIONS MANAGER MY
FAMILY MOTOR COACH BUSINESS
AMADOR STAGE FIND HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. IT'S AN HONOR TO
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATION THE MOTOR COACH
COMPANIES TO MAKE UP THE GROUND
TRANSPORTATION INTENT OF
CALIFORNIA TOURISM. MANY DON'T
KNOW THAT OF HOW MOTOR COACH
COMPANIES FAMILY AND OPERATED.
AMADOR SAVE FINDS THE SOUND IN
AN EIGHTEEN FIFTY TWO AS A
STAGE COACH COMPANY. KERRY
MINORS IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA
TO THE GOLD COUNTRY. MY
GRANDPARENTS STARTED A CHARTER
IN SCHOOL BUS SERVICE IN
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. AND THEN
PURCHASE AMADOR IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX. AND THE WHEELS HAVE
BEEN ROLLING EVER SINCE OR
SHOULD I SAY UNTIL NOW. PEOPLE
ASK HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN IN
THE BEST BUSINESS. I AND I USED
TO LIVE IN A WOMB TO TOMB. MY
PARENTS MET AT A MOTOR COACH
CONVENTION AND I'VE BEEN
SURROUNDED BY THE BUS WORLD
EVER SINCE I WAS BORN. NOW
INSTEAD OF ONE TO TWO. I
WORRIED IT'S WILLING TO YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY. CURRENTLY THE
CHARTER BUS INDUSTRIES BUSINESS
HAS COME TO A COMPLETE HALT. WE
WENT FROM NINETY MOVES A DAY TO
TWO. AND THOSE TWO ARE BECAUSE
THEY'RE SMALL CONTRACT MOVE FOR
THE MILITARY HERE LOCALLY IN
SACRAMENTO. IN FACT ANOTHER
CALIFORNIA BUS COMPANY MOVE
TROOPS TO THE U. S. MERCY AND
LONG BEACH ONE CALLED IN MARCH.
WHEN COVERT HEAD AND THE
GOVERNOR DECLARED AN EMERGENCY
WE STARTED GETTING CANCELLATION
AFTER CANCELLATION. FOR TRIPS
FROM MARCH UNTIL PRESENT DAY.
WE REFUNDED ALL OF OUR
CUSTOMERS PREPAYMENT. ALTHOUGH
THE CHARTER TO STOP COMING IN
THIRD STILL BILLS THAT NEED TO
BE PAID FOR. OUR BUSINESSES
HAVE LOAN PAYMENTS ON NEW CARB
COMPLIANT BUSES. IN FACT WE
WERE ONE OF THE FIRST COMPANIES
TO COVER OUR FLEET BEFORE THE
CORPORALS WERE IN PLACE. WE
HAVE BEEN WE HAVE BUILDING
PAYMENTS INSURANCE PAYMENTS
HEALTHCARE PAYMENTS. DMV
REGISTRATION PAYMENTS AND MORE.
SPEAKING OF DMV REGISTRATION
PAYMENTS. HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PAY A HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND AND BASS REGISTRATION
FEES FOR VEHICLES AND NOT BE
ABLE TO USE THEM. IT'S A LOT OF
MONEY HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND INR BUSTER SITTING IN
OUR YARD. OUR STORY IS THE SAME
STORY IN A DIFFERENT VERSION
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA BUS
ASSOCIATIONS. OVERALL THIS IS A
FAIRNESS ISSUE WE ARE
COMPLETELY SHUT DOWN AS A
BUSINESS BECAUSE OF THE
GOVERNOR STAY HOME ORDER. NOW
OUR INDUSTRY IS SIMPLY ASKING
FOR A CREDIT. OF OUR DMV
REGISTRATION FEES FOR TWENTY.
THAT WE CAN USE TOWARDS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IT'S NOT FAIR TO
CHARGE COMPANIES THESE DMV
REGISTRATION FEES IF WE REALLY
CAN OPERATE AND TELL THE
GOVERNOR DECLARES THIS PHASE
FOR. BEFORE YOU KNOW IT
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL
BE HERE OUR DMV RENEWAL OF
REGISTRATION FEES WILL BE DUE.
FOR MANY COMPANIES THIS WILL BE
THE STRAW THE BREAKS THE
CAMEL'S BACK THERE'S NO INCOME
EVERYTHING EACH FAMILY BUSINESS
HAS FOUGHT FOR COULD BE THROWN
OUT THE WINDOW IN A BLINK OF AN
EYE. TODAY WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
TALK ABOUT OUR WONDERFUL TOUR
THE MARKET. FROM THE BEACHES TO
THE REDWOODS. TO THE MANY WINE
COUNTRIES ALL OVER THE STATE
EVERYONE CAN FIND SOMETHING
THEY CAN ENJOY IN CALIFORNIA.
DURING THIS TIME TOURISM HAS
COME TO AN END. SO BUSES HAVE
COME TO AN END. IN THE PAST WHO
DO FORTY TRIPS TO DISNEYLAND
PER WEEKEND IN MAY FOR GRAD
NIGHTS. WE WOULD DO WINE
COUNTRY TRIPS WEDDINGS YOU
SOMEBODY TRIPS CULTURAL TRIPS
YOU NAME IT WE WERE OUT THERE.
WITHOUT HEALTH IS PREDICTED
THAT 8290% OF US COMPANIES WILL
GO OUT OF BUSINESS. WHO WILL
MOVE CALIFORNIA TOURIST ALL OF
OUR WONDERFUL SPOTS. WE WENT
FROM A HUNDRED AND TEN
EMPLOYEES TO CURRENTLY TEN
EMPLOYEES. INSTEAD OF KEEPING
EMPLOYEES ON FURLOUGH WE
RECENTLY HADTO LET MANY
EMPLOYEES GO THAT I WORKED
FIRST FOR TWENTY TO THIRTY
YEARS. THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
JUST EMPLOYEES. THEIR FAMILY.
THEY HAVE WATCH MY FAMILY GROW
AND WE'VE WATCHED THEIR- TO
THINK WE HAVE THE TO LET THEM
GO WAS DEVASTATING. BUT IT'S
REALLY THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
SURVIVE. WE ARE NOT ALONE.
BEFORE COLBERT HIT THERE ARE
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYED BY MOTOR
COACH COMPANIES. NATIONWIDE
FROM DRIVERS OFFICE STAFF
MECHANICS AND SO N. IN THE
RECENT WEEKS THREE HUNDRED
EIGHT THOUSAND HAVE BEEN LAID
OFF OR FURLOUGHED. THIS NEWS
IT'S HARD TO HEAR IT NOT ONLY
HURTS US. AS A WHOLE. BUT OUR
EXTENDED FAMILIES AND THE
ECONOMY. THE MOTOR COACH
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE IS ON THE
BRINK OF NO RETURN. WITHOUT ANY
HELP MANY COMPANIES WILL NO
LONGER BE IN BUSINESS. WHO WILL
BRING THE GROUPS INTO THE
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM WHO WILL
TAKE OURIST THIRTY. FOR A DAY
OF SHOPPING AND FUN. THE US
MOTOR COACH INDUSTRY PROVIDES
NEARLY SIX HUNDRED MILLION
PASSENGER TRIPS PER YEAR. THEIR
LIVES PROVIDE SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOMESTIC TRIPS PER PER
YEAR. SO WE'RE VERY CLOSE THE
PASSENGER TRAVEL. THEY RECEIVED
TWENTY FIVE BILLION AND WE'VE
RECEIVED ZERO. THE MOTOR COACH
INDUSTRIES TAKEN FOR GRANTED
BUT WE'RE THERE TO TAKE YOUR
CHILD TO THEIR FIRST OVERNIGHT
FIELD TRIP FOR THEIR TO GET
THOUSANDS OUT OF A NATURAL
DISASTER OUT OF FIRES AND SO
ON. WERE THERE FOR YOUR BEST
FRIEND'S WEDDING WHERE THERE IS
A DESIGNATED DRIVER OUT ON THE
TOWN. WHERE THERE TO TAKE FIFTY
FIVE CARS OFF THE ROAD AT A
CERTAIN TIME. TO HELP BETTER
THE AIR QUALITY AND DO OUR PART
TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE. PLUS
PLUS MUCH MORE. AS A WHOLE THE
MOTOR COACH INDUSTRY BRINGS IN
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
BILLION AND TOURISM AND JOBS
NATIONWIDE. WITHOUT US THERE
WILL BE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN THE
OVERALL ECONOMY. WE ALWAYS WE
ARE ALWAYS HERE TO HELP NOW WE
NEED YOUR HELP. WE NEED YOUR
HELP AND YOUR VOICES WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN RECEIVE A CREDIT
FOR A DMV REGISTRATION FEES FOR
THE NEXT YEAR. IF THIS BURDEN
IS LIFTED IT THERE'S STILL HOPE
COMPANIES CAN STAY AFLOAT. WE
WANT TO BE THERE WHEN YOU CALL
WE WANT TO BE THERE FOR THE
GOOD TIMES WE WANT TO BE THERE
IN THE NEXT NECESSARY MOMENTS
OF SURVIVAL. I WANT MY CHILDREN
TO HAVE THE JOY OF SHARING
THEIR MOTOR COACH INDUSTRIES
STORIES AND TO BE PROUD OF
CONTINUING A LEGACY. I KNOW I
SPEAK FOR MYSELF AND MANY
OTHERS TODAY WE LOVE WHAT WE DO
AND WE DO IT FOR THE PEOPLE.
THE MOTOR COACH INDUSTRY NEEDS
TO BE SAVED AND WE NEED YOUR
HELP. OUR SLOGAN IS WE'RE GOING
PLACES. I HOPE WE AND OTHERS
CAN CONTINUE THAT SLOGAN FOR
MANY MANY MONTHS AND YEARS TO
COME. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. I HOPE I MADE
IMPACT ON HOW IMPORTANT THE
MOTOR COACH INDUSTRY NOT ONLY
IS TO MYSELF. BUT CALIFORNIA
OUR ECONOMY. OUR EMPLOYEES.
TOURISM AND BUSINESS OWNERS.
LET'S NOT LOOK BACK AND SAY YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'VE GOT TILL
IT'S GONE. LET'S MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TODAY AND KEEP OUR
MOTOR COACH INDUSTRY AND
BUSINESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
TO. YOUR POINTS REALLY QUICK- I
THINK I COVERED IT MULTIPLE
TIMES IN HERE BUT THE DMV
REGISTRATION FEES IT'S- IT'S
HUGE I MEAN OUR BUSES ARE
PARKEDWE'VE DONE ONE TRIP
SINCE MARCH SEVENTEENTH. SO
BASICALLY PAID A HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO THOUSAND TO LICENSE OUR
BUSES AND WE'VE DONE ONE TRIP
SO IT IT'S HUGE AND THAT'S NOT
ONLY US BUT- A- FIVE BUS
COMPANY A TWENTY BUS COMPANY.
WHETHER IT'S TWENTY THOUSAND A
HUNDRED THOUSAND A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND IT'S A HUGE
IMPACT ON. ON ON US PEOPLE
CANNOT STAY IN BUSINESS- AND
THEN THE CAR RULE THERE'S A
COMPANY IN SAN FRANCISCO HOP ON
TOURS IT'S A DOUBLE DECKER BUS
HE CALLED ME YESTERDAY. AND HE
ASKED IF I COULD MENTION THE
CARPOOL HE JUST PURCHASED.
MULTIPLE BUSES FOR HIS COMPANY.
AND HE HAS WHAT GOOD FOR FIVE
YEARS TO USE THEM BECAUSE THE
MISSION'S ROLE OF COURSE. SO I
ST WE CAN'T USE THEM FOR ONE TO
TWO YEARS HE WAS HOPING TO USE
OF FORTY FIVE YEARS BUT NOW
HE'S OUT PROBABLY ONE TO TWO
YEARS OF USE OF THE BUSES. SO
IT SUCKS THOSE ARE VERY
SPECIFIC REQUESTED I THINK
THEY'RE ON VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT. COULD BE SOMETHING
THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT. WE CAN.
DO OUR BEST BUT- ONE IT'S VERY
SPECIFIC LIKE THAT THERE'S
ALWAYS AN OPPORTUNITY THAT WE
CAN. MAKE A CASE FOR IT SO WE
APPRECIATE IT WE ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR STORY VERY
COMPELLING THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT- THAT IS
GOING TO TAKE US TO PART THREE
OF OUR HEARING. AND A LOT OF
INFORMATION HERE BUT I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR THIS FIRST HAND SO WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO PART THREE
HOW CAN CALIFORNIA'S TOURISM
INDUSTRY RECOVER- WE HAVE AARON
GUERRERO WHO IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA'S.
ATTRACTIONS AND PARKS
ASSOCIATION. WELCOME ERIN HI
HUGH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- AND GROW ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONS AND
PARKS ASSOCIATION. FIRST OFF WE
WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT TO THIS IMPORTANT
POSITION AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE MANY
ISSUES WE WILL BE FACING OVER
NEXT NEXT MANY YEARS. ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA'S THEME PARKS
LARGE AND SMALL WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO THE COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
DIRE IMPACT- BUT NINETEEN IN
THE MANDATED CLOSURES HAVE HAD
ON OUR INDUSTRY AND OUR WORK
FORCE AS WELL AS ON THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES AND THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND HOW WE
CAN BEGIN TO RECOVER. YOU CAN'T
TALK ABOUT TOURISM IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT TALKING
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S THEME PARKS.
THESE ICONIC PARKS ARE A
SIGNATURE INDUSTRY FOR OUR
STATE. AND THEY- INSTANTLY
CONJURE IMAGES OF MICKEY MOUSE.
WHICH I KNOW YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH- WITH THE BEAUTIFUL FERRIS
WHEEL AT THE END OF SANTA
MONICA PIER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLUMAS DISTRICT AND THE KNOTT'S
BERRY FARM'S BOYSENBERRY
FESTIVAL ONE OF TINA'S
FAVORITES. AND A AND GHOST TOWN
WHICH IS ALSO IN YOUR DISTRICT.
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW EVERYBODY
IS FAMILIAR WITH CALIFORNIA'S
VIBRANT THEME PARKS. AND THEY
ARE ONE OF THE PRIMARY DRIVERS
OF CALIFORNIA'S FORMERLY
VIBRANT TOURISM INDUSTRY. AND I
KNOW THE SEGMENT IS ABOUT HOW
CALIFORNIA'S TOURISM INDUSTRY
CAN RECOVER BUT I THINK WE ARE
UNIQUE BECAUSE WE ARE. CLOSED
SO ARE MESSAGES THAT THE FIRST
STEP FOR GETTING AMUSEMENT
PARKS OUT OF THIS HOLE. IS TO
STOP DIGGING. FOR EACH DAY THAT
GOES BY THAT A MUSEUM PARKS
DON'T HAVE A PATHWAY TOWARD
RESPONSIBLE RE OPENING ON A
REALISTIC TIMELINE. THAT HOLE
GETS DEEPER. AND JUST A BIT
ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW THIS ALL
EVOLVED BACK IN MARCH. THANKS
VOLUNTARY COULD VOLUNTARILY
CLOSE THEIR DOORS WE WANTED TO
BE PARTNERS WITH THE STATE WE
UNDERSTOOD THE GRAVE SITUATION
OF COCA NINETEEN AND WE WANTED
TO WORK TOGETHER IN A
COLLABORATIVE WAY. ARE YOU
LOOKING FORWARD TO A DAY THAT
WE COULD REOPEN. DURING THOSE
SEVEN MONTHS WE'VE DEVELOPED
COMPREHENSIVE PLANS THAT
CONSIST OF REDUCE CAPACITY
RIGOROUS SANITATION PROCEDURES
EMPLOYED PROTOCOLS AND TRAINING
GUESTS PROTOCOLS FACE COVERING
REQUIREMENTS PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. AND OVER THE SEVEN
MONTHS THEY'VE REFINED OF THOSE
PLANS IN ORDER TO BE PREPARED
TO REOPEN IN A SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE MANNER AS SOON AS
WERE GIVEN THE GREEN LIGHT. AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ALSO TO
HIGHLIGHT WHAT MAKES PARKS
UNIQUE- WHEN YOU GO TO VISIT A
PARK. YOU SEE THE MAGIC YOU SEE
THE FUN THAT'S KIND OF THE
MYSTIQUE OF THESE PARKS THAT'S
THEIR GOALS FOR YOU TO YOU KNOW
FORGET YOUR WORRIES AND HAVE
FUN. BUT THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
BEHIND THE SCENES SO YOU KNOW
THESE ARE PRIMARILY OUTDOOR
LOCATIONS. THEY HAVE A LOT OF
OPEN SPACE. THEY'RE NOT
TYPICALLY INTENDED FOR
CONGREGATING OR MIXING IT'S A
PLACE WHERE A FAMILY WILL GO TO
ENJOY EACH OTHER'S COMPANY. AND
NOT HUDDLE UP WITH WITH
STRANGERS. THERE CONTROLLED
ENVIRONMENTS UNLIKE MANY OTHER
ACTIVITIES. THAT ARE ALREADY
BEING ALLOWED IN THE STATE.
THERE ARE AREAS WHERE YOU CAN'T
ENFORCE MASKING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY GAS OF THEME PARKS
ARE USED TO THIS THEY KNOW THAT
WHEN THEY GO TO A PARK. THEY'RE
GONNA BE EXPECTATIONS OF THEIR
BEHAVIOR SO THERE THERE ARE
PERFECT EXAMPLES OF HOW. AN
INDUSTRY CAN ENCOURAGE THE
BEHAVIOR THAT WE NEED TO SEE TO
CONTINUE TO FIGHT THE PANDEMIC.
A PARKS ARE IN THE BUSINESS OF
ME MOVING PEOPLE IT'S NOT
STATIC THE CONTROL THE CAPACITY
ON A REGULAR BASIS- EVEN PRE
COATED. AND THEY PLACE A HIGH
VALUE ON GUEST AND EMPLOYEE
SATISFACTION- PARKS KNOW THAT
THEY NEED A HEALTHY WORKFORCE.
AND THAT THEY NEED CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE THESE ARE CRITICAL
IN THE LONG TERM IT DOES NOBODY
ANY GOOD TO RE OPEN PREMATURELY
IN AN UNSAFE WAY. WE KNOW THAT
WE'VE BEEN PREPARING FOR RE
OPENING AND WE THINK THE TIME
IS GETTING CLOSE I WON'T GO
TOO. DEEP INTO THE IMPACTS ARE
HEARING IT FROM OTHER
INDUSTRIES BUT YOU KNOW TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
LAID OFF AND FURLOUGHED. THESE
PEOPLE ARE READY TO GET BACK TO
WORK- ON THE- INDUSTRY SIDE
WERE REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
LOSING THAT TELL US
PERMANENTLY. AND BEYOND THE
PARKS YOU'VE GOT COMMUNITIES
AND SMALL BUSINESSES. THAT
DEPEND ON THE THEME PARK
INDUSTRY. AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO WHO RELY ON THOSE TAX
DOLLARS. AND I THINK. AS WE AS
WE EXPLORE RE OPENING WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO KEEP THAT
HELL AND FIGHTING THE PAN TOP
OF MIND AND OUR MAIN MESSAGE
FOR YOU IS THAT RESPONSIBLY
REOPEN CALIFORNIA'S AMUSEMENT
PARKS AND A STUBBORN COMMITMENT
TO FIGHTING COATED AND TAKING A
SCIENCE AND DATA AND HEALTH
FIRST APPROACH. THESE ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE THINGS YOU
CANNOT DO BOTH SIMULTANEOUSLY.
AND WE HAVE EXPERIENCE IN OTHER
STATES AND IN OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT ARE SHOWING THAT PARKS ARE
RE OPENING SO YOU KNOW MANY OF
OUR PARKS HAVE FACILITIES.
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA AND IN
MANY CASES THERE CALIFORNIA
PARK IS THE ONLY PART THAT'S
NOT REOPENED. THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD AND WE'RE NOT SEEN THESE
OUTBREAKS OF COVERT BEING
TRACED BACK TO PARKS. ARE THERE
IS A RECENT NEW YORK TIMES
ARTICLE THAT CAME OUT AND IT
HIGHLIGHTED THAT. THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO THE PEOPLE FEAR
TO DISNEY WORLD. JUST ISN'T
PLAYING OUT AND THEY SITE THAT
HEALTH OFFICIALS AS WELL AS AN
AS WORKER UNIONS. ARE CITING
THE SAFETY PROTOCOLS THAT ARE
IN PLACE AS RESPONSIBLE FOR
KEEPING THE VIRUS THAT DAY.
HERE IN THE STATE WE'VE GOT THE
ORANGE COUNTY HEALTH AGENCY
THAT IS RECOMMENDING. THAT THE
PARTS OF THE RE OPENING TIER
THREE. SO THERE ARE MANY
EXAMPLES THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
SHOWING THAT THESE PARKS CAN WE
OPEN IN A SAFE WAY. SO WHERE
ARE WE NOW AGAIN OUR FIRST STEP
IS TO PLOT OUT RESPONSIBLE AND
REASONABLE RE OPENING PLANNED
FOR THE PARKS WE DESPERATELY
NEED THAT- I'M SURE THAT YOU
KNOW PEOPLE HAVE BEEN READING
THE PRESS IT'S BEEN HIGHLIGHTED
PRETTY PRETTY WELL AND THAT THE
GOVERNOR I NOW SENDING AND
TEAMS OF FOLKS OUT TO THE VISIT
THE PARKS CURRENTLY WE'RE
EXTREMELY ENCOURAGED BY THIS
PARKS ARE COMPLEX AND YOU'VE
GOT TO SEE IT FIRST HAND TO
KNOW EXACTLY HOW THESE
EXTENSIVE PLANS ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED IN IN REAL IN REAL
TIME.AND IT I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WHENPARKS REOPENED IT'S GOING
TO LOOK DRAFT DIFFERENT THAN IT
DID BEFORE COPELAND IT'S NOT
GOING TO GO BACK TO PRE CODED
YOU KNOW AS SOON AS THEY- GIVE
US THE GREEN LIGHT. SO TO
ANSWER ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO THIS
QUESTION- CAN'T LIMIT TO THREE
SORRY. SO I THINK THEY'RE FIVE
THINGS REALLY THAT THAT WE
NEED. FIRST OF ALL WE'RE
LOOKING FOR FAIRNESS AGAIN I'M
UPPER REPRESENTING AT AN
INDUSTRY THAT HAS BEEN CLOSED
FOR SEVEN MONTHS. WE LOOK AT
SIMILARLY SITUATED INDUSTRIES
THAT HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
REOPEN. WE SEE OTHER INDUSTRIES
THAT ARE NOT SIMILAR SIMILARLY
SITUATED BUT- ACTUALLY POSSIBLY
RISKIER THAT HAVE BEEN ALLOWED
TO REOPEN SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SOME FAIRNESS AND TREATMENT-
WITHIN THE BLUEPRINT. OF A
REASONABLE TIME. WAITING UNTIL
TIER FOUR TO RE OPEN PARKS WILL
DECIMATE THE INDUSTRY I CANNOT
I CANNOT STATE THAT MORE
CLEARLY- THERE ARE NO CONSIST
PROJECTIONS ABOUT WHEN THESE
COUNTIES WITHIN PARKS WOULD HIT
TIER FOUR WERE WORRIED ABOUT.
THE TIER FOUR METRICS- ONE CASE
FOR WHY HUNDRED RESIDENTS AND
SOME OF THESE COUNTIES FALL SO
POSITIVE THE LOAN COULD PUSH
THEM OF THAT SO WE DON'T SEE
TIER FOUR AS AS A RE OPENING
PLAN WE SEE IT AS A IT WOULD BE
A WAY TO KEEP PARKS CLOSED
INDEFINITELY. NUMBER THREE. WE
NEED REASONABLE GUIDELINES WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT ANY
CAPACITY OR GEOGRAPHIC
LIMITATIONS MAKE SENSE. THAT
THERE FEASIBLE AND PRACTICAL.
AT FOURTH WE NEED AN ITERATIVE
AND COLLABORATIVE PROCESS AND I
AM HOPING THAT WE'RE MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION. WE HAVE WORLD
WIDE EXPERIENCE AND WE'VE GOT
BEST PRACTICES- THAT WE CAN
DRAW FROM. WE WELCOME
INVOLVEMENT BY THE HEALTH
OFFICIALS AND WE WANT YOU TO
WORK TOGETHER. NOPE THERE'S
NEVER A PERFECT. SITUATION IN
ANY REGARD RIGHT BUT WORKING
TOGETHER CAN ALWAYS MAKE IT
BETTER AND WE WILL EAGER TO DO
THAT. AND THE FIFTH ONE IS. A
MESSAGE TO THE STATE NOT ONE
SIZE ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL-
THE GOVERNOR'S OF KNOWLEDGE
THAT THESE ARE COMPLEX. THEY'RE
LIKE LITTLE CITIES AND- THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE PARKS
ARE NOT HOMOGENEOUS THEY'RE ALL
THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT YOU'VE
GOT SMALL PARTY GOT THE PARKS.
AND WE NEED TO SEE A LITTLE BIT
OF- YOU KNOW DIFFERENTIAL
TREATMENT BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT
PARKS. AND AS FAR AS OUR FUTURE
GOES WHEN I THINK THERE'S A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL THEIR DATA
AND RESEARCH EXTREMELY HELPFUL
FOR PLANNING- YOU KNOW AS
CAROLINE POINTED OUT WE WILL BE
BACK. TO PRE COVERED LEVELS
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. SO
THE RECOVERY IS GOING TO BE YOU
KNOW VERY SLOW GOING OF COURSE
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO A
VACCINE ADVANCED THERAPEUTICS.
BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO RESTORE
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IN TRAVEL.
BUT YOU KNOW IN THE NEAR TERM
pRE OPEN AT ALL IN ORDER TO.
LOOK TO THE FUTURE- YOU KNOW
PARKS ARE ABOUT FUN THERE ABOUT
HOPE. THEY'RE ABOUT CHOI. AND
WE WANT TO GET BACK TO BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDING THAT TO
FAMILIES- WE AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TO YOU AND I LOOK
FORWARDTO CONTINUING WORKING
WITH YOU AS WE- TRY TO OPEN OUR
DOORS AGAIN. THANK YOU I DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MR
MILLER MISTER TO. I JUST ONCE I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
AND MABE TO EVERYONE HERE. MY
QUESTION AROUND SPECIFICS IF
YOU WANT TO SEND US ANYTHING IN
WRITING AFTER THIS HEARING- THE
OPEN TO THAT I AM VERY VERY
SORRY NO WITH THIS HEARING WAS
SUPPOSED TO WRAP UP BUT FOR NOW
I'M GONNA LEAVE IN A FEW
MINUTES TO GET BACK. OF FOR A
COUPLE OF EVENTS THAT I HAVE
BUT I AM VERY EAGER TO HEAR
MORE SPECIFICS AND- I DO HAVE
STAFF WERE WATCHING THIS AND
TAKING NOTES BUT TO REALLY
APPRECIATING IT AND I'VE TO
SAY- WHILE I FEEL CLOSE TO THE
INDUSTRY. A LOT OF THESE VERY
SPECIFIC SUGGESTIONS ARE ALL
NEW TO ME SO IT'S JUST AGAIN
THIS IS WHY THIS YEAR AND SO
HELPFUL TO BE ABLE TO REALLY.
EDUCATE US ON THIS AND GIVE US
SOME FOOD FOR THOUGHT OF WHAT
WE CAN DO. THANK YOU FOR THE-
THANK YOU I DO I DO HAVE A
COMMON ON PARTICULAR THE THEME
PARKS AS MY DISTRICT BUT BUT I
CARE ABOUT ALL OF THIS
COMMITTEES ISSUES BUT AS I
HAVE- DISNEYLAND AND KNOTT'S
BERRY FARM IN MY DISTRICT I
THINK EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE
MENTIONED IS NOT ONLY.
IMPORTANT BUT IT IS VITAL I TOO
AM CONFUSED. ABOUT WHY IN
ESSENCE WE CAN HAVE BEACH IS
OPEN WHICH YOU KNOW WE SELL ON
LABOR DAY FOURTH OF JULY MANY
MANY PEOPLE VERY CLOSE%
TOGETHER- WE'VE SEEN A WHETHER
IT BE SOME SCHOOLS OPENED
WHETHER IT BE- OTHER PLACES
THAT WOULD QUESTION WHY- PARKS
WITH. QUITE A BIT OF ACREAGE
CANNOT BE OPENED I THINK THIS
IS US SENDS A MESSAGE TO OUR
STATE- OR NOT TO OUR STATE TO
THE PEOPLE LIVING IN OUR STATE
THAT WE'RE NOT READY TO TAKE
THIS ON. AN IDEA WENT TO MYSELF
ON THE TOUR AND DOWNTOWN DISNEY
AND SAW VERY CLEARLY. THAT IS
THE PROTOCOLS ARE TAKEN VERY
SERIOUSLY MUCH LIKE WHAT YOU
SEE IN THE CAPITAL WITH
TEMPERATURE TAKING- WITH
SANITIZERS WITH JUSTIN SCENE
AND I AM. HOPING THAT AFTER
THIS HEARING WE WILL BE ABLE
TO. BE VERY DETERMINED AND
AGGRESSIVE IN PUSHING SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS FORWARD AS FAR
AS CONSISTENCY AS FAR AS
GUIDELINES. THAT WE DO NOT WANT
TO SEE ONE OR TWO- THEME PARKS
I'M NOT SURVIVE THIS THEY ARE
VERY ICONIC TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S THAT
EXPERIENCE THAT THEY DO SO WELL
IT MAKING PEOPLE. WE HAVE THE
HAPPIEST PLACE ON EARTH OR
GHOST TOWN OR WHAT WOULD
TYPICALLY BE HOLLOWING HELL A
HOT TIME AND THERE'S SO MANY
SUPPLIERS AS FAR AS- THE
PARTNERSHIPS IN THESE AREAS
WITH UNIVERSAL MONTH MOTION
PICTURES. SO I THINK IT'S OUR
JOB ON THIS COMMITTEE TO BE-
PUSHING FORWARD THIS TOPIC
UNTIL WE GET ANSWERS THAT THANK
YOU FOR IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT SO THEN WE'RE GOING
TO NOW HAVE JOHN MAKE REYNOLDS
WHO'S THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
FOR UNIVERSAL PARKS AND RESORTS.
IT'S NOT OVER HERE FOR THE. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE READY- MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I
DON'T TAKE A SECOND STEP THANK
YOU- STAFF IS WHO KEEPS US SAFE
UP HERE CLEANING AND DOING ALL
THE THINGS AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE
DON'T THINK STAFF ENOUGH IT'S
SOMETHING WE DO CONSTANTLY OF
PERSONAL BECAUSE WE REALIZE
THERE'S A THING. WE'VE GOT
EQUATION T. SAP TEAM MEMBER
SATISFACTION EQUALS G. SET
GUEST SATISFACTION IT WAS A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE RETURN WHAT
IS A FAIR AND EQUITABLE RETURN
IN VAIN IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC IT MEANS SAFETY THAT'S
A FAIR AND EQUITABLE RETURN.
SOMETHING TO THE STAFF THANK
YOU ALL WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
IT- I'M HERE TODAY TO KIND OF
PUT A POSITIVE SPIN ON IT I'M
NOT HERE TO. TRY TO BEAT UP BY
ANYBODY ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS WE ALL KNOW THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS WE APPRECIATE
THE RECENT CONVERSATIONS WE'VE
HAD WITH THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF I
DO WANT TO GO ON RECORD AND SAY
THAT. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WE
WANT TO LOOK AT. YOU ALL AND
SAY WE'RE READY TO HELP. WE'RE
READY TO HELP WITH TO STEP UP
AND I KNOW WE CAN IT. BECAUSE
JOB IS. EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
FREEDOM PERSONAL PARKS AND
RESORTS WHAT DOES THAT MEAN.
I'VE GOT A TEAM AND SOCAGE PAN
I'VE GOT A TEAM IN BEIJING.
I'VE GOT TEAMS HERE AND TEAMS
IN FLORIDA. WE KNOW WE CAN OPEN
WE KNOW WE CAN DO IT WE KNOW WE
CAN DO IT SAFE. WE HAVE DONE IT
IN LOCATIONS AROUND THE WORLD.
AND WE'VE DONE IT WITH
ABSOLUTELY ZERO PRESENCE. OF
ANY CLUSTERS COMING OFF OF OUR
SITE AND WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS.
TO PROVE THAT CAN GO OVER THE
PROTOCOLS. SO ONE OF THE THINGS
I WANT TO DO TODAY IS TO SHOW
YOU SOME OF THE PROTOCOLS WE'VE
HAD. SO YOU CAN SEE THE DEPTH
OF WHAT WE'VE DONE TO TRY TO
PROVE THAT WE CAN DO THE SAME
SO EFFECTIVELY. AS YOU CAN SEE
ALL THIS SKIP OVER THIS REALLY
TO GET TO KEEP YOU ON TIME BUT
IT'S REALLY TO SAY LOOK WE'RE
HERE WE'RE READY TO BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION. WE'VE TRACKED TO
THE RESILIENCY ROAD MAP OF WHAT
OUR PROTOCOLS ARE AND HOW WE RE
OPEN- OF THE CAR CALIFORNIA PUB
EMPLOYEES WERE UNDER THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND R. O. PARK AND
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND FULL TIME.
AND THEN A HANDFUL- THAN
THOUSANDS OF SEASONAL. WE ARE
DOWN TO ABOUT A THOUSAND FULL
TIME- ACTIVE AND I THINK I HAVE
TO BECAUSE FOR THE MOST PART WE
HAVE TRIED TO KEEP EVERYONE ON
WE COULD ON THE- ON THE- ROLES.
MOST IMPORTANTLY HELPING OUT
WITH THEIR HEALTHCARE AND SO
FORTH BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE TO BE
IN THIS TOGETHER. I GOT A
PRAISE MY PARENT COMPANY
COMCAST COMCAST STEPPED UP AND
SAID WE ARE GOING TO TAKE CARE
OF YOU. AND WE WERE THE VERY
LAST IN OUR INDUSTRY TO REALLY
FOR A LOW ANYBODY. BECAUSE WE
WANTED TO DO WHATEVER WE COULD
FOR THE SKE OF OUR EMPLOYEES
AND AGAIN KUDOS TO THE ROBERTS
FAMILY IN THE COMCAST COMPANY
BECAUSE THEY REALLY DID STEP
UP- AND BECAUSE OF THAT ALSO IS
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY IN SOME
OF OUR LOCATIONS LIKE FLORIDA
WE WERE ABLE TO. OPEN SO
QUICKLY BECAUSE WE WEREN'T
PULLING PEOPLE BACK OFF FOR
LONG. WE REALLY SAY OKAY LET'S
GO LET'S GET THIS PLACE OPEN-
WHEN WE KEEP GOING. SO THE
GUEST JOURNEY LITERALLY WE HAVE
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PAGES OF
PROTOCOL DOCUMENTS ON NOTHING
BUT DEALING WITH BECAUSE OF IT
AND OUR GUEST EXPERIENCE AND A
TEAM MEMBER EXPERIENCE FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PAGES. AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT IT STARTS
WITH THE PRE ARRIVAL
COMMUNICATIONS IT'S HOW YOU GET
A MESSAGE TO THE GAS ARE YOU
GOING TO TALKING THROUGH THE
ENTIRE JOURNEY. NOT ONLY ONCE
THEY GET THERE BUT LONG BEFORE
WE'RE STARTING TO PLAN WITH THE
SEED IN IN THEIR MINDS OF WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH WE
TALK WE- LOOK AT THE ENTIRETY
OF THE TRANSPORTATION OF LA
BECAUSE WE ARE ALMOST AS MANY
CITY. OF HOW WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH OUR FOLKS ARE SECURITY
CHECKS HOW WE WORK WITH PEOPLE
TO MAKE SURE WERE SECURE HOW
ARE OWN STAFFERS SECURE-
SCREENING PEOPLE AND WE DO DO
FULL TEMPERATURE CHECKS WE HAVE
MANAGED TO MASK. AND I WILL
TELL YOU ON THE TEMPERATURE
CHECK ONE LITTLE ONE LITTLE
KNOWN FACT. WHEN WE STARTED THE
FIRST IN FLORIDA AND THEN I
ALSO GET YOU BANNED EVERYBODY
SAID WELL YOU KNOW ARE YOU
REALLY GONNA CATCH PEOPLE. THE
ANSWER IS. WE HAD NO SALES. AND
YOU KNOW ONE WORD GOT. OUT IF
YOU GOT A TEMPERATURE DON'T
COME. WE DIDN'T A CHALLENGE
WITH OUR PEOPLE. WITH HAVE
PROBLEMS. IT WE HAD STATE OF
THE ART EQUIPMENT. AND PEOPLE
KNEW THEY JUST COULDN'T COME.
AND IN THE FIRST TWO THREE
MONTHS OF OPERATION THEIR
INTERNAL SAKA I THINK WE HAD A
TOTAL OF A HANDFUL OF GAS THAT
TURNED AROUND AND TURNED AWAY
WHEN WE TOLD THEM NO YOU CAN'T
COME IN IF YOU'RE NOT GONNA
WEAR A MASK. EVERYBODY ELSE
SAID THAT THE PRICE OF
ADMISSION YOU GOT. SO AS YOU
CAN SEE WE TAKE IT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE FRONT ENTRY THE
PARK ATMOSPHERE. AND FRACTIONS
I MEAN WE REALLY TAKE EACH
INDIVIDUAL SEGMENT OF THE
VISIT. AND WE BREAK IT DOWN.
AND WE BREAK IT DOWN INTO HOW
WE GONNA KEEP OUR GUESTS SAFE
AND HOW ARE WE GONNA DO IT
EFFECTIVELY WITH OUR TEAM
MEMBERS. FOR INSTANCE PROGRAM
LAST YOU SIT DOWN YOU SENATE
QUICK SERVE RESTAURANT WE'VE
CONSERVING WE HAVE FULL SERVICE
YOU'RE GETTING A PIECE OF PIZZA.
SO I WAS WITH A GROUP OF FOLKS-
FOR LUNCH TODAY AND I NOTICED
REALLY TURNED THE TABLE. SIX OF
THE VENICE FOR SITTING ON THE
TABLE. SO WE SAID WAIT A SECOND
YOU CAN'T HAVE THIS IT'S NOT
SANTA THROUGH WHAT WE GONNA DO.
SO ABSOLUTELY AFTER FIRST DAY
OF OPENING WE SAID. EVERYWHERE
YOU SAID TO EAT A MEAL WE'RE
GOING TO OFFER YOU A LITTLE
BACK. A LITTLE BAG TO PUT YOUR
MASK AND FOR SANITATION
PURPOSES. THOSE ARE THE TYPE OF
THINGS WHERE THE BREED THE
PROTOCOLS WE'VE ESTABLISHED OUR
LIVING BREATHING DOCUMENTS.
CALIFORNIA IS LUCKY. CALIFORNIA
IS LUCKY BECAUSE YOU LAGGED AND
I GET IT TOUGH CHOICES WERE
BEING MADE I DON'T BELITTLE THE
CHOICES THAT EITHER YOU ALL.
FOR THE HEALTH OFFICIALS HAD TO
MAKE. BUT YOUR LACKING THE
INDUSTRY AROUND THE WORLD. BUT
IT ALSO MEANS YOU'RE GONNA GET
OUR BEST PROTOCOLS. BECAUSE
THEY HAVE WORKED AND THEY HAVE
COME TOGETHER AND THEY HAVE
BEEN CONSTANT FEEDBACK WITH THE
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS AND I
DON'T MEAN JUST A VISIT TO GET
A SOMETHING. THE HEALTH
OFFICIALS IN THE DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS WHERE WE OPERATE
HAVE COME THROUGH MULTIPLE
TIMES. IN ORDER TO HELP
CONSTANTLY REFINE THE PROTOCOLS
WITH NEW GUIDANCE NEW ADVICE
AND SO FORTH. AND THEN
ULTIMATELY YOU SEE AT THE END
AND I'M GONNA GO INTO IT RIGHT
NOW THE NEW STANDARDS OF WORK
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO IT.
SO WE TALK TO OUR TEAM MEMBERS
AND WE SAID LOOK FIRST AND
FOREMOST. YOU KNOW I. HEY
HEARING STORIES LIKE FRANK
SANTOS WE'RE HERE'S A HARD
WORKER. THROUGH NO FAULT OF HIS
OWN YOU KNOW FINANCED
UNEMPLOYED AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE
SAID TO OUR FOLKS WE'RE GONNA
CREATE A ENVIRONMENT THEN
YOU'VE GOT TO HELP US HELP YOU
BUT NO THIS. IF YOU SUSPECT
YOU'VE BEEN AROUND FAMILY
MEMBERS OR ON THE ENVIRONMENT
AND YOU HAVE BEEN AROUND
SOMEBODY WOULD CALL IT. YOUR
JOB IS NOT GONNA BE THREATENED.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE ANY
PENALTY POINTS YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO HAVE ANYTHING. TELL US. TELL
US WE'RE GONNA HELP MONITOR
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO HELP YOU
GET THROUGH THIS TOGETHER. AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA LOOK AROUND
WHO MAY HAVE BEEN RIGHT AROUND
YOU AT YOUR WORKPLACE AND AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION SO SOME OF
THOSE FOLKS TO GO TAKE A COUPLE
DAYS TO MAKE SURE THEY DON'T
SHOW ANY OF THE SYMPTOMS WHY.
BECAUSE IT'S A SHORT TERM PAIN
FOR A LONG TERM ABILITY TO
OPERATE SAFELY. AND YOU KNOW
WHAT AREN'T PLEASE OF ALL SAID
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE IN THIS
TOGETHER YOU BETTER BELIEVE IT.
AND THEN IT TALKS ABOUT THE
ARRIVAL IN THE TRAINING AND
EVEN THINGS LIKE AT FIRST WHEN
WE WERE. WHEN WE ARE TAKING THE
TEMPERATURE OF OUR PLACES THEY
WERE TOUGH. AS THEY WERE-
COMING YOU WOULD SAY OKAY WELL
YOU KNOW THEY GET OUT OF THE
CARS THAT PARK THE COMMENT. NO
NO WE- WENT UP TO THEM WITH
POLLING IN. CAR AND SET UP A
CHECK SO WE CAN ACTUALLY TAKE
THEIR TEMPERATURES AS THEY
PULLED IN ONE. BECAUSE IT
PREVENTED OTHER TOUCH POINTS
FOR THEM TO GET OUT OF THE CAR
COME INTO. IT'S THE LESSONS
LEARNED OF HOW DO YOU PUSH THE
GUIDANCE OUT FURTHER. AND THEN
YOU TALK ABOUT TRAINING IN
GUEST INTERACTION WE TRAINED.
OUR EMPLOYEES OUR EMPLOYEES. IN
OUR INDUSTRY ARE TRYING TO GO
UP TO YOU. AND WE TALK ABOUT
FACING. A GUEST AND LOOKING
THEM IN THE EYE AND GIVING THEM
THAT SPECIAL GUEST EXPERIENCE.
WE SAID WE'RE GONNA TEACH YOU
BUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO TAKE A
COUPLE STEPS BACK IN STOCK THAT
IS STATE A PHYSICALLY DISTANT.
SPOT SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE YOU
THROUGH TRAINING TO TEACH YOU A
MAKE SURE YOU GET THAT IN IN
YOUR IN YOUR MIND IN YOUR MIND
SET. WHICH IS DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TRAINED IN THE
PAST. ONE DIRECTING THE
ENGAGEMENT. RIGHT ONCE YOU
DON'T EVEN THINK OF. IT WE HAVE
THAT ARE SECOND THIRD FOURTH.
EMPLOYEE AND THEY'RE FOR. HELLO
EVEN THOUGH ALL OF THEM ARE
FAMILY THEY'RE STILL FAMILIES
SOME OF THESE FOLKS FISCHLER
TECH SERVICE WORKERS HAVE BEEN
TAKING LUNCHES TOGETHER FOR
TWENTY YEARS. WE SAID FOLKS
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO STAY THE
BUT WE WILL YOU TO PUT IN THE
BACK OF YOUR MIND SOCIAL
DISTANCING SITE YOU KNOW
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. AND BE
SMART IN UNDERSTAND THAT MASKS
MATTER AND ALL THOSE KIND OF
THINGS SO IT REMIND THEM
CONSTANTLY AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
WE HAVE SIGNAGE EVERYWHERE AND
WE ALSO HAVE OUR TEAM LEADERS
BEEN TOLD. GO AROUND AND CHECK
ON YOUR STAFF TO REINFORCE THE
POSITIVE MESSAGING ON HOW WE'RE
DOING YOU KOW WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS IMPORTANT. I WILL TELL YOU
WE MEASURE OUR TEAM
SATISFACTION SCORES CONSTANTLY.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THE
INTERESTING PART OUR FACILITIES
PEOPLE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST JOBS BECAUSE YOU'RE
BASICALLY CLEANING ALL DAY.
TYPICALLY THOSE T. SAID SCORES
ARE GOOD FOR US BUT THEY'RE NOT
THE HIGHEST POSSIBLE. I GOTTA
TELL YOU POST CODE THAT'S
CHANGED. BECAUSE ALL THE SUDDEN
THEY UNDERSTAND THEY'RE DOING
SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT FOR
ALL OF US AND THE PRIDE IN
BEING IN THAT DEPARTMENT HAS
GONE UP EXPONENTIALLY WHICH WE
CANNOT. THANK THEM ENOUGH FOR
THEIR EFFORTS. SO YOU KNOW YOU
PUT UP SOME BLUEPRINT. FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND WE
ACTUALLY WENT DOWN AND ACTUALLY
MAXTONE. FOR POINT FOR POINT.
AND I WILL GO THROUGH EVERY
SINGLE ONE NOW TO TRY TO KEEP
YOU ON SCHEDULE BUT I'LL BE
GLAD TO LEAVE THE POWER POINT
WITH YOU ALSO YOU CAN SEE. HOW
WE COMPARE THEM TOGETHER AND
HOW WE ARE GOING TO DRIVE TO
THE ANSWERS. MOST IMPORTANTLY
SO I WANT TO POINT OUT JUST.
ONE THING ESPECIALLY ON THIS IF
I COULD. AND THAT IS WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT LIMIT PEOPLE MIXING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ARE AIMED AT
KEEPING DIFFERENT HOUSEHOLDS. I
REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON THAT
FOR SECONDS IT'LL TELL YOU HOW
WE HAVEN'T CHANGED OUR MINDSET.
TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE BECAUSE
EVERYTHING WE DO IN OUR
INDUSTRIES ABOUT THROUGHPUT HOW
MANY PEOPLE COMING THROUGH PUT
ON A RIDE TO THE TRACTION IF I
CAN'T GET THE OF THE MARK IT'S
NOT GOOD AND WE CHECK IN ON AN
HOURLY BASIS AND IF WE KNOW
THAT WE'VE GOT SOMETHING NOT
MIXING WILL CHANGE OF TEAM WILL
FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
GET THAT THROUGH PUT DONE. IN
THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY POST
COMMENT. WE TOOK THOSE SINGLE
RIDER LINES THAT WE USED TO DO
TO FILL AN EMPTY SPOT. ON ANY
TO LINE THAT CAME TOO CLOSE.
AND WENT INTO THAT SIX WITH
SEPARATION WE TOOK OUT THREE
DESIGN. WE DID THINGS LIKE
LOADING EVERY OTHER ROADS WE
DID THE THINGS THAT WE SAID
WE'RE GONNA MAKE THE COMMITMENT
AND LIVE UP TO THE SAFETY
GUIDELINES PROTOCOLS WHICH WE
DON'T NEED NEVER DID NEED A
2550% LIMITATION ON US. THE
SAFETY PROTOCOLS GIVE US OUR
LIMITATIONS AND WITH THE SAFETY
PROTOCOLS WE'VE BEEN PUT IN
PLACE HONESTLY TO GET ABOVE
3540% IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE NOR
WOULD WE WANT TO BECAUSE THE G.
SEPTIC GUEST SATISFACTION
NUMBER WOULD JUST DISAPPEAR
NOBODY COME BACK. SO THE
REALITY OF IT IS THE ACTUAL
PHYSICAL DISTINGUIR GARMENTS
THAT WE MANDATE IN OUR QUEUE
LINES IN OUR TRACKS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE ARE GONNA
DETERMINE THAT PERCENTAGE NO WE
UNDERSTAND STATE WILL PROBABLY
WANT TO LOOK AT A PERCENTAGE WE
GET THAT. BUT UNDERSTAND IT'S
ALREADY THERE FOR US IN WHERE
WE OPERATE AROUND THE GLOBE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY GETTING
CALIFORNIANS BACK TO WORK
SAFELY. I WANT YOU TO LOOK AT
THAT NUMBER RIGHT THERE MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF CONSTRUCTION WORK IS
NO LONGER. ONE COMPANY FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
CONSTRUCTION WORK ON CAPITOL.
OFF THE BOOKS. THE SOONER WE
CAN GET BACK OPEN THE SOONER
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT POTENTIAL
NEW PROJECTS ON THE ROAD
BECAUSE NEW PROJECTS MEAN
CONSTANT VISITATION BUT
UNDERSTANDING IN THIS MARKET
AND I WILL BE BACK WITH THE
THERE'S A CALIFORNIA GIRL ON
THE TEAM SAID. GUESS WHAT THIS
IS ALL DRIVE MARKET RIGHT NOW I
KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S FOLKS WANT
TO LOOK AT A MILEAGE AND SO
FORTH IT IS ALL PRIVATE MARKET.
I KNOW. BECAUSE I'M THE ONE
THAT GETS TO DEAL WITH THE
BUSINESS JUST TO TRY TO GET
SOME VENDORS BACK INTO JAPAN
AND CHINA. NOBODY'S TRAVELING.
FACT ONE OF THE FEW COMPANIES
THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO SO
BECAUSE WE'RE BUILDING A PARK
IN THE MIDDLE OF BEIJING. TALK
ABOUT SOME REAL IN THE MIDDLE
OF ALL THIS. I HAD TO GET THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE BACK INTO
BEIJING IN THE MIDDLE OF COLOR.
BUT THE REALITY OF IT IS I WILL
TELL YOU WHAT THE RESTRICTIONS
ARE PLACED ON THE INTERNATIONAL
TRAVEL ANOTHER QUESTION WAS
ASKED BEFORE. IT'S NOT HAVE.
OKAY JUST TODAY I WAS ON THE
PHONE THE JAPANESE EMBASSY
TRYING TO GET SIX HUNDRED
PACKAGE DIDN'T TO JAPAN. SO THE
REALITY IS. WE WANT TO FOCUS ON
GETTING. WORKERS BACK HERE. WE
KNOW THE VISITATION WILL BE
WITHIN THE LOCAL MARKET THAT
PRODUCT. YES WILL BE A LITTLE
LOUDER YOU ASK BUT NOT AS MUCH
AS YOU WOULD THINK. SO AS
PEOPLE WORRY AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT I WANT TO TAKE AND TAKE
YOUR MIND. WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
A THEME PARK YOU THINK ABOUT
THE FOURTH OF JULY. YOU THINK
ABOUT JAMPACKED PARKS. WITH THE
SAFETY PROTOCOLS THAT'S NOT THE
NORM ANYMORE AND WE HAVE GOT TO
GET THE STATE OFF THE MIND SET
UP I SEE A HUGE BUNCH OF PEOPLE
IN A SINGLE LOCATION. IN FACT
THERE IS A FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS SAYING ALL THESE.
FACTORS THAT I PUT ON THE ON
THE BOARD AGAIN I KNOW I'M FROM
RUSSIA TO KEEP YOU GUYS ON
SCHEDULE. BUT THERE'S A
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION AT ALL THE
HEALTH OFFICIALS EXPECT THE
POLITICS OF IT ALL THE HEALTH
OFFICIALS HAVE SAID. TO ME
PERSONALLY AROUND THE GLOBE.
HOW CAN YOU GUARANTEE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND WE GO THROUGH
THE PROTOCOLS AND THEY GO YOU
ARE PART OF THE ANSWER BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES ANOTHER SIX MONTHS
TO A YEAR THEY'RE JUST NOT. WE
KNOW WHERE THE TRANSMISSIONS
ARE HAPPENING A LOT OF TIMES
ARE HAPPENING THOSE LARGE
FAMILY BARBECUES AND EVERYTHING
ELSE WHEN YOU GET THE
GATHERINGS PEOPLE FEEL CLOSE
THEY SEEM TO KNOW EACH OTHER.
WE'RE WE REALLY SHOULD BE
ASKING REGARDLESS OF THE
VOLUMES IN WE'RE CAN YOU PUT
PEOPLE SAFELY. THAT WILL GIVE
THEM AN OUTLET. GIVE THEM
SOMETHING TO DO BUT NOW YOU'VE
GOT THE REGULATORY. REGULATORY
CONTROLS TO CREATE THAT
PHYSICAL DISTANCES. THEME PARKS
ARE YOUR ANSWER. AND I KNOW
THAT'S WEIRD SOME STRANGE. BUT
WHEN THE HEALTH OFFICIALS IN
BOTH FLORIDA AND JAPAN NOT THE
POLITICIANS ON ANYBODY ELSE
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE IN THE MINDSETS OF
SOME FOLKS ON HOW FLOOR OPEN TO
QUICK AND SO FORTH WITHOUT
GETTING INTO THAT IT WAS THAT
HEALTH OFFICIALS IT SAID WE
HAVE GOT TO PUT THESE PEOPLE
SOME MORE. AND IT WAS THE
HEALTH OFFICIALS THAT MADE THE
ULTIMATE DECISION WHERE TO WHAT
WE'RE TO DO THAT. SO WE'VE GOT
SOME OF OUR PREVENTIVE MEASURES
THAT U. S. H. YOU'RE JUST SOME
SIGNS THAT WE HAVE ALL OVER THE
PLACE. IN OUR OPERATIONS IN
OSAKA JAPAN IN BEIJING IN
ORLANDO. WE'VE COME UP WITH THE
STANDARDS- EVERYWHERE YOU GO.
WE HAVE HIRED ADDITIONAL STAFF
TO SERVICE AND BASS CENTERS TO
DO NOTHING BUT ROAD IN THE
PARK. AND TO CREATE AND
REMINDER CONSTANTLY OF WHAT TO
DO WE PUT IN A KEY CHOKEPOINTS
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE SO
PHYSICALLY DISTANCED. WE DON'T
WANT OTHER THING THAT THE LOCAL
HEALTH ARE. ABOUT AROUND THE
WORLD. BUT SAID MASS ARE POOR
RIGHT. BUT IF YOU'RE OUT IN THE
SUN EIGHT TO TEN HOURS. SO IS A
COUPLE MINUTES FRESH AIR. SO WE
CREATED FREE SAFE ZONES WHERE
WE CAN PROBLEM AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
SEPARATION BE PUT BETWEEN
PARTIES AND ALLOW THEM TO GO IN
AND TAKE OFF THE MASKS. AND
THEN WE ONLY LET HIM GO IN
THERE FOR TEN OR FIFTEEN
MINUTES AND I'M BACK IN THE
PARK WE DON'T WANT TO DO A LOT
OF FOOD AND DRINK IN THERE OR
ANYTHING BECAUSE IT'S NOT WE'RE
GONNA GO GRAB YOUR LUNCH. AND
IT'S WORKED OUT FANTASTICALLY
IN THE HEALTH OFFICIALS AND
LOVED IT. IN FACT I'D LIKE TO
GET TO THIS THIS IS A THIS IS A
QUOTE FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY
FLORIDA HEALTH OFFICIAL DR
ROUTE. I'M SORRY RALPH PENA
ROLLA'S JUST BEEN FANTASTIC
BEEN. ABLE TO WORK WITH. READ
THIS WE ACTUALLY I HAD A I HAVE
NOT HAD A MAJOR ISSUE WITH THE
THEME PARKS THEY HAVE TAKEN
THIS VERY SERIOUSLY THEY ARE
NOT ONLY INTERESTED IN
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. BUT THEY
ARE ALSO INTERESTED IN
PROTECTING THEIR BRAND. SO FAR
THE EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN VERY
GOOD. THAT'S WHAT THE PERSON
WITH DIRECT OVERSIGHT OF OUR
INDUSTRY. AND YOU KNOW WHAT I
TOLD HIM FROM DAY ONE YOU SEE A
CLUSTER I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
WE'RE SHOT NOW. AND IT HASN'T
HAPPENED. SO JUST GIVE ME A
COUPLE PICTURES OF. WHAT SOME
OF THE ENTRY HOUSE LOOKS LIKE
THIS IS IMPORTANT HOW IT WOULD
LOOK THE SAME. LITTLE BIT OF
SOCIAL DISTANCING PEOPLE YOU
ARE DOING IT BY THEM BY
THEMSELVES AS THEY WALKED
THROUGH THE WALKWAYS THIS IS
OUR ENTRANCE TO ISLANDS OF
ADVENTURE. AND HERE IS KIND OF
UNIQUE YOU SEE THE BOTTOM OF.
THIS AREA. THE TALKS ARE
ALREADY THERE ONE BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO GUARANTEE THE SHOCK
AND GATES WERE YOU TYPICALLY
ARE SENATE NEXT SOMEBODY WOULD
NOT BE AN INTERFERENCE AND SO
WE CAN LOW PEOPLE IN IN ROW
AFTER ROW BUT IN A SEPARATE
CONTAINED WAY SO THAT'S WHERE
YOU SEE ALL THAT TOP PART ABOUT
THE TURNSTILES. ARE ONLY. SO
WE'RE GONNA SPEND THE MONEY TO
DO THIS RIGHT AND WE CONTINUE
TO DO SO. BUT. FOR GOING TO THE
NEXT SO WITH THAT I GUESS WANT
SAY THANK YOU LET BE PART OF
SALUTE. LET US HELP OPEN THIS.
AND GIVE PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR- THE MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA TAKE CARE OF OUR GAS AND
WE'RE GONNA TAKE CARE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. THANK YOU.
GREAT JOB. AND I HOPE THAT SOME
OF THE GUESTS ARE HERE ALSO
TAKING NOTES BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S THE OTHER PART OF THIS
IS NOT ONLY LOOKING AT
SOLUTIONS BUT IT'S LEARNING
FROM EACH OTHER. AND FROM
EXPERIENCES. RICHARD ANY
COMMENTS OF. HEALTH
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU FOR THE
GREAT DETAIL AND THERE'S A LOT
TO CHEW ON HERE AS YOU KNOW
SOME OF US OF- SIGNED LETTERS
AND IN SUPPORT OF- MAKING SURE
THAT- YOUR INDUSTRY GETS BACK
ON ITS FEET AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
AND I DO HOPE THAT THE ISSUES
THAT ARE. PERCOLATING OKAY GET
RESOLVED VERY SOON. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT- FROM THE
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM WE HAVE
JULIE PACKARD. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU WELCOME
JULIE CAN LOOK AT MUSIC. WELL
GREENS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW
WORDS ABOUT THE MODERATE A
QUORUM AND THE SEASON AQUARIUMS
O CALIFORNIA WHICH ARE PART OF
THE WHOLE PICTURE HERE OF
CALIFORNIA TOURISM. SO OF
COURSE IT'S BEEN AN
EXTRAORDINARILY CHALLENGING
TIME I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
WHAT A TIME TO BE A PUBLIC
SERVANT WELL. NOW THAT'S BEEN
OBVIOUSLY FOR ALL OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS UNLIKE ANYTHING
WE'VE EVER EXPERIENCED BEFORE.
OF COURSE MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM
HAS DOWN THE ANCHOR OF TOURISM
ON THE MONTEREY PENINSULA SINCE
WE OPENED OUR DOORS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. AND TO BE HONEST
WHEN MY FAMILY FIRST FOUNDED
AND CREATED THE A CORE AND WE
HAD NO IDEA THAT WE WOULD. EVER
BE IN A CRISIS LIKE WHEN WE ARE
IN TODAY THAT- THAT HONESTLY IS
COMING PRETTY CLOSE TO
THREATENING OR OUR WHOLE
EXISTENCE. SO AS OF YESTERDAY-
WATER BE CURRENTS BEEN CLOSED-
FOR SEVEN MONTHS AND OF COURSE.
BASED ON THE TRAJECTORY OF KOBE
CASES AND RECOVERY MONTEREY
COUNTY- WE STILL DON'T KNOW
WHEN WE'LL BE ALLOWED TO OPEN.
AND THE THING ABOUT AQUARIUMS
AND M. INSTITUTIONS LIKE OURS
IS THAT YOU CAN'T YOURSELF THE
DOOR AND CALLED IN AND BE
CLOSED- WE SPENT ABOUT A
MILLION DOLLARS. EVERY MONTH
AND ANIMAL CARE. ALONE AND OF
COURSE WITHOUT ANY ADMISSIONS
REVENUE TO SUPPORT THE SERVICES
ARE CORAM LIKE OTHER CALIFORNIA
USE OF KOREANS HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO MAKE REALLY BIG CUTS AND
OTHER PARTS OF OUR BUDGET LIKE
MANY OF YOUR SPEAKERS HERE
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT ALONE FOR
US. THAT INCLUDED- A REALLY
HEARTBREAKING HEARTBREAKING
LOSS OF ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES- ANNABELLA FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR REVENUE. DEFICIT
ARE LOSS THIS YEAR. SO LIKE YOU
WERE SUPER COMMITTED TO SAFETY
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS IS OUR TOP
PRIORITY WHICH- IS WHY WE'VE
WORKED WITH- WITH HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THE DESIGN
RIGOROUS DATA DRIVEN SAFETY
MEASURES LIKE THE ONES YOU JUST
HEARD ABOUT. DIFFERENT THE
SPREAD AMONG OUR STAFF FOR
VISITORS AND EVEN OUR ANIMALS.
AND WE'VE ALSO JOINED WITH THE
KOREANS ACROSS THE STATE TO
ADOPT A CONSISTENT SET OF
PROTOCOLS EVERYONE TO AGREE TO
THE SAME PROTOCOLS FOR
INSTITUTIONS THAT EXCEED THOSE
OF OTHER SECTORS. YEAH OF
COURSE THE AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH EARNED
NEEDED. SIDE FROM THE FACT THAT
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO- BUT
ALSO BECAUSE CORPS INTRODUCE
CANNOT SHUT DOWN FOR CORE
OPERATIONS IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERED CRISIS. WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO MAINTAIN THE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO CARE FOR
THE THOUSANDS OF ANIMALS IN OUR
CARE. AND OF COURSE
UNFORTUNATELY THE CARERS COME
AT A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL COST
OF PUTTING. FUTURE OF OUR
KOREAN AND THE KOREANS INTO'S
ACROSS THE STRAIT ACTUALLY IN
PARTICULAR PERIL. SOME OF THEM
GOT SOME EARLY SUPPORT BUT OF
COURSE LIKE MANY BUSINESSES AS
YOU KNOW THAT'S NO LONGER
AVAILABLE AND MANY OF THE MARIN
AND IN REALLY BIG TROUBLE. ALSO
ALONG WITH THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF CLOSURES HELD ON THE
REVENUE PERSONNEL'S COURSE ALSO
UNDERMINED A ROLES A DRIVER OF
MONTEREY COUNTY'S THREE BILLION
DOLLAR TOURISM ECONOMY. OTHERS
ESTIMATED SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
HOSPITALITY WORKERS AND ARE
COUNTY ALONE THAT ARE
UNEMPLOYED RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF
THAT. AND VISITORS ARE TRULY
THE LIFE BLOOD OF MODERATE
ECONOMIES MODERATE ECONOMY
ALLEN- CORRIMAL LOAN AND-
TWENTY NINETEEN WELCOME TO
MILLION GAS THAT SORT OF OUR
AVERAGE EVERY YEAR. AND THEN
INCLUDED A HUNDRED THOUSAND-
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS ADMITTED FREE OF
CHARGE ALL OF OUR EDUCATION
PROGRAMS HAVE FREE ADMISSION.
AND OF COURSE CENTER IN THE
CITY'S RELY HEAVILY ON SALES
AND HOTEL TAXES SOME VISITORS
TO SUSTAIN. ALL THE VITAL
HEALTH. SAFETY AND OTHER PUBLIC
SERVICES. THIS YEAR MODERATE.
THOSE ESTIMATED TO LOSE FORTY
MILLION TAX REVENUE AND
PROJECTED LOSSES. FOR THE NEXT
YEAR OR TRIPLE THAT TOTAL-
COMPARED TO TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT SUB 73% OF CLIENTS THAT
YOU KNOW SIMILAR. SIMILAR
NUMBERS THAT SELL NOW- FAMILIAR
VERY FAMILIAR TO YOU DESPITE
THE CLOSURE OF THE AQUARIUM
THOUGH THERE HAS BEEN SOME GOOD
NEWS NEVER WASTE A CRISIS- WE
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PUBLIC
CAN ACTUALLY HAVE GROWN OUR
AUDIENCE- OUR VIRTUAL AUDIENCE
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE NO REVENUE
COMING IN- WE'VE WE'VE GROWN
OUR AUDIENCE- TO A- LARGER
NUMBER THAN EVERY EVER BEFORE.
WE'VE HOSTED FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS SO FAR MOST FROM
CALIFORNIA FOR FREE ONLINE
DISTANCE LEARNING CLASSES IN
ENGLISH AND SPANISH THIS YEAR
WE'RE GONNA START OFFERING
VIRTUAL FIELD TRIPS SERVING AS
MANY AS FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS A
WEEK FROM ACROSS THE STATE THE-
AGAIN ALL FREE OF CHARGE SO.
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT TO ME AND I
FIELD SOUTH OF KOREANS ARE
PROVIDING HOPE AND SALAS AND- A
PLACE TO CONNECT WITH ANIMALS
AND THE NATURAL WORLD. WE GET
COMMENTS ABOUT PEOPLE WATCHING
OVER WEBCAMS FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD JUST- TO CONNECT WITH
NATURE AND HAVE SOME PEACE. BUT
OF COURSE WITHOUT GETTING BACK
IN BUSINESS WE CAN'T CONTINUE
TO LIVER THESE. SERVICES
INDEFINITELY AND- MY MESSAGE.
TODAY IS TO ASK YOU TO JOIN US
IN APRONG APPROACH TO HELP FOR
OF ALL AND HONESTLY OF COURSE
MOST IMPORTANT IS TO INCREASE
SUPPORT FOR CLOVER NINETEEN
PREVENTION AND RECOVERY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. SECOND TO HELP US
OPEN AND THIRD TO WORK WITH US
TO FIND SOURCES OF FINANCIAL
RELIEF. SO MOST IMPORTANTLY WE
NEED TO TAKE ACTION TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES AND WORKERS MOST AT
RISK FROM COVER NINETEEN. AND
THAT THE KOREAN WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY ENDORSE THE
STATE'S NEW EQUITY HEALTHEQUITY
METRIC SO IMPORTANT SUCH A GOOD
MOVE AND- COURSE IS GOING TO
HELP ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
MOST AFFECTED. BY COVER
NINETEEN ARE GIVEN THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED. IN MONTEREY COUNTY
THE SEVENTY UP SORRY. I WISH IT
WAS 1770% OF PEOPLE INFECTED
WITH COCA NINETEEN OR LATIN
ACTS. AND MANY POSITIVE CASES
ARE OCCURRING AMONG THE FORMER
FOR COMMUNITY IN SALINAS AND
SLING THIS. THESE WORKERS WERE
ESSENTIAL OF COURSE YET LACKED.
OF BEACON SECURITY. HOUSING AND
HEALTH CARE THIS INEQUITY
DEMANDS OUR COLLECTIVE
ATTENTION. THE KOREANS WORKING
CLOSELY WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS AGRICULTURE
HOSPITALITY COUNTY GOVERNMENTS
AND FOUNDATIONS INCLUDING THE
DAVID AND LUCILLE PACKARD
FOUNDATION THAT I'M INVOLVED
WITH TO PROMOTE A STAKEHOLDER
DRIVEN APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
THE CRISIS IN OUR COMMUNITY. WE
FEEL THAT IT'S UP TO ALL THE
BUSINESSES AND INSTITUTIONS IN
THE COMMUNITY TO DO THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WHICH IS GET.
GET OUR COMMUNITY RECOVERED. SO
WHAT WE NEED FROM YOU IS YOUR
SUPPORT TO FOCUS STATE
RESOURCES ON THE REGION'S IN
CALIFORNIA THAT NEED IT MOST
INCLUDING MONTEREY COUNTY. SO
SECOND ALL CALIFORNIA THE
KOREANS THAT MEET THE STATE'S
STRICT REOPENING GUIDANCE THE
NEED TO BE ALLOWED TO OPEN IN
TIER ONE AND NOT BE SUBJECT TO
REPEATED OPENING AND CLOSING AS
THEY ARE NOW. RIGHT NOW
MODERATE A KOREAN CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE CENTER AND THE CABRILLO
MARINE AQUARIUM IN LA. THEY'RE
THE ONLY THREE ACCREDITED
ASSOCIATION IS THE OWNER CORAM
INSTITUTIONS IN THE NATION THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN ALLOWED TO REOPEN
BECAUSE OUR COUNTIES ARE IN
TIER ONE. AND N. AS WAS JUST
STATED BEFORE- MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN OPEN SINCE
JULY AND I'VE LEARNED A LOT SO
BY THE TIME WE GOT TO OPEN
HOPEFULLY SOON. WE WILL HAVE A
LOT OF INFORMATION UNDER OUR
BELT. SO RIGHT NOW ALTHOUGH WE
HAVE STRICTER STATE MANDATED RE
OPENING REQUIREMENTS THAN OTHER
INDOOR ESTABLISHMENTS THE
KOREANS IN TIER ONE COUNTIES
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO OPEN EVEN AT
JUST 25% CAPACITY WHICH WOULD
BE OUR FIRST OPENING- STEP
WHILE THE STATE ALLOWS OTHER
NONESSENTIAL INDOOR
ESTABLISHMENTS LIKE SHOPPING
MALLS WHICH HAVE FAR FEWER
CONTROLS TO OPEN OPENING
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDE MANDATORY
PRE VISIT SOMETIMES SCREENING
SCREENING OF ONE WAY VISITOR
PATHS MANDATORY MOUSE FOR
EVERYONE. OVER AGE TO TIME TAKE
ADMISSIONS SOLD ONLY BY- AT
ADVANCE RESERVATIONS. AND UNDER
THESE COVERT NINETEEN SAFETY
MEASURES THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HOST FAR FEWER PEOPLE IN THE
BUILDING AND THEN UNDER NORMAL
CONDITIONS. FOR EXAMPLE ON A
BUSY- PICK SUMMER DAY WE MIGHT
HAVE- EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
THE AQUARIUM AT ONE TIME. UNDER
THESE COVERT CONDITION
RESTRICTIONS AT THIS REDUCE
CAPACITY WE ESTIMATE THERE
MAYBE JUST FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE.
AT ANY ONE TIME IN THE AQUARIUM
SO THAT JUST GIVES YOU AN IDEA
OF THE SPACING THAT THAT WILL
BE GOING ON. AND ALSO THEY'RE
LIKELY STAY FOR SHORTER TIME
BECAUSE WE'RE CLOSING ALL THE
EXHIBITS. THAT ARE BOTH
CHILDREN- BUT AND ONE BALL
TOUCH EXPERIENCES. AND THE
CLOSURE AUDITORIUM IN ANY PLACE
THAT WOULD- WOULD POSE A RISK.
SO A CRIMES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ALREADY A REALLY CONSCIOUS
APPROACH TO DATE NOT A SINGLE
ONE OF THE OVER. HAVE REPORTED
A COVERED NINETEEN TRANSMISSION
CASE. SO OF THE THIRD THE THIRD
MESSAGE- IN TERMS OF HOW THE
STATE CAN HELP IS- THE
CALIFORNIA AQUARIUMS AND ZOOS
THEY ALSO NEED FINANCIAL
RELIEF- THE STAGGERING REVENUE
LOSSES PAIRED WITH THE HIGH
COST OF ANIMAL CARE. CARE THAT
WE CANNOT STOP PROVIDING HAVE
BROUGHT MANY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS TO THE BRINK- TO
DATE MONTEREY BAY AQURIUM HAS
BEEN ENTIRELY LEFT OUT OF THE
ENACTED FEDERAL CODE RELIEF
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T MEET THE FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEE LEVEL AND JUST
BECAUSE YOUR BIG DOESN'T MEAN
THAT I'S EASIER IT ACTUALLY
MEANS THAT YOU HAVE. A HUGE
ANIMAL COLLECTION AT A BIG
BUILDING AND A LOT OF EXPENSES
AND SO IT ALMOST SO YOU YOU YOU
LOSE MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF MONEY
FASTER THAN. PERHAPS THIS IS IF
YOU WERE SMALLER- WITH
UNNECESSARILY SLOW- A REAL
OPENING PACE WHICH IS THE RIGHT
THING. AND LIMITS AND VISITOR
CAPACITY YOU KNOW HONESTLY THE
FATE OF CALIFORNIA'S USE AN
AQUARIUMS. WE'RE GOING TO
REMAIN IN JEOPARDY FOR MONTHS
IF NOT YEARS AND I BELIEVE YOU
KNOW SOME OF THEM JUST ARE NOT
GOING TO MAKE IT. SO WE
UNDERSTAND OUR ENTIRE STATE IS
A NEED RIGHT NOW THAT'S WHY OUR
KOREAN ALONG WITH THEIR PEERS
ACROSS THE NATION CONTINUE TO
PRESS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL FOR
STATE AD LOCAL RELIEF AND
CORONA FUNDING BILLS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD ON THAT ALL
TOGETHER ALONG WITH THE
NATIONAL MUSEUM COMMUNITY- AND
SO TODAY I'M ASKING YOU TO
INCLUDE AQUARIUMS AND ZOOS IN
THE STATE REALLY STRATEGIES.
THAT WILL ENABLE US. TO
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE THE STATE'S
EDUCATION CONSERVATION GOALS
BECAUSE WORLD NON PROFITS
THAT'S WHAT WE DO WE'RE
PROVIDING HUGE SERVICES
ESSENTIAL SERVICES I BELIEVE IN
EDUCATION ESPECIALLY DURING.
THE HYBRID- PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND A LOT OF WORK UP IN
A LOT OF ONE SCHOOL AT HOME
THAT'S GOING ON THAT NEEDS-
CURRICULUM RESOURCES DIGITAL
ONES TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN. SO
THE KOREAN LIKE OTHER MAINSTAYS
OF HER TOURISM ECONOMY. WE'RE
OUR EXISTENCE
AND- WORLD BIT ROCKS EVER
COMMUNITIES ALONG WITH BEING
KNOWN AROUND THE WORLD AS
LEADERS IN SCIENCE EDUCATION
AND CONSERVATION WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY WELL PREPARED TO
FACE THE NEW REAL A REALITY
WITH THE HIGHEST STANDARDS OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY- BUT WE NEED
YOUR HELP TO SURVIVE THE CRISIS
AND CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC. INTO THE FUTURE SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING ON ALL ALL HOPE
FOR THE BEST IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THE
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCES YOU
PROVIDE TO OUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES I HAVE BEEN TO. MANY
OF THE KOREANS THAT YOU
MENTIONED. ALL OF THEM I THINK
YES. ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO
WRAP UP WITH ALL THIS- THE LAST
THREE PRISONERS THE ROAD AHEAD.
AND WE APPRECIATE THOSE OF YOU
ARE HANGING IN THERE THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT LONGER THAN EXPECTED
SO WE'LL TRY TO BE AS SWIFT AS
POSSIBLE WITH OUR LAST THREE
SPEAKERS. WE HAVE. MONEY WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AND PUBLIC POLICIES FOR
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AS
STATED MY NAME'S ANOTHER BODY
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE THE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
PROBLEMS FOR THEM IN
CALIFORNIA. WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH BIPARTISAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA. AS CAROLINE
MENTIONED EARLIER HIM HEARING
VISIT CALIFORNIA MARKETS THE
STATE AS A WORLD CLASS
DESTINATION. CAL TRAVEL ON THE
OTHER HAND ENGAGES WITH ALL OF
YOU AND THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROTECT AND ENSURE A THRIVING
INDUSTRY. OUR MEMBERS INCLUDE
DESTINATIONS LODGING
ATTRACTIONS AIRPORTS AIRLINES
TRANSPORTATION COMPANIES AND
OTHER SMALL BUSINESSES THAT.
ARE RELATED TO THE TOURISM
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA. AS
PREVIOUSLY TO OUR INDUSTRY HAS
LOST OVER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
JOBS SINCE FEBRUARY- A DRASTIC
REDUCTION FROM THE ONE POINT
TWO MILLION JOBS TOURISM
PROVIDED CALIFORNIANS PRIVATE
PRIOR TO PUT IT NINETEEN. MANY
OF THESE JOBS AS THE OTHERS
HAVE TESTIFIED WILL NOT COME
BACK ONCE WE ARE OUT OF THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY. VISIT
CALIFORNIA'S REVENUE WHICH IS
FUNDED BY PRIVATE BUSINESSES
THROUGH A SELF IMPOSED
ASSESSMENT BASED ON INCOME HAS
BEEN REDUCED TO MORE THAN HALF.
THIS IS WHY CAL TRAVEL ON
BEHALF OF IS A CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH SENATOR
MCGUIRE. AND OTHER TOURISM
TOURISM CHAMPIONS IN THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY INCLUDING BOTH OF
YOU AND MANY OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES- TO HELP PRIORITIZE
A FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION FOR VISIT
CALIFORNIA'S MARKETING EFFORTS.
THROUGH EITHER ABOUT BUDGET
ALLOCATION OR A STIMULUS
PACKAGE. THIS FUNDING WOULD
AUGMENT VISIT CALIFORNIAS
CAMPAIGN LETTING TRAVELERS KNOW
THE CALIFORNIA DESTINATIONS ARE
PRIORITIZING THEIR HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND TO PROMOTE BEST
PRACTICES FOR RESPONSIBLE
TRAVEL ACROSS ALL SECTORS. I
THINK CALIFORNIANS TRAVELING
AGAIN WILL ENABLE OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES TO REOPEN. GET
WORKERS BACK TO THEIR JOBS AND
ULTIMATELY HELP JUMPSTART A
QUICK RECOVERY OF OUR ECONOMY.
WE NOTICED WORKS BECAUSE WE
THOUGHT AND ACTION AFTER THE
SEPTEMBER ELEVEN ATTACKS
IMMEDIATELY AFTER NINE ELEVEN
GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS MADE A ONE
TIME ALLOCATION TO VISIT
CALIFORNIA THAT FUELED A MULTI
TIERED IN STATE AND DRIVE
MARKET CAMPAIGN. DESIGNED TO
GIVE CALIFORNIANS THE
CONFIDENCE TO REDISCOVER OUR
GREAT STATE. THE CAMPAIGN WAS
SUCCESSFUL IN STATE TRAVEL
JUMPED 10% IN 200-012-2000 TWO
AND TOURISM WAS ONE OF THE
FASTEST AND STREETS TO RECOVER.
IF GIVEN AN ALLOCATION TODAY IT
IS ANTICIPATED THAT WAS A
CALIFORNIA CAN GENERATE TEN
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
REVENUE TO CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND ADDITIONAL STATE AND LOCAL
TAX REVENUE. THIS ONE TIME
FUNDING WOULD BE AN IMPACTFUL
DOWN PAYMENT TO HELP CALIFORNIA
RECOVER. FROM THE DIRE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF FOR THE NINETEEN.
EVERY DOLLAR SPENT BY TRAVELER
POWERS OKAY OUR LOCAL COUNTY
COMMUNITIES MANY TIMES OVER.
FOR EXAMPLE THE TAXES PAID BY
HOTEL AND VACATION RENTAL
GUESTS DIRECTLY POWER LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
FORTY SIX CITIES RELY ON
TRANSIENT OCCUPANCY TAX
REVENUES TO COVER AT LEAST 30%
OF THEIR OVERALL GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES. ASIDE FROM THIS
CRITICAL FUNDINGTHE
LEGISLATURE CAN SUPPORTER
STRUGGLING INDUSTRY AND FEW
OTHER WAYS. WITH THE GOT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UNABLE TO
COME TO A CONSENSUS AND
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL RELIEF WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE STATE LEVEL
SUPPORT BUSINESSES SHOULDERING
THE COSTS OF ACQUIRING PP. AND
ENHANCED CLEANING AND
SANITIZATION PROTOCOL. ANOTHER
PLACE OF SUPPORT WOULD BE TO
OFFER A TEMPORARY TAX CREDIT TO
CALIFORNIANS ONCE IT'S SAFE TO
REALLY PICK UP TRAVEL TO
INCENTIVIZE DOMESTIC BUSINESS
AND LEISURE TRAVEL AND STATE.
ONCE WE'VE SEEN. OUR COUNTIES
PROGRESS FURTHER IN A TIERED
SYSTEM. THE TAX CREDIT WOULD
WORTH 50% OF QUALIFIED TRAVEL
EXPENSES FOR A LIMITED TIME
PERIOD. QUALIFIED TRAVEL
EXPENSES WOULD INCLUDE ANY-EXPENSE OVER FIFTY DOLLARS AND
HURDLE TRAVELING IN CALIFORNIA
AWAY FROM HOME WITH LANGUAGE TO
EXPLICITLY REFERENCE EXPENSES
RELATED TO MEALS. LODGING
RECREATION TRANSPORTATION
MUSEUM OR ENTERTAINMENT
BUSINESS MEETINGS OR EVENTS AND
FUEL. DETAILS I CAN SHARE WITH
STAFF. FINALLY WE NEED TO
LEGISLATORS HELP ADVOCATING FOR
THE FEE FREE OPENING OF
BUSINESS MEETINGS WHICH WAS
DISCUSSED PRETTY. PRETTY
BROADLY BY JOE DALLESANDRO
EARLIER IN HEARING- SPEAKING TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO US DURING
HIS PRESENTATION WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON STANDARDS BOTH FOR BUSINESS
MEETINGS ON A SMALLER SCALE AND
CONVENTIONS AND TRADE SHOWS.
BUT WE NEED APPROVAL AND
GUIDANCE AND A CLEAR INDICATION
OF WHEN WE CAN BRING BACK THIS
IMPORTANT SEGMENT OF THE TRAVEL
INDUSTRY IN ORDER TO PRESERVE
BUSINESS THAT TAKES YEARS TO
SECURE PLAN AND EXECUTE. AS IT
IS WE ARE LOSING BUSINESS TO
OTHER STATES WHO ARE HOSTING
EVENTS WITH ALCOHOL BREAKS.
INDIANAPOLIS FOR EXAMPLE HOSTED
EIGHTEEN EVENTS IN FORTY DAYS
WITH NO EXHIBITED INCREASE IN
CASES AND ONE OF THE EVENTS
HOSTED. WAS ABOUT NINE THOUSAND
PEOPLE. MARKETING FROM
INDIANAPOLIS ACTUALLY IS
TALKING ABOUT HOW THE ****
DRIVABLE AND THERE ARE
CAPTURING OUR OUR BUSINESS
RIGHT NOW AS WE SPEAK AND TO.
DR PANTS POINT EARLIER- BECAUSE
THEY'RE ABLE TO MEET NOW AND
HAVE BEEN MEETING NOW THEY'RE
ABLE TO SECURE BUSINESS FOR
FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
REALLY WANT TO KEEP THAT
BUSINESS FROM. GOING AWAY
FOREVER I SAW AN EXAMPLE- ONE
OF OUR- MEMBERS SHOWED US A
CONTRACT THAT WAS CANCELED. FOR
FALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT WAS
BOOKED IN- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
LONG LEAD TIME THAT'S NEEDED TO
KEEP THAT. BUSINESS AND STATE
ANYTHING THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO
TO EASE THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS AND ENCOURAGE
ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIANS TO
TRAVEL AGAIN WILL GO A LONG
WAY. TOWARD REPAIRING ARE
DEVASTATED TOURISM ECONOMY I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN FEELING A LACK OF
SUPPORT AND- IS WE'RE TOLD THAT
WE CAN'T OPEN BUT WE'RE NOT
GIVEN ANY- STOP GAPS- FOR
EXAMPLE WISCONSIN JUST MOVE
BACK IN THEIR RE OPENING. 27%
CAPACITY FOR INDOOR GATHERINGS.
BUT THEN THE GOVERNOR TURNED
AROUND AND HE ALLOCATED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
TOURISM INDUSTRY TO HELP KEEP
BUSINESSES THE FLOW. SO IF
WE'RE GONNA HAVE OUR HANDS TIED
WE DO NEED THAT FINANCIAL
SUPPORT AND ENGAGEMENT. I THINK
THE LEGISLATORS ON A REALLY
GREAT JOB OF SUPPORTING THE
WORKERS AND WE SAW A LOT OF
BILLS. GET PASSED THIS YEAR
THEY DO PROTECT WORKERS AND WE
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO WORKERS. TO
GO BACK TO WORK BUT IF
BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING. AND
THEY'VE SHUT DOWN FOREVER THAT
WORK GOES AWAY- THAT BEING SAID
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE WORK. OF REVIVING OUR
INDUSTRY WITH YOU AND ADVANCING
OUR SHARED GOAL OF JUMPSTARTING
OUR STATE'S ECONOMY. IN THE
WAKE OF THE CURRENT ADDRESS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
AGAIN SOME SPECIFIC ASKS THAT I
THINK- MAKE IT EASIER FOR US
TO. HOW CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
DAN GORDON CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE GORDON BURTCH
BREWING COMPANY.
GERMAN AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY HAVE A LITTLE
PRESENTATION I LIKE TO BRING UP.
YOU HAVE YEAH. THOSE ARE MY
THIS IS JUST THE NEXT SLIDE- OR
THIS YEAR OKAY LARRY OUR DO I
THAT'S ME OF THIRTY TWO YEARS
AGO WAS WHEN WE OPEN UP IN PALO
ALTO ALL RIGHT OR NICHE WAS
THREE RESTAURANTS WE ARE. GILT
EIGHT INCOME. THIRTEEN TOTALED
SELLING OTHER RESTAURANT
COMPANY DUE TO YOU HOUSE. THE
COMPANY THAT ACQUIRED US
CONTINUE OPEN UP TO THIRTY
EIGHT NATIONWIDE WITH ANOTHER
FOUR. IN THE ACTION NOW FIVE IN
TAIWAN CURRENTLY THERE'S ONE IN
CALIFORNIA. SEVEN IN THE U. S.
FIVE A TAIWAN. IT'S GONNA BE
KIND OF INTERESTING STAT-
OBVIOUSLY FINANCIAL TURMOIL
FROM COVE IT IS TAKEN DOWN SO
MANY RESTAURANTS AND WERE ONE
OF THE- FATALITIES BUT I BUILT
A BREWERY IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN. AND LIKELY THAT IS BEEN
THE SAVING GRACE FOR ME MY
FAMILY AND MY COMPANY. THE
RECORD FOR A DUTY COVE IT IT'S
VERY SOMEONE AND- WE UP WE'RE
IN THEIR WE HAVE FOR RESTAURANT
LOOKING AND HER. EITHER A SHUT
DOWN NO DRAFT THERE. ALL THE
STATE I AGREED GARLIC YOU MAY
BE FAMILIAR WITH THEM.
THEREAFTER SOME OF IMPORT FOOD
NOW. THEY THEY DON'T EXIST
RIGHT AFTER WE DON'T I WAS.
GOING ON LIFE SPORTS OF THE
SPORTS IN IS A FROM SPONSOR FLY.
AND THERE THERE'S A WHOLE
SUPPLIES ANDIN A THAT. THAT IS
LACKING HER FROM THE- ARE
REPRESENTATIVE HOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE OUT OF BUSINESS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT DELIVERING ANY
GOODS- ON SALE THERE'S NO DRAFT
AS YOUR BUSINESS AND
RESTAURANTS RESTAURANTS JUST
ARE LIMITED TO THE VOLUME THEY
THEY'RE ABLE TO- TO SELL SO
THEIR ONLY USING PACKAGE BEER.
SO THE BREEZE LIKE SOME OF OURS
THAT RELY DROP YOUR BUSINESS
ANYWHERE FROM 3250% OF THE
VOLUME. ARE LOSING OUT ON THE
SALES. AND THEN YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY CONTRACT DURING PLANTS
WHICH ARE BUSINESSES 90%
CONTRACT BRINGS OUT OF IN ORDER
ANY TRAFFIC THERE SO. THAT'S
THAT'S USUALLY 30% DROP AND NOT
THE PRETTY COMMON AMONGST THE-
INDUSTRY. I WONDER THAT IN THE
IN THE IMPACT OF THE RESTAURANT
COLLEAGUES- AND I'M- STAYED IN
CONTACT. WITH ALL MY ALL I CAN
ALMOST RELATIONS IN THE REST
BUSINESS LIMóN. YEAH THERE A
LEAST THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET
THE NEED THE MONEY. THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO SIT. OF UP ON IT. THE
ONLY THING YOU DO THIS RIGHT
BACK WHICH IS A TERM I FOR
SINGLE RESTAURANT THERE. ARE
THEN YOU HAVE OF THE GUY OPEN%
CLOSE NOW DON'T THINK. ANYBODY
IN THE SIX OF WAY. OR THE STATE
SENATE OR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
REALIZES HOW PAINFUL AND
EXPENSIVE IT IS TO TURN OFF AND
OPEN THE FAUCET EVERY TIME. AND
THESE RESTRICTIONS OUT OF GONE
WHEN YOU HIRE YOUR STUFF BACK
IN THE TRIGGERMAN PUT AN
INVENTORY. WE'VE ALREADY
WRITTEN OFF TO LOWER LAYERS OF
INVENTORY IN THE INDUSTRY
THAT'S UNSUSTAINABLE THEY'RE
ALREADY OUT OF ACTION IT'S NOT
GONNA WORK. THEY IN TURN YOU
HAVE TO. PATTERSON GOT IS
ANOTHER PROBLEM BECAUSE WHEN
YOU START THIS OPENING CLOSING.
IT'S A CHICKEN LITTLE AFFECTED
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT IS WHAT WHAT
YOU'RE REALLY GOING TO DO. AND
THE LEADERSHIP IN SACRAMENTO IS
GIVING INCONSISTENT MESSAGES
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE COVERAGE
EXPERIENCE. AND BECAUSE OF THAT
IT'S RIPPLING THROUGH THE
TOURISM INDUSTRY. HOSPITALITY
AND THEN PARTICULARLY IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. AND WHEN
I'M REFERRING THE RESTAURANTS
ON TALKING MORE OR LESS ABOUT
FULL SERVICE RESTAURANTS. THAT
ARE THE HIGH PAYING JOBS THAT
REPRESENT INCOME. NOT THIS FAST
FOOD QUICK SERVE FIFTEEN DOLLAR
AN HOUR POSITIONS. ARJUN ARE
THE ONES THAT PEOPLE RELY ON
FOR THEIR EFFORT TO MAKE A
LIVING. SO THE ECONOMIC SHOCKS
TREMENDOUS WHEN YOU HAVE THESE
POSITIVE CASES. IF ONE PERSON
IN YOUR STAFF TEST POSITIVE
YOU'RE SHUTTING DOWN FOR THREE
DAYS. AND THAT'S A BIG ISSUE
AND A VERY COSTLY ONE FOR EVERY
RESTAURANT THAT EXPERIENCE IS
THAT. AND IT IT GENERALLY THE
ODDS ARE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
ONE PERSON ON YOUR STAFF. BUT I
HAVE A SOLUTION FOR THATCOMING
UP LATER ON. CORPORATION CANCEL
ALL OTHER LARGE EVENTS- YOU
DON'T HAVE. YOU HAVE COUNTY
LEVEL GOVERNANCE THAT IS
CONFLICTED. FOR INSTANCE AYE
AYE WEBER IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IT'S NOT OPEN. YEAH THE STATE
SAYS IT CAN OPEN SO WHY. WHY
CAN'T WE HAVE SOMETHING
CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT. OUR OUR
GOVERNMENTS TO ALLOW. FOR
BUSINESSES TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO AN TO
HAVE COMMON SENSE PREVAIL. WE
HAVE TO WITH ALREADY CENTER
THAT EMPLOYEES OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. THEY ARE DECIDING THE
FATE OF THE ENTIRE COUNTY RIGHT
NOW. THAT'S TERRIBLE YEAH
EVERYTHING ELSE SPORTING IN THE
UNIVERSE OF VENUES ARE CLOSED
STILL BARS. OF SPORTING BARS
WERE BARS TV IMPERIAL. BARGER
CLOSED WINERIES. PARK PARTIALLY
OPEN ON SMALL BRIEF NO TASTING
ROOMS THAT'S THE REVENUE. YOU
GO DOWN THE WHOLE LIST IS JUST
THE START OF A SCENARIO SO
THERE'S NO OPTION IN THE DAY.
FOR FULL SERVICE REST NOT TO
RESTAURANT OWNER RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT YOU CAN DO
TAKE THAT THAT PICTURE HOME.
MONEY IS. YOU HAVE A CHOICE
WILL CHOICES ARE BAY. OR
THINKING BY WAY THANK. I'M
REFERRING TO HOPING. THAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO COME
BECAUSE I'M NOT SCARED OFF FROM
FROM PATRONIZING RESTAURANT
THAT'S ALLOWED TO OPEN UP. FOR
OR PUTTING IN SUCH RESTRICTIONS
THAT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM
TO OPEN. YOU ALSO LOOK AT ALL
PROVIDING ART THAT'S A GREAT.
SOLUTION UP UNTIL NOW.
PSYCHOLOGICAL IN CALIFORNIA THE
MINUTE RANGE PEOPLE STOPPING
GOING OUT WITH CITY OUTSIDE TO
GO TO A RESTAURANT. AND IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO STAFF AN
OUTDOOR DINING ONLY SCENARIO TO
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT THE
WEATHER'S GOING TO BE A-
SCHEDULE THE PEOPLE SHOW UP AND
START SPRINKLING. NOBODY SITS
DOWN AND THEN HAVE THAT. LIKE I
SAID EARLIER ONE CASE OF
PROVIDENCE STAFF. IN THE BACK
OF THE HOUSE FORCES RESTAURANT
TO CLOSE SO- WELL IT'S HARD TO
THIS ONE ALREADY THIS IS NOW
DURING CERTAIN THE SCENARIO.
ARE YOU HAVE A SKILLED GROUP
OWNER PLUS ONE COOK IN THE
SERVER. SO THIS WOULD BE A
RESTAURANT TYPICALLY THAT HAS
INTERIOR SEATING FOUR HUNDRED A
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE. AND NO
LONGER HAVE THAT THEY'RE
DEALING WITH FALLOUT FOUR FIVE
TABLES OUT OF THE PARKLAND.
THEY HAVE A BILL THAT PARKER BY
THE WAY. AND I AM READY BUILT
PLEXIGLASS SHIELDING ON THEIR
SEEDING. TO ALLOW FOR INDOOR
DINING THAT WOULD SHUT DOWN.
FIVE MONTHS AGO SO THEY WON'T
SPEND A SMALL BUSINESS SPENDING
ALREADY TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
AT THE REQUEST. OF THE
GUIDELINES OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THEY'RE NOT
EVEN ABLE TO USE THAT SO IT'S
SOMETHING MONEY. S. AND
RECOVERABLE SO. 25% ENDORSING
AREA. YOU STILL HAVE ONE KIRK
ONE SERVER AND THERE'S CHANGE
BECAUSE YOU JUST DON'T. THE
VOTES. TWENTY FIVE PER. IS
TERRIBLE SO. CONSIDER THIS. 25%
SEATING CAPACITY IS EQUIVALENT
OF FLYING A SEVEN FORTY SEVEN
WITH ONE ENGINE. IT'S GOING TO
IT WON'T TAKE OFF BUT IT
CERTAINLY CRASH. AND THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE WHAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS GIVING US RIGHT
NOW. IN IF YOU SURVEYS SOME
OTHER STATES- PRINCES I CONTACT
MY- COLLEAGUE FRIEND ONCE
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED RESTAURANTS
THAT ARE IN TWENTY FIVE STATES
EAST. OF COLORADO. HE'S RUNNING
AT 94% SALES LEVELS WITH 80%
OCCUPANCY. NINE IF HE CAN DO
THAT WHY. AREN'T THE- LEADERS
OF CALIFORNIA MODELING OR
GUIDELINES AFTER THEIR- THIS IS
A DIRECT QUESTION AND THAT'S
THE QUESTION I WANT YOU TO
THINK BACK TO ALL YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN STATE IF THE
OTHER STATES CAN DO THIS
PROPERLY SAFELY AND BE ABLE TO
KEEP KEEP THE JOBS GOING AND
YOU CAN WOULD CHICAGO. SUBURBS
OF CHICAGO EVEN A LOOK AT
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE
RESTAURANTS ARE PACKED IN THERE
NOT BANG EARLY. THEY REALLY ARE
SO GIVE US 80% SEATING CAPACITY
AND YOU'LL SEE 99% OF LOCATIONS
OPEN LIKE MY BODY HAS BEEN IN
THE EAST COAST. SO WHAT IS
CALIFORNIA POLICY SO I'M LIKE
OTHER STATES THAT'S WHAT YOU
NEED TO. TAKE HOME TODAY THAT'S
MIND MY WISH THERE'S A WE HEARD
FROM TEACHERS THIS IS A TRUCK
ON HIS FIRST TOP OF THE DAY.
THAT TRUCK WOULD BEEN FULL IF
WE HAD- 99% OF THE RESTAURANTS
ON. TO RIGHT NOW I PERSONALLY
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED FROM THIS
BECAUSE I HAD A ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT MY
RESTAURANT CALLED. AND THIS IS
WHY OF THE MINE WAS ON THE
RIGHT. YEAH MCCORMACK AND
SCHMIDT SERVICE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TEN ELEVEN LOCATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY THEY YOU CAN
BUY EITHER ONE OF THOSE FOR
ZERO DOLLARS JUST ASSUME THE
LEASE AND THE LANDLORD TO BE
HAPPY TO DO THAT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY. NOBODY WANTS TO
OWN A RESTAURANT RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY THE FULL SERVICE
CATEGORY. SO IT'S DEVASTATING
HERE SOME WHAT YOU GUYS CAN DO
TO HELP FIRST. WE NEED TO HAVE
THE ABBOTT TEST PROVIDED FREE
OR AND OF REALLY LOW SUBSIDIZE
COSTS SO WE CAN TEST. THE
INDIVIDUAL SERVERS AND BACK OF
THE HEALTH PEOPLE BEFORE THEY
ENTER THE RESTAURANT TO GO TO
WORK. GIVE THEM THE FIFTEEN
MINUTE ADVANCE THE COMMANDER
SPIT IN THE CUP. IT'S ONLY 80%
ACCURATE. BUT IT'S- 20% OF THAT
INACCURACIES FALSE POSITIVES.
THEN YOU CAN SEND THAT PERSON
AFTER A FULL PC ARE ORIENTED
TESTING FACILITY. AND GET THEM
TESTED THOROUGHLY BUT THEY
WON'T COME TO WORK AND COST
CONTAINMENT. CROSS CONTAMINATE
THE REST OF THE STAFF. DELIVERY
SERVICES THIS A BIG DEAL RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE BEEN
PROGRAMMED INTO GRUBHUB UBER
EATS AND OTHER OTHER VENUES.
FOR DELIVERY SERVICES THEY'RE-
RIPPING OFF THE RESTAURANT
OWNERS. IF YOU GOT A CAPTAIN
215% THAT'S PLENTY REVENUE THEY
CAN GET IT BACK LATER ON WHEN
WE GO INTO FOUR CONDOMINIUM OR
1100% OPEN. BUT IN THE
MEANTIME. WE'RE YOU'RE GETTING
FEES UP 2406% FROM SOMEONE LIKE
ROB IT. OR DOORDASH IT'S
TERRIBLE. ALL RIGHT THIS IS THE
EASIER THING AND THIS IS FOR.
SAKE CAL WITH AND SACRAMENTO
IT'S THE MOST ABSURD THING IN
THE WORLD YOU HAVE THE HIGHEST
PAID RESTAURANT EMPLOYEES.
RAKING IN MORE MONEY THE GUIDE
TIPS THAN THEY EVER CARE ABOUT
AN HOURLY WAGE. AND IF YOU
GUARANTEE THEM TWENTY DOLLARS
MINIMUM WAGE AT A GALLERY
THAT'S REPORTED. TO THE STATE
THEN THAT'S FINE THEN DO LET US
CHARGE PAY THEM. SEVEN TO TEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR BUT NOT. NOT BE
WE'RE WE'RE ONE OF SEVEN STATES
IN THE UNITED STATES AT THE
DON'T HAVE A TO CREDIT FORTY
VERY OTHER STATES SEE THE LIGHT.
AND IT'S REALLY DEVASTATING SO
IF YOU WANT TO GET PEOPLE BACK
TO WORK. GIVE SOME BREATHING
ROOM TO THE RESTAURANT OWNERS
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE BE ABLE TO
COVER THOSE VARIABLE PASS AND
THAT'S ALL TRYING TO DO.
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT CAN EVER BE
ABLE TO CALL THE GOVERNOR FIX
GLASS OVER THE NEXT EIGHT NINE
MONTHS. UNTIL THERE'S A
VACCINE. SO IN THE MEANTME LET
US GET THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE
WILLING TO GO OUT TO. EAT HAVE
AN EXPERIENCE THAT ARE LOW
RISK- INDIVIDUALS TO ENJOY
THEIR LIVES. AND THE PERCENT
OCCUPANCY LEVEL WILL BE FINE
AND THEN START CHARGING THE
EMPLOYER. PAYROLL TAXES FOR
TIPS ON REVENUE OF MONEY. THAT
THEY NEVER SEE. SO YOU HAVE
TIPS CREDIT CARD FEES ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE- WE PAY
TAXES ON. THE RESTAURATEUR
THREE TAXES ON- THAT THEY DON'T
EVER SEE RECEIVE MONEY FOR IS
AN ADDED BURDEN COST. AND RIGHT
NOW. YOU KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT
50% LABOR COSTS FOR TO BE ABLE
RE OPENED WITH US. THE DOWNSIDE
OF THE SALES WE JUST DON'T HAVE
THE SALES VOLUME. CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS FULL SERVICE
RESTAURANTS ARE DOWN THIRTY
FIVE PERCENT. THAT THE LOT AND
THIS IS AS OF OCTOBER IT'S
RAMPING LITTLE BIT UP BUT IT'S
MOSTLY IN THE QUICK SERVICE
SECTOR. SO THE HIGH PAYING JOBS
ARE NOT THERE FOR THOSE PEOPLE
TO LEAVE AMERICA. MIND THREE
FOUR TAKEAWAYS AND I'M SORRY
DID WANT AN EXTRA ONE BUT-
THOSE ARE THE THINGS WE REALLY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO COME BALLOTS
BACK. AND THERE ARE A HUGE PART
OF OUR ECONOMY IT'S OVER 10% OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROPERTY. RIGHT
THANKS. THANK YOU MISTER GORE.
GREATER FROM. LOT DO. YEAH HALF
OF IT YES. OKAY ARE LET PRESENT
TODAY IS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AT RIDGE MALL
HOSPITALITY. PATEL.
THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I KEEP THIS BRIEF I
KNOW YOU ALL HAVE BEEN HERE FOR
A LONG TIME. MY NAME IS AT THE
TOWN AND THE CITY OF RIDGEMONT
HOSPITALITY BASED IN OAKLAND WE
ARE A FAMILY BUSINESS THAT
STARTED FORTY YEARS AGO- IS
WORKING AT THE FRONT DESK OF
THE HOTEL AND WE CURRENTLY OWN
SIX HOTELS. IN ALAMEDA AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTY I ALSO SERVE
AS A COMMISSIONER AND. PAST
YEAR OF MUSIC CALIFORNIA. OUR
HOTEL ARE LOCATED AS A MAIN
HE'S CLARA ALAMEDA COUNTY WERE
FOR TO SHUT DOWN AND LAST THREE
OPEN. TO LEISURE TRAVELER THE
CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN MOUNTED
AGAINST US EARLY ON IN DEPEND
ON ME FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OUR
FORTY YEAR HISTORY WE HAD TO
CLOSE ALL BUT ONE HOTEL. WE
HAVE TO COMPLETELY. OUR ENTIRE
BUSINESS MAKING SOME VERY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS LIKE
FOLLOWING OUR EMPLOYEES. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO BRINGING EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF THEM AS WE
GRADUALLY COVER AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY ALLOWS US TO OPEN FULLY.
WE ARE NOW OPEN THE NEW
SCREENING PROTOCOLS AND SAFETY
PROCEDURES TO PROTECT OUR TEAM
MEMBERS AND A HOTEL GUEST.
SAFETY OF OUR TEAM MEMBERS AND
OUR GUEST. HAS BECOME OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITY. OF THE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLAR JOB ECONOMY.
IN CALIFORNIA TWENTY NINE POINT
EIGHT BILLION WAS ON BY HOTELS.
AT THE STATE LEVEL HOTELS HAVE
BEEN INCREDIBLY HARD HIT WITH
FOR OCCUPANCY BOTTOMING AT 21%
BACK IN APRIL AND NOW HOW ARE
YOU CAN JUST ABOVE 50% THE
EARLY GLIMMERS OF RECOVERY
HAVING VERY UNEVEN WITH URBAN
AREAS LAGGING WAY BEHIND WILL
REGION'S. WE JUST OPENED A NEW
HOTEL IN DOWNTOWN OAKLAND SIX
MONTHS GO AND THE COME THE
CENTRAL BUSINESS DISTRICT HOTEL
BUSINESSES DECIMATED BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO NEW NOPE
INVENTIONS AND THAT IT'S NOT
OPEN FOR BUSINESS. IN THE SAN%
FRANCISCO BAY AREA FOR EXAMPLE
OUR OCCUPANCY RATES ARE DOWN
42% YEAR OVER YEAR AND REVENUE
SIDE DOWN BY 75% FOR US IN OUR
DOWNTOWN OAKLAND HOTEL.
OCCUPANCY IS EYEING LOW
TWENTIES TO MID TEENS AND I
BUSINESS IS DOWN BY 95% THE
PANDEMIC HAS DEVASTATED
CALIFORNIA'S TOURISM INDUSTRY
ERASING TEN CONSECUTIVE YEARS
OF GROWTH. THE REASON HE'S ONE
OF THE MOST RESILIENT. ECONOMIC
SECTORS AND IF TO RESERVE
ANYTHING FOR ANY SIGNS. DURING
CRISES IT'S VITAL. IT TOOK TWO
YEARS LEFT FOR THE TRAVEL
INDUSTRY TO RECOVER FROM THE
GREAT RECESSION COMPARED TO THE
REST OF THE ECONOMY. NOW WE ARE
FACING LOSSES OF NEARLY EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND A TIMELINE
DECLARING AT LEAST FOUR YEARS
TO REBUILD THE INDUSTRY BACK TO
WHERE WE WORK BE PAN AM.
CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIANS CAN
SUPPORT OUR OWN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WE'VE DONE IT BEFORE.
FALLING MANY OTHER PRICES IN
THE STATE'S HISTORY INCLUDING
NINE ELEVEN AND THE DESTRUCTIVE
I LIFE. BY FIRE SEASONS OF THE
PAST FIVE YEARS. THE TOURISM
INDUSTRY WAS ABLE TO BAND
TOGETHER THROUGH JOINT SB
NATION PROMOTIONS TO BRING
TRAVELERS BACK TO OUR STATE AND
BILLS BACKED ECONOMIES. AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS. I THINK
THE BOARD AND THE MARKETING
TEAM AT VISIT CALIFORNIA AND
REALLY ALL OF OUR DESTINATION
PARTNERS ACROSS THE STATE
RECOGNIZED TWO REASONS FOR OUR-
TO HELP SMALL BUSINESSES NOT
JUST THAT HE DIDN'T SEND THE
DISNEYLAND. BUT BUSINESSES LIKE
MINE AND OTHER SMALL MOM AND
POP SHOPS. CALIFORNIA'S WORK IS
CRITICAL TO GROWING OUR TOURISM
ECONOMY THAT IS ONE OF
CALIFORNIA STRONG GUEST
ECONOMIC ENGINES. WE KNOW THESE
MARKETING PROGRAMS WORK WITH A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF
INSPIRING TRAVELERS. WE
GENERATED OR FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN INCREMENTAL SPENDING
IN THE STATE. STATE. NEARLY
TWENTY THOUSAND TOURISM
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE STATE
INVEST IN THESE MARKETING
EFFORTS. A MARKETING THE NEW
YORK REFERENDUM FAST JUST A
YEAR LAST YEAR WITH 95% IN
FAVOR THE HIGHEST APPROVAL
RATINGS IN THE ORGANIZED SINCE
THE ORGANIZATION WAS CONCEIVED.
THAT MANDATE SHOWS INCREDIBLE
UNITY BEHIND THE CALIFORNIA
BRANCH THAT HAS BEEN BUILT AS
WELL AS DATA THAT SUPPORTS HOW
WELL THE MARKETING WORKS.
CALIFORNIA'S TOURISM INDUSTRY
HAS GIVENSO MUCH BACK TO THE
STATE AS A WHOLE AND NOW IN OUR
TIME OF NEED IT'S TIME FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO REINVEST INTO
GETTING THIS INDUSTRY BACK ON
ITS FEET. CALIFORNIA HOTELS ARE
PREPARED WITH CLEAN AND SAFE
PROCEDURES TO REVEAL INDIVIDUAL
MEETINGS. THAT WILL RETURN
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES TO WORK
WITH THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY FOR
A STATE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY
AND REPLENISH. MUNICIPAL
COFFERS WITH MUCH NEEDED TAX
REVENUE. OUR STATE SHOULD RE
OPEN OUR HOTELS WITH INDIVIDUAL
MEETINGS FOR MONTHS AFTER TO
RESTORE ALLOWED TO RETURN
WITHOUT INCIDENT. WE'VE BEEN
OPERATING FOR THE LAST FEW
MONTHS WE'VE ALL THE SAFETY
MEASURES AND HAVE. YOU SEE
GREAT SUCCESS. SO WHY NOT ALLOW
THE MEETING SMALL MEETINGS TO
COME BACK JUST LIKE WHAT WE ARE
DOING HERE TODAY. THE ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS ARE TAKING THEIR TOLL
ON EMPLOYEES THEY INDUSTRY AND
CD'S SOURCES I EMPLOYEES WANT
TO COME BACK TO WORK DELEGATING
FOR US TO START THE MEETING THE
BANQUET. AND CATERING.
CALIFORNIA HAS LOST TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND JOBS
IN TWENTY TWENTY DIETED PLEA AS
A RESULT OF LACK OF MEETINGS IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR EVERY MONTH
MEETINGS ARE DELAYED CALIFORNIA
WE LOSE FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
OUTPUT. THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
V. THIS THE LOSS OF CURRENT AND
FUTURE LEADING TO OTHER
DESTINATIONS WHICH DIRECTLY
IMPACTS OUR EMPLOYEES OUR
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY AND OUR
TAX REVENUES. CALIFORNIA HOTEL
AND LODGING ASSOCIATION HAS
ISSUED STATE WIDE GUIDELINES
FOR INDIVIDUAL MEETINGS.
SUPPORTED BY CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
AND CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH STANDARDS. CHML
ISSUED IS CLEAN AND SEVEN
GUIDELINES APRIL THIRTY TWENTY
TWENTY. PROVIDING TIME FOR
STATE HOTELS TO ESTABLISH A
HEALTHY HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTOCOLS JDM PLOYS AND THE
CHOIR PROTECTIVE GEAR AND
SANITARY EQUIPMENT. OUR STATE
LODGING ASSOCIATION YOU ANY
RIGHT PROVIDED FREE PP TWO
HOTEL- OF MEMBERS WHO CAN'T OF
FORTY THREE WAS A GREAT EFFORT
ON CHIRLA. AND EACH GENERALLY.
WE ARE GOING TO NEED SOME. AND
STATE HELD A FEW TO ALLOW
HOOKED TO THE PLAN FOR INDIA
MEETINGS. MANY OF THE STATE'S
HOTELS HAVE SAFELY HOSTING
LEISURE TRAVELERS WITHOUT
RESTRICTIONS ON OCCUPANCY AND
WITHOUT MAJOR INCIDENT SINCE
THE STATE ALLOWED TO RESUME DO
YOU MEAN JUNE. OTHER STATES ARE
ABLE TO STAY FREE HOST MEETINGS
INCLUDING DEFINITION CITIES
LIKE ORLANDO DALLAS SEATTLE SAN
ANTONIO AND LAS VEGAS WHICH
RECENTLY APPROVED HOSTING
MEETINGS UP TO ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE. WE NEED CONSISTENT
MESSAGING- GOING BACK TO.
SENATOR CHIU ASKING THREE
THINGS WE NEED TO SYNC
CONSISTENT MESSAGING AYE DADDY
AYE MY BUSINESS IS IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND THEN THE STATE OF
DECLARES ORANGE COUNTY DOESN'T
COMPLY WITH THAT AND THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN RULE IT DOESN'T HELP
IT DOESN'T HELP THE TRAVELERS
AND YOU DON'T HEAR THE
CONSISTENT MESSAGE AND THE
MESSAGE THERE ARE STATE IS OPEN
FOR BUSINESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SEE MY- WE
APPRECIATE THIS I THINK THIS IS
BEEN A VERY THOROUGH-
INFORMATIONAL HEARING I KNOW
I'VE LEARNED A LOT WE HAVE LOTS
OF NOTES WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
A FINAL COMMENT. THANK YOU FOR
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THE HEARING AND I NEGLECTED TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON BEING
APPOINTED TO OF THE COMMITTEE'S
CHAIR. I HOPE TO BE SEEING.
MORE OF YOU ON THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. FOR I KNOW I HEARD
MANY MANY TIMES THROUGHOUT THIS
PRESENTATION- NOT ONLY
CONSISTENT GUIDELINES AND
MESSAGING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IS VITAL- US WITH- MEETINGS
SMALLER MEETINGS- ENCOURAGING
LEISURE TRY TRAVEL OR SOME OF
THE TAKE AWAYS BUT THEN ALSO
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC. REQUEST
LIKE THE DMV CREDIT OR OTHER
CREDITS I THINK. WE HAVE A LOT
TO GO BACK WITH AND- FOR SOME
OF YOU WHO DID IT EXTENSIVE
PRESENTATIONS THANK YOU AND
WE'D BE HAPPY TO HAVE A COPY IF
WE DON'T ALREADY. SOME OF YOU
MIGHT NOT KNOW BUT I'M A FORMER
A CLASSROOM TEACHER AND I TAKE
LOTS OF NOTES AND LIKE TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THINGS WELL
JUST HAD WITH KIND OF A HAPPY
STORY IF I COULD. YOU HAVE TO
BE WE HAVE PEOPLE UP THERE I'M
SORRY. OKAY BUT MEMBERS OF THE
CULT COOKED THE PUBLIC SORRY IF
I DIDN'T FORGET ABOUT YOU I BUT
I DID I GUESS. A MOMENT HERE
YEAH SO YOU THANK YOU I TOOK IT
DOWN THERE I. THANK YOU FROM
WAY UP HERE OKAY THAT'S JUST BE
VERY BRIEF A JURY DESMOND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION A TRAVEL
ORGANIZATIONS THE CTO. AROUND
TWENTY YEARS REPRESENTS
NATIONAL STATE AND REGIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS OF TRAVEL ADVISORS
TRAVEL AGENTS AND TOUR
OPERATORS AND A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS JUST TO ADD VERY
BRIEFLY WHAT IS. NOT LAW THERE
ARE SEVERAL THOUSAND TRAVEL
ADVISOR COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE 98% OF THEM ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES. TWO THIRDS OF THEM
ARE WOMEN. OWNED UP. NO PERCENT
OF THEM UP HAVE LOST 6% OF
THEIR BUSINESS WE SEE THE LONG
TERM TREND THE PREVIOUS OF
WITNESSES AND GROUPS I DID TALK
ABOUT. EVEN THOUGH THE BUSINESS
ENDED IN MARCH THEY HAVE BEEN
VERY BUSY WITHOUT FEES PAYING
BACK THE REFUNDS AND ARRANGING
FOR THE CANCELLATIONS OF TRIPS
ETCETERA ETCETERA. AND UP AND
THAT CONTINUES WE SEE THE LONG
TERM PATH IS A VERY LONG TERM
PASSED SO WE SUPPORT YOU KNOW
THE GUIDANCE THAT WAS TALKED
ABOUT AND YOU WERE MENTIONING
IN THE WRAP UP AS WELL. IF
THERE WERE TWO SPECIFIC ACTS
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN ADDRESSED
BEFORE V. AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CONSIDERS EXTENSION
OF FINANCIAL RELIEF LIKE THE
CARERS ACT TO ENSURE THAT. ANY
HELP THAT'S OUT THERE FOR THE
AIRLINES IT'S BEEN THIRTY TWO
BILLION IN THE PAST THAT IT
INCLUDES TICKET AGENCIES
SPECIFICALLY WITHIN THE
POTENTIAL RECIPIENTS OF THE
FUNDING AND THEN ALSO. AS THE
FEDERAL U. S. TREASURY
IDENTIFIES- HOPEFULLY OBTAIN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
KINDS OF FINANCIAL HELP THAT
CAN BE PROVIDED SO THAT THEY
ARE INCLUDED IN THAT AS WELL
WITH LONG TERM RELIEF AND PAY
BACK OPTIONS BECAUSE OF THE
SITUATION RENT. AND SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS OF ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WORKING TOGETHER TO
COMPRISE THE TOURISM INDUSTRY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
FOR EVERYBODY WHO SAID I WAS
JUST GOING TO DO A DISNEY STORY
BUT- I WILL IN THE HOUSE SO
THIS THIS IS GROWING UP IN
FULLERTON CALIFORNIA I ACTUALLY
WORKED AT DISNEY WHEN I WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL AS MANY MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS. BUT I COME FROM A
FAMILY OF TEN SOUL DO A RIDDLE
AND YOU SEE IF YOU CAN FIGURE
IT OUT. SO STARTED FROM THE TOP
OF THE NAMES OF MY FAMILY- YEAH
ARE A CINDY RICKY SUSIE LARRY
CARE AND SHARE AND- LYNETTE.
BILLY JOHNSON. AND MARK. SO MY
NAME COME FROM. THE MICKEY
MOUSE. AND IT IS TRUE AND MY
MIDDLE NAME TO. SHARE DARLEY
ANYHOW WE GOT SOME SMILES WILL
DO THE BEST WE CAN TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS BECAUSE I TO-
WE WANT TO GET NOT ONLY YOUR
EMPLOYEES BACK WE DON'T WANT TO
GET THE DOORS OPEN AND WE WANT
TO GET BACK TO WORK. THANK YOU
SO MUCH.